AND SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
ON EDUCATION WILL COME TO ORDER
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
BASS COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY WE HAVE TWO MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATOR
GLAZERS AND SENATOR MEN AND
CAPITOL ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
HERE WITH ME OUR SENATORS
CORTESE LAYERED MCGUIRE A CHOI
BOGUE AND PAN WELCOME MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. IN
PERSON AND REMOTELY. WE'LL HAVE
WITNESSES WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY THEY ARE JESSICA
HOLMES FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BROOKS ALLEN FROM THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION. AMY
LEAVE FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SHELLY BAER
MONTEZ FROM THE CAMPBELL UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT. RICHARD BURKE
BARRERA FROM THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT CHRIS
EVANS FROM THE NATOMAS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. DAVID SHAPIRO
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION LORI
EASTERLING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
INTERESTING BROWN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WELCOME TO YOU ALL
ALSO. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS YOU PLEASE MOVE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK BY ACID
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT UNMUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. OR IT PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOUR DAD. WANTS RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. THAT EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. AND WE HAVE A NEW
ACCESS CODE. DONNA FOR A THIRD.
SORRY WE HAVE NO ACCESS CODE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE OR SUB COMMITTEE WEBSITE
OUR NEW ACCESS CODE IS NINE OH
NINE. EIGHT SIX FOUR NINE AGAIN
NINE OH NINE EIGHT SIX FOUR
NOT. FOR TODAY'S HEARING WILL
BE WE WILL BE HEARING ALL OF
THE PANELS OF WITNESSES. ON THE
AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE'VE
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES WE
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE TOPICS. ON
TODAY'S AGENDA PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM AT ALL TIMES DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO ISDISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND%
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. OKAY WE
OVERSIGHT HEARING. WELCOME TO
TODAY'S HEARING ON THE VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC OF THE
GOVERNOR'S SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL
PLAN. THIS PLAN PROPOSES TO
PROVIDE TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
REOPEN ALMOST IMMEDIATELY OR AS
SOON AS THEIR REGIONAL CASE
RATES FALL BELOW A CERTAIN
LEVEL. THE GOVERNOR'S ASKING
THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE EARLY
ACTION TO APPROVE THIS
PROPOSAL. THIS HEARING PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
EDUCATION POLICY AND FISCAL
COMMITTEES TO JOINTLY DISCUSS
AND CONSIDER THE MERITS OF THE
SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL PLAN. THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PLAN IS A POSITION A POSITIVE
STEP FORWARD IN ENSURING THAT
EVERY CHILD REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY MAY LIVE OR BE ENROLLED IN
SCHOOL. HAS THE ABILITY TO
RECEIVE QUALITY INSTRUCTION
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. STUDENTS
LEARN AND PERFORM AT THEIR BEST
IN PERSON AND PARENTS ACROSS
THE STATE ARE ANXIOUS TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR KIDS DON'T FALL
FURTHER BEHIND. TO THE
PANDEMIC. I SHARE THE
GOVERNOR'S GOAL OF RETURNING TO
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AS
QUICKLY AND SAFELY AS POSSIBLE.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. BUT DO HAVE
SOME SPECIFIC CONCERNS AROUND
THE PLANT. THE PURPOSE OF
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THE COMPONENTS
AND REQUIREMENTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. AFFECT THE
RE OPENING PLANS A VERY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SUPPORT DISTRICTS
THAT CHOOSE TO RE OPEN UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL AND ASSIST
EDUCATORS IN BEST SERVING OUR
YOUNGEST AND MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. THE STATE SAFE
SCHOOLS FOR ALL PLAN IS VERY
BOLD WELL IT HELPS TO SCHOOLS
OPEN SAFELY. WE DON'T KNOW WE
HOPE TO FIND THAT OUT TODAY.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE WITNESSES
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
ALL OF YOU AND AT THIS TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK SENATOR
LAYERED IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKING
OPENING REMARKS. CENTER LAYERED
I WOULD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR. THE END OF. THE
CHAIR DID A GREAT JOB OF
OUTLINING OUTLINING THE- THE
PROPOSAL AND SOME OF THE ISSUES
IN FRONT OF US AND I JUST WANT
pTHAT DON'T. ALL AGREE ON ABOUT
THIS ISSUE. IN PERSON EDUCATION
IS PREFERABLE TO ONLINE
EDUCATION DISTANCE LEARNING
THEIR NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES THAT HAVE
FALLEN THROUGH THE CRACKS IN A
DISTANCE LEARNING WHETHER IT'S
OUR KIDS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
HOMELESS KIDS FOSTER KIDS. ARE
DOES IT DEPEND ON SCHOOLS FOR
NUTRITION OR KIDS THAT ARE
CAUGHT ON THE WRONG SIDE OF THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE AND HAVING SAID
THAT THE QUESTION WHICH WAS
ALSO STATED BY THE CHAIR IS HOW
WE REACHED OPEN SCHOOLS SAFELY.
AND I THINK THERE ARE JUST A
FEW PRINCIPLES AND THAT WE
SHOULD CONSIDER. OF THE FUNDING
IN THE STRUCTURE OF THE
SCHOOL'S REOPENING GRANT SURE
SHOULD THE SHOULD SUPPORT ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN PRIORITIZE
EQUITY THE PLAN SHOULD PROVIDE
A CLEAR COHERENT PATH FOR
SCHOOLS TO RE OPEN WHILE
GRANTING FLEXIBILITY SO
DISTRICTS CAN MEET THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. FACING EACH SCHOOL
COMMUNITY. RULES MUST BE SO
FIRST. TEACHERS AND STAFF
SCHOOLS NEED CONSISTENT
STANDARDS AND RELIABLE
SUPPORTERS AND THERE NEEDS TO
BE SUPPORT FOR SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE ALREADY REOPENED AND I
THINK THAT TODAY. IT'S AGAINST
THOSE PRINCIPLES AND THOSE
NEEDS WILL HEAR THE TESTIMONY
AND HOPE TO MAKE PROGRESS ON
WHAT WE THINK IS A GOOD PLAN
FOR SAFE WE RE OPENING SCHOOLS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR LAYERED. I WOULD WE
HAVE ANY OTHER SENATORS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT AND
REMOTELY I DON'T SEE ANY RAISED
HANDS SO WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
GET STARTED. BUT BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR SPEAKERS I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE THE PUBLIC
WANTING TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL
IN NOW. PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL
FREE NUMBER. 844-291-6364 WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE ACCESS
CODE NINE OH NINE. EIGHT SIX
FOUR NINE NOW LET'S HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST PRESENTER JESSICA
HOLMES WHO IS AN ASSISTANT
PROGRAM BUDGET MANAGER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WELCOME
MISS HOLMES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AT. CARE I AM FROM FINANCED.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A- WHILE
CHILDREN ARE LESS LIKELY TO GET.
THREE THREE LOW WHO VOTED
NINETEEN ADULT BIRTHDAY REALIZE
HAVE NOT BEEN ANY BLESSED IT IS
BY THE PENDEK. A MAJORITY OF
THE STATE SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
HAVE NOT HAD ACCESS IN PERSON
INSTRUCTOR AND LAST MARCH. WITH
PROFOUND IMPLICATIONS WALDRON
LEARNING HOW. ALL NATIONAL WELL
BEING. FOR EXAMPLE I KNOW THEM
WHAT THE REPORT ON THE FEDERAL
BUDGET CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND PREVENTION REPORTED
THAT NATIONALLY. TION OF MENTAL
HEALTH REALLY IS IT A LITTLE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT CHILDREN
AGED FIVE TO ELEVEN YEARS. AND
ADOLESCENTS AGE TWELVE TO
SEVENTEEN YEARS INCREASED BY
APPROXIMATELY 24% AND 31%
RESPECTIVELY COMPARED WITH
THOSE IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
ANECDOTAL REPORTS HER SCHOOL
OFFICIALS INDICATE SIMILAR
POTENTIAL NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
STUDENT LEARNING AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
COMPOUNDING THESE ISSUES THE
LACK OF INTERPERSONAL
INTERACTIONS RESULTING FROM THE
PANDEMIC ALSO MAKES IT LESS
LIKELY THAT CHILDREN WILL FEED
THE SERVICES NECESSARY TO
MITIGATE AND MANAGE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC.
BECAUSE OF THIS IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT CHILDREN HAVE
THE OPTION TO RETURNED IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AND SOON AND
IF THEY FLEE IF POSSIBLE.
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS OF MORE THAN SIX
POINT SEVEN BILLION CAN ABLE
SCHOOL CAN MITIGATE CODED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IMPACT ON
STUDENTS AND STAFF. AND
PROVIDED GOLD GUIDANCE AND
RESOURCES TO MAXIMIZE STATE AND
KIRSTEN INSTRUCTION TO STUDENTS.
HOWEVER AS THE PANDEMIC
PROGRESSES AND AS THE SCIENCE
AND UNDERSTANDING OF KOBE
NINETEEN INCREASES WE MUST BE
ADAPTABLE TO OUR CIRCUMSTANCES
AND SEIZE ON OPPORTUNITIES AND
THE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC
HONORED CHILDREN. WHICH IS NOT
IN THE ADMINISTRATION UPDATED
AT TALKING THANK YOU GOTTEN FOR
AND PERCENT TRACTION
RECOGNITION THAT MASKING SOCIAL
DISTANCING CO HOARDING AND
OTHER KEY MEASURES. ARE
EXCELLENT SAFEGUARDS TO
MINIMIZE MINIMIZE VIRUS SPREAD
IN CAN OFFER PATHWAYS TO SCHOOL
RE OPENING EVEN IN COMMUNITIES.
ARE RIGHT TO COMMUNITIES BETTER
HIGH. CASH ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
KEEN TO. IMPROVING OUR INTEREST
TO. TOOLS AND PUTTING HEALTH
SAFEGUARD IN PLACE. MAKING IT
EASIER FOR EDUCATION AND
STREETERS TO GET ONE ON ONE
GUIDANCE FROM PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS. AN ACCESS CODE
NINETEEN TESTING. AND MAKING IT
EASIER FOR SCHOOL STAFF AND
COMMUNITIES TO ALERT PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS. BUT HEALTH
CONDITIONS AT SCHOOL CONCERNED
THEM. SH BY COLLEAGUE BROOKS
ALLEN WILL GO INTO MORE DETAIL
ON THESE TOPICS BUT THEY ARE
ESSENTIAL TO OUR PROGRESS. IN
BRINGING STUDENTS AND STAFF
BACK TO CAMPUS IS SAFELY. LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY MANAGEMENT AND
LABOR HAVE BEEN ASKED TO BE
INCREDIBLY FLEXIBLE AND
RESPONSIVE. TO THE EVER
CHANGING ENVIRONMENT THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED. I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEIR TIRELESS WORK IN TRYING
TO GET STUDENTS THE VERY BEST
ACCESS TO EDUCATION SERVICES.
IN THE MOST CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ANY OF US
HAD EVER SEEN. WE KNOW THAT YOU
ARE TIRED IN WITH VERY GOOD
REASON AND THAT YOU ARE DOING
THE BEST THAT YOU CAN AND FOR
THAT WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL. WE
KNOW THAT FURTHER FORWARD
PROGRESS REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. AND TO THAT END THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING TO
BILLION FOR IMMEDIATE ACTION
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION GRANT.
THIS GRANT YOUR INTENDED TO
BUILD ON TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
ACT INVESTMENTS AND PAIR WITH
SIX BILLION IN FEDERAL
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOL
EMERGENCY RELIEF FUND THAT WILL
SOON BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
SCHOOLS. GRANTLAND CENTRALIZED
AND FUNDS BAKERY OPENING FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN IN
THE STATE INCLUDING CHILDREN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE STUDENTS WITH
pDISABILITIES. AND THE STATE'S
YOUNGEST LEARNERS. LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL. ARE ELLIE. WITH
RELATIVE LOW COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION RATE THE HAVE
PLANS IN PLACE FOR STATE SAFE
REOPENING BY FEBRUARY FIRST.
WILL RECEIVE PROPORTIONALLY
LARGER GRANT AMOUNTS BUT ELIUD
NEEDING MORE PLAYING TIME CAN
APPLY FOR GRANTS BY MARCH FIRST
TO RECEIVE FUNDING A SLIGHTLY
LOWER BUT STILL SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT. L. USING COMMUNITY HIGH
TRANSMISSION CAN ALSO APPLY FOR
GRANTS ON EITHER DATE AND
RECEIVED GRANT FUNDING BUT ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO RE OPEN FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. UNTIL
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION RATE
ACCORDING. EARLY FEEDBACK ON
THIS PROPOSAL HAS CENTERED
LARGELY ON A COUPLE OF SPECIFIC
AREAS BUT I WANT TO ADDRESS
NOW- BUT I RECOGNIZE YOU MAY
HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS OR HAVE
FURTHER CONCERNS I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS
MAY HAVE AFTER THE PANEL
PRESENTATIONS. FIRST I WANT TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS ABOUT EQUITY.
WE HAVE RECEIVED COMMENTS BUT
THE PROPOSAL WILL FAVOR
WEALTHIER ELEAZAR ELEAZAR
ALREADY OPEN. AND L. USING
COUNTY THAT LOWER TRANSMISSION
RATES. WE WOULD NOTE ELEAZAR
CAN APPLY FOR THE GRANTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR
TRANSMISSION RATE AND RECEIVE
COMPATIBLE FUNDING.
ADDITIONALLY GRANT AMOUNTS ARE
INCREASED FOR ELEAZAR SERVING
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE. CASH JOHN HOW THE
THIRD THAT FAMILIES IN AREAS
WITH HIGH TRANSMISSION RATE
MAYBE MORE RETICENT TO SEND
CHILDREN BACK TO SCHOOL MAKING
ELEAZAR NEED AREAS AN ELIGIBLE
TO APPLY FOR FUNDING HOWEVER
THIS ISN'T TRUE. I'LL YOU NEED
ONLY TO OFFER THE OPTION IT IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FAMILIES TO
RECEIVE GRANT FUNDING FAMILIES
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO RETURN IF
THAT IS THEIR PREFERENCE.
ADDITIONALLY THE RECENT UPDATES
TO HEALTH AND SAFETY GUIDANCE
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THAT
MECHANISM FOR FAMILIES WITH
SCHOOL STAFF. ARE INTENDED TO
HELP BUILD CONFIDENCE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION CAN BE DONE SAFELY.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT FAMILIES
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF RETURNED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WILL BE MORE LIKELY
TO RETURN STUDENTS TO SCHOOL
CAMPUSES IF THEY SEE THAT THE
CHILDREN OF THEIR NEIGHBORS ARE
ABLE TO RETURN SAFELY. THE
QUESTION THE FEASIBILITY OF
EARLY AGE TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR A COMPLETED
SAFETY PLAN RELATED COSTS
RELATED COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
CO THAT NINETEEN SURVEILLANCE
TESTING. PRIOR TO THE FEBRUARY
FIRST AND MARCH FIRST DEADLINE
FOR GRANT. TWENTY NOTE THAT IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO RECEIVE
THE GRANT IS NOT REQUIRED UNTIL
FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH OR MARCH
SIXTEENTH OR UNTIL AN ALLEY A
WITHIN A HIGH TRANSMISSION.
TELL ME DROPS BELOW HAD
DECRYING TRANSMISSION RATES. SH
BUT WE ARE TAKING YOUR COMMENT
SERIOUSLY I DO WANT TO ENSURE
THAT PARTICIPATION THE GRANT
PROGRAM IS PRACTICABLE FOR AS
MANY. AS POSSIBLE. WE WANT
SCHOOL TO OPEN. HOWEVER WE
RECOGNIZE THERE MAY BE CHAO
FIRST LED NEEDING FRENCH.
MOSTLY IS ARE NOT STARTING FROM
SCRATCH. THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THREE D. PLAN SINCE LAST
MARCH AND ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
CHANGES IN THE RECENTLY
RELEASED HEALTH AND SAFETY
GUIDANCE. WE BELIEVE THAT GIVEN
THE SUPPORT AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED BY THE
STATE. REQUIREMENTS FOR
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE GRANT
ARCHIE MOBILE AND ESSENTIAL TO
A QUICK AND SAFE RETURN TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY ADDITIONAL CONCERNS
OR ANSWER ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
THAT MEMBERS MAY HAVE A BETTER
PROPOSAL FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION GRANT. HOWEVER I
WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE BROOS ALLEN FROM THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
DISCUSS THE OTHER PILLARS OF
OUR PROPOSAL TO CREATE SAFE
PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS AND
STAFF. TO RETURN TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS HOLMES MISTER ALAN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY PLEASE GO
RIGHT AHEAD. THANK YOU A GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR SANDERS. MY
NAME'S BROOKS ALLEN NOW THE
PLEASURE OF SERVING AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
PARK EDUCATION. I'M JUST LIKE A
BREEZE PERSON NOTE. ON MY
CALLER IN THIS HALL COMMENTS AS
A OF THE GRADER A SEVEN GRADER.
WHO ARE IN DISTANCE OR AND HAVE
BEEN SATISFIED MARCH ARE AND
HAVE. MANY FOR AND COLLEAGUES
FUTURE. AND WORKING AND
DISTRICTS ACROSS THIS. ARE I
JUST CAN'T OUTSIDE. HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE TO ALL SCHOOLS-
WORK IN IT EVERY LEVEL TO
SUPPORT. EDUCATION F OUR
STUDENTS FROM THOSE. WORKING
ABROAD MALES. ARE THOSE
WORKING- YOU KNOW ON THE SCHOOL
SIDE CONSULTANT JUST
TECHNOLOGIES THERE AS WELL AS
EDUCATORS. I REALLY DON'T
PARTICULARLY IN THINGS- TO MAKE
THINGS WORK IN THIS IN THIS
VERY CHALLENGING TIME. I JUST
LIKE TO OFFER MY. DEEP THANKS
ALL RIGHT OFF THE TOP. I'M YES
MY- ON AND- THE GOVERNOR'S
SCHOOLS BROADWAY. IT WAS
RELEASED DECEMBER. IT IS
COMPOSED OF FOUR MUTUALLY
REINFORCING DOLLARS. OF DISCO
SMALL VOTER CONTINUE OUR SAY
AND TO EXPAND OF SMALL STATE
RESUMING IN PARSONS. ASPIRINS
RATES THE GREENS. BASED ON WHAT
EARNINGS WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
SKINNER. THE SIX GOALS FOR ALL
EVENTS THE SPREAD. TO CREATE
SAFE LEARN ENVIRONMENT FOR
STUDENTS. AND SAFE WORKPLACES
FOR AN AND ALL SCHOOLS. WITH A
FOCUS ON WELL PLANNED
IMPLEMENTATION AND BUILDING
CONFIDENCE THROUGH MAINTAINING
SAFE OPERATIONS WHERE SCHOOLS
ARE OPEN. REGARDLESS OF THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS SERVED AS
WELL AS BRINGING BACK OUR
YOUNGEST CHILDREN AND OUR MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
STUDENTS FIRST INCLUDING AS
MISS HOLMES ADDED AS I NOTED
EARLIER OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES OUR FOSTER YOUTH
OUR STUDENTS ARE HOMELESS. AND
THOSE SALAS WAS STRUCK BY
CENTER EARLIER GO ON THE WRONG
SIDE OF THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. AND
THEN A FOCUS ON BRINGING BACK
THE OTHER GRADE. LEVELS WHICH
SCHOOLS ARE NOT OPEN YET. I
MISS HOMES OR COVER THE FILM
MILLER OF THIS PLAN. BUT AS
THESE BILLS ARE MAY TO BE
MUTUALLY. I LIKE TO BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE THE REMAINING THREE
PILLARS OF THE PLAN. STARTING
WITH THE SAFETY MITIGATION
FILLER. WHICH REALLY STARTS
WITH THE CONSOLIDATED AND
UPDATED GUIDANCE ISSUED LAST
WEEK BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
BUILDING ON THE GUIDANCE
ORIGINALLY ISSUED LAST JUNE.
THIS UPDATED GUIDANCE
CONSOLIDATES THE CALLOSUM
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
APPLICABLE TO ALL EMPLOERS.
AND BECAME EFFECTIVE ON
NOVEMBER THIRTIETH OF LAST YEAR.
AND REQUIREMENTS FROM THE
PREVIOUS DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE THAT THE STATE
WAS ISSUED LAST JUNE. THIS
GUIDANCE NOW REQUIRES THAT
MASKS WILL BE WORN BY ALL
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF AGE AND%
RECOMMENDS DISPOSABLE SURGICAL
MASKS FOR STAFF WHO COME INTO
REGULAR CONTACT WITH OTHERS.
AND NOTABLY ON THIS POINT ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE NOW ABLE TO
LEVERAGE ST GOSHEN MASTER
CONTRACTS FOR THESE MASKS. ALSO
CONSISTENT WITH THE LATEST
SCIENCE REGARDING HOW IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
SAFELY SPECIALLY FOR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOLS. THE UPDATED GUIDANCE
REVISE THE PROCESS FOR SCHOOLS
SERVING ELEMENTARY GRADES TO
RESUME IN PERSON INSTRUCTION IF
THEY'RE IN THE PURPLE TEAR
REPLACING THE PREVIOUSLY OR
PROCESS. UNDER OUR BLUEPRINT
FOR SAFER CON. DON'T EXPLAIN
HIS LATEST UPDATES INCLUDING
THE LATEST RATIONALE AND
EVIDENCE OF THE STATE SAFE
SCHOOLS TEAM WHICH HAS BEEN
RECENTLY COME OUT CREATED HAS
BEEN HOSTING REGULAR WEBINARS
FOR EDUCATORS SCHOOL STAFF AND
LEADERS UP AND DOWN STATE. ON
NEARLY A WEEKLY BASIS. IN
ADDITION NEW RESOURCES AND
GUIDELINES TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF SCHOOL CENTER
CODE NINETEEN TESTING HAVE BEEN
ISSUED. AND THE STATE IS
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING ALL
SCHOOLS IMPLEMENT TESTING UP TO
ONCE A WEEK. FOR STUDENTS AND
FOR STAFF INCLUDING ACCESS TO
THE STATE BUILT AND OPERATED
VALENCIA BRANCH LAB. WHICH
OFFERS PCR TEST AT ONE THIRD
THE MARKET RATE. AND FORTY
EIGHT HOUR TURNAROUNDS. ALL
THIS INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE
FOR THOSE WHO'VE BEEN SEEKING
PERMISSION BE WATCHING DAY ON
THE STATE'S KOBE NINETEEN
WEBSITE AND THEN ONCE BRANCH
LEVINE. WITH RESPECT WERE THIRD
OF THE OVERSEE AND SINCE DOLLAR.
THE NEW STE SCHOOL SAFETY TEAM
WHICH IS ACROSS TO TAKE LED BY
DR NAOMI BY. AND COMPOSE OF
DESIGNATED EXPERTS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH CAL
OSHA AND EDUCATIONALLY THESE.
ARE HELPING TO OVERSEE AND
ASSIST LOCAL IMPLEMENTATION OF
SAFE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. IT
TO SUPPORT THIS OVERSIGHT. TO
DIRECTIVES WERE ISSUED BY THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH LAST
WEEK IT REQUIRED TWO THINGS
THAT I KNOW ARE OF GREAT
INTEREST. TO ALL OF US. ONE IS
TO HAVE SCHOOLS REPORT ON THE
REOPENING OF STATUS SCALE AND
MODEL EVERY OTHER WEEK. SO
STARTING WITH NEXT MONDAY ON
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH. WE'LL
START GATHERING THE STATE I WAS
STATEWIDE BASIS SO WE WILL KNOW
IN LA LEVEL UP BY MY SCHOOL BY
GRADE SPAN. AWARE FOLKS ARE
OPEN AND TO THE EXTENT THEY ARE
OPEN. AND CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT FEDERAL AND STATE LAW
REPORTING OF ANY POSITIVE
COPING NINETEEN CASES FOR
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN ON SCHOOL
SITES. WILL NEED TO BE REPORTED
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS WILL
THEN REPORT THAT DATA UP TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. IN TERMS OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SCHOOL LEADERS
SEEKING GUIDANCE REGARDING HOW
TO PLAN AND IMPLEMENT SAFETY
MEASURES. ARE ABLE TO REQUEST
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM THE
STATE SCHOOL SAFETY SCHEME BY
SUBMITTING A REQUEST OUR NEW
STATE SCHOOLS FOR ALL HUB.
WHERE ALL THIS CONSOLIDATED
GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE OPPORTUNITIES WILL
BE POSTED. AND FINALLY THE
FOURTH PILLAR OF THESE FOUR
INTERLOCKING PILLARS IS THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
PILLAR. AND FOR THIS PIECE THE
TELEPORTING DIRECTIVES THAT
JUST MENTIONED BOTH REGARDING
REOPENING STATUS AS WELL AS
REPORTING OF CASES WILL END UP
SUPPORTING AN INTERACTIVE GIS
MAP THAT WILL BE LAUNCHED ON
THAT SAME STATE SCHOOLS FROM
HIGH UP IN THE COMING WEEKS.
OVERRIDE THAT TRANSPARENCY AS
WELL AS ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
ADEQUATE SAFETY MEASURES. IN
ADDITION WE LAUNCHED ASAFETY
PROBLEM HOTLINE FOR SCHOOL
STAFF AND PARENTS TO SUBMIT ANY
SAFETY CONCERNS THEY MAY HAVE.
ABOUT SPECIFIC SCHOOLS EITHER
ONLINE OR VIA TELEPHONE. AND
THE PHONE NUMBERS POSTED ON
THAT SPACE- STATE SCHOOLS HELP
SITE THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER.
THE CITY SCHOOLS TEAM WORK
MONITOR THESE REPORTS AND WHEN
APPROPRIATE. PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND OR IF NECESSARY
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS HELP ASSIST
US ALL GET TO A PLACE WE HAVE A
SAFE WORKPLACE AND SAFE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT. FINALLY
WE'VE ISSUED AN ALL COUNTY
LETTER ON THE WENT OUT LAST
WEEK IT'S GREATER CLARITY IN
HIGHLY KEY ISSUES AROUND ISSUES
SUCH AS WHEN A SCHOOL IS DEEMED
TO BE OPEN. OTHER BEEN RAISED
BY SCHOOLS ARE AND IF NOT WOULD
PROVIDE- TO ALL DISTRICTS AND
ALL COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE.
IN SOME THESE FOUR PILLARS OF
ALL SCHOOLS FOR ALL PLAN
FUNDING. SAFETY MITIGATION
OVERSIGHT ASSISTANCE AND
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
ARE DESIGNED TO HELP ENSURE
SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE A SAFE WORK
ENVIRONMENT AND LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT OUR EDUCATORS
SCHOOL STAFF AND STUDENTS ARE
URGENTLY NEEDED. RESIDENTS ON
SAID I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT TO THESE
DOLLARS ON WEARABLE PROVIDE
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER ALLEN NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM AMY LEE WHO IS
A FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. MISLI THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SENATORS AMY LEE WHAT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. TODAY I'M JOINED BY TWO
OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE L. EEO
AFTER CABRAL THE DEPUTY OF THE
K. TWELVE TEAM AND SONYA
PADDOCK WHO COVERS. PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR OFFICE. LET ME BEGIN
BY SAYING THAT WE THINK IT IS
WORTHWHILE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO EXPLORE WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
SCHOOLS TO REOPEN. AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE CITING
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT YOUNGER
CHILDREN MAY PARTICULARLY
BENEFIT FROM BEING BROUGHT BACK
INTO THE CLASSROOM. ESPECIALLY
FOR THEIR SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT.
MORE RECENT RESEARCH SUGGESTS
THAT YOUNGER CHILDREN CAN BE
BROUGHT BACK INTO SCHOOL SAFELY
EVEN WHEN TRANSITION RATES ARE
HIGH. HOWEVER AS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS CURRENTLY CRAFTING
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
EFFECTIVE THE PROPOSAL WILL BE.
AN ULTIMATELY GETTING SCHOOLS
REOPENED EARLIER. AND WE HAVE A
HANDOUT THAT WALKS YOU THROUGH
SOME OF THE KEY CONSIDERATIONS
I BELIEVE THIS YEAR THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO SENATORS IN ADVANCE
AND MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC CAN
FIND THIS HANDOUT. AND THE ONLY
A WEBSITE AT L. E. O. DOT CA
DOT GOP ON THE RIGHT HAND ARE
LABELED OTHER PUBLICATIONS. I
AM I WOULD ALSO BE HAPPY TO
SHARE THE HEAD ON THE SCREEN OF
THE SENATORS WITH MIKE. PLEASE
DO. OKAY. SORRY IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH I'M NOT ABLE TO SHARE MY
SCREEN- NO WORRIES OF THE AREA
OKAY. ONCE AGAIN PLEASE. OKAY.
WE COULD SEE JUST FINE THANK
YOU OKAY PERFECT- SO. BEGINNING
ON THE FIRST PAGE ON BACKGROUND
IN AUGUST THE GOVERNOR
ESTABLISHED K. FOURTEEN
FRAMEWORK WHICH HELPS GUIDE
SCHOOL RE OPENING FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION I THINK THIS IS A
FRAMEWORK THAT MOST OF US ARE
RATHER FAMILIAR WITH AT THIS
POINT. COUNTIES FALL INTO ONE
OF FOUR TIERS RANGING FROM
PURPLE WHERE TRANSMISSION IS
WIDESPREAD TO JELLO OUR
TRANSMISSION IS MINIMAL LAST
THURSDAY ON JANUARY FOURTEENTH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH RELEASED UPDATED
GUIDANCE THAT LOWERS THE RE
OPENING CRITERIA FOR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL STUDENTS. THIS UPDATE
WAS MOTIVATED BY NEW RESEARCH
SHOWING THAT- YOUNGER CHILDREN
TYPICALLY HAVE LOWER RATES OF
INFECTION AND TRANSMISSION OF
COMPLETE NINETEEN. MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT PAGE. SO IN THIS
FIGURE OUT WE COMPARE ADVANCED
SCHOOL RE OPENING HER CRITERIA
UNDER THE GUIDANCE RELEASED IN
AUGUST WITH THE UPDATED
GUIDANCE RELEASED EARLIER THIS
MONTH STARTING WITH THE TOP ROW
FOR HIGH NEED STUDENTS AND WHEN
WE SAY HIGH NEEDS WE TYPICALLY
REFER TO STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. STUDENTS ARE
CONSIDERED MOST AT RISK FOR
FALLING BEHIND UNDER CONTINUE
DISTANCE LEARNING DISTRICTS MAY
BRING BACK HIGH NEED STUDENTS
AND SMALL CORDS AT ANYTIME
REGARDLESS OF TIER AND THERE IS
NO CHANGE TO THIS CRITERIA
UNDER THE UPDATED GUIDANCE.
MOVING ONTO THE NEXT ROW FOR
ELEMENTARY STUDENTS PREVIOUSLY
SCHOOLS COULD ONLY OPEN FOR
THESE GRADES AFTER BEING IN THE
RIGHT HERE WHERE TRANSMISSION
IS SUBSTANTIAL FOR AT LEAST
FOURTEEN CONSECUTIVE DAYS THIS
IS UNLESS THE SCHOOL OF TEAMS
IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL WEAVER
THROUGH THE COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. UNDER THE UPDATED
GUIDANCE DISTRICTS CAN BRING
BACK ELEMENTARY GRADES AFTER
CASE RATES FALL BELOW TWENTY
FIVE PER HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE THIS THRESHOLD IS STILL
WITH IN THE PURPLE CARE MEANING
THAT UNDER THE UPDATED GUIDANCE
SOME ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS WOULD
BE ALLOWED TO REOPEN IN PURPLE
TIER RATHER THAN BRED AS WAS
PREVIOUSLY THE CASE. ON THE
UPDATED GUIDANCE ALSO HOLDS
THAT PREVIOUS WAIVER PROCESS
HOWEVER PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
WAIVERS REMAIN VALID. WESLEY
FOR OLDER GRADES NOT LAST ROAD
AFTER GETTING GUIDANCE ALLOWS
DISTRICTS TO BRING STUDENTS
BACK AFTER BEING IN THE RIGHT
HERE FOR FIVE CONSECUTIVE DAYS
THE STORE IS THE PERIOD FROM
FOURTEEN CONSECUTIVE DAYS AS
WAS PREVIOUSLY THE CASE. SO
ALONG WITH THE UPDATED GUIDANCE
THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED OTHER
EFFORTS TO REOPEN SCHOOLS AND
THESE ARE THE OTHER PILLARS
THAT MR AND WE MENTIONED
EARLIER SORRY. I'LL JUST MOVE
PAST THAT. HERE WE KNOW IT'S
THAT SCHOOLS LEARN HAVE
DISCRETION OVER WHEN AND HOW TO
RE OPEN. ALTHOUGH UNDER THE NEW
STATE GUIDANCE DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE REOPENED OR PLAN TO REOPEN
MUST PUBLICLY POST. AND SUBMIT
SCHOOL REOPENING PLANS TO
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND-
VESTI CROSS AGENCY TEAM AND
THAT IS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S.
INITIATIVES ON A SCHOOL
REOPENING- AND THIS TEAM IS
CONSISTING OF THE CALIFORNIA
BERMAN PUBLIC HEALTH-
CALIFORNIA CAL OSHA AND THE AND
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. HOWEVER
IT'S BECAUSE OF THIS LOCAL
DISCRETION OVER WHEN TO RE OPEN
THAT IN THE FALL WHEN HE
STREETS FOR LOWER ACROSS THE
STATE- IN MANY DISTRICTS
CONSIDERED RE OPENING NEAR THE
BEGINNING OF THE SCHOOL. SCHOOL
YEAR THE ULTIMATELY DECIDED TO
CONTINUE WITH DISTANCE LEARNING
IN ANTICIPATION OF THE HOLIDAY
SURGE. THIS MEANS HOWEVER THAT
MOST SCHOOLS HAVE OFFERED ANY
SIGNIFICANT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION SINCE LAST MARCH.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT SCHOOLS HAVE
RECEIVED SIGNIFICANT STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT COULD. BE
USED TO SUPPORT SCHOOL RE
OPENING. WE ON TO THE NEXT HE.
OKAY SO HERE WE PROVIDE DETAILS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL I'M
OUR COLLEAGUES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
ALREADY DESCRIBED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN DETAIL
I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL DOESN'T
INCLUDE ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
THEIR HIGH NEED STUDENTS
DEFINITION REYES STATE GUIDANCE
TYPICALLY DOES INCLUDE THIS
GROUP OF STUDENTS UNDER THE
HIGH NEEDS CATEGORY. SO WITH
THAT I THINK I'LL JUST MOVE ON
TO THE ISSUES FOR
CONSIDERATION. I'M HERE WE
OFFER- DAY LEGISLATURE JUST
SOME ISSUES TO CONSIDER
PRIMARILY WE DON'T THINK THE
PROPOSAL ALLOWS ENOUGH TIME FOR
DISTRICTS TO COMPLETE THE
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS. TO MEET
THE FEBRUARY FIRST DEADLINE
WHICH IS A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
A WEEK FROM TODAY DISTRICTS
WOULD HAVE VERY LITTLE TIME TO
UPDATE THEIR SCHOOL WE OPENING
PLANS ARE RANGE FOR ROUTINE
TESTING. AND GO SHE WITH THEIR
LABOR UNIONS THIS MAY BE
SPECIFICALLY CHALLENGING FOR
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN CLOSED
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION SINCE
MARCH. WE'RE ALSO UNCERTAIN
ABOUT THE CAPACITY OF STATE
AGENCIES AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR SCHOOL OPENING- THAT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR EXAMPLE
DOESN'T PROVIDE AUGMENTATION TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
BUDGETS TO SUPPORT THIS
ADDITIONAL WORK. LASTLY WE
NOTES THAT AND THAT PROPOSAL AS
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED IS
UNLIKELY TO LEAD TO EARLIER IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. I THINK
THERE ARE TWO REASONS FOR THIS
FIRST TO THE REQUIREMENT FOR
EAST ROUTINE EXAMS ATIX
TESTING. AS OFTEN AS EVERY WEEK
FOR ALL STUDENTS AND STAFF
NGUYEN TRANSMISSION RATES ARE
HIGH THIS ADDS MORE COMPLEX
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES TO SCHOOL
RE OPENING WHICH IS ALREADY A
RATHER LOGISTICALLY CHALLENGING
ENDEAVOR TO BEGIN WITH. TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING UNDER THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL AND DISTRICTS
WOULD ESSENTIALLY NEED TO RUN
THEIR OWN TESTING OPERATION WE
THINK THIS IS LIKELY TO DAMPEN
OVERALL INTEREST IN SCHOOL
PARTICIPATION IN THE GRANT
PROGRAM. SECONDLY KOBE NINETEEN
CASE RATES ARE RATHER HIGH
ACROSS THE STATE RIGHT NOW
GREATER THAN A HUNDRED CASES
PER HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE AS
OF JANUARY NINETEENTH THIS IS
ACTUALLY MORE RECENT DATA THAT
WAS INCLUDED AND HAND OUT. THE
CURRENTLY ONLY SIX COUNTIES
FALL BELOW THE TWENTY FIVE PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND THRESHOLD FOR
SCHOOLS. FOR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
RE OPENING GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY OVER WHEN CASE
RATES WILL FALL AND THE
CORRESPONDING DELAY IN SCHOOL
REOPENING WE THINK THE PROPOSAL
MIGHT ACTUALLY MIGHT NOT.
ACTUALLY RESULTS IN MUCH MORE
IN PER SINISTRA AND- TURNING TO
OUR LAST. HERE- WE PROVIDE THE-
WHEN YOU SEE A FEW OP TO
CONSIDER MANY OF THESE OPTIONS
ARE GEARED TOWARDS ADDRESSING
THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HIGHLIGHTED EARLIER- FIRST THE
LEGISLATURE COULD MODIFY THE
PROPOSAL TO REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO
OFFER IN PERSON INSTRUCTION ALL
HIGH NEED STUDENTS A MONTH
BEFORE THE OTHER ELEMENTARY
GRADES THIS ALLOWS SCHOOLS UNEF
TIME TO RAMP UP THEIR TESTING
CAPACITY AND ADDRESS OTHER
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES WITH
SCHOOL RE OPENING WITH A
SMALLER GROUP OF STAFF AND
STUDENTS FIRST. WHILE STILL
PROVIDING IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
TO BENEFITS TO STUDENTS WHO
WOULD LARGELY BENEFIT FROM IT
I'M SECONDS THAT LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER INCLUDING SOME
FLEXIBILITIES ON A SYMPTOMATIC
TESTING REQUIREMENTS WE THINK
THIS IS THE ASPECT OF THE
PROPOSAL MOST LIKELY TO REDUCE
SCHOOL PARTICIPATION THE
LEGISLATURE FOR EXAMPLE COULD
PROVIDE DISTRICTS AN OPTION TO
DEVELOP AN ALTERNATIVE TESTING
KEEP AND WHAT THEIR LABOR
PARTNERS OR ALLOW DISTRICTS TO
TEST ALL STAFF WEEKLY BUT A LOT
OF RANDOM SAMPLING OF STUDENTS
ON A WEEKLY BASIS. WE THINK
THIS APPROACH- ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT YOUNGER CHILDREN ARE JUST
AT LOWER RISK OF TRANSMITTING
COPING NINETEEN BUT STILL
ALLOWS FOR ROUTINE. TESTING IN
A MORE FEASIBLE WAY. WESLEY
FROM THE FROM. AND THEN
LEGISLATURE LOOK AT WAY TO
INCREASE. TESTING CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO MORE EASILY ACCESS
ROUTINE TESTING ALTHOUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS OFFERED
SCHOOLS ACCESS TO THE STATE
SUPPORTED VALENCIA BRANCH LAB.
BASED ON EARLY ESTIMATES THE
TESTING CAPACITY SET ASIDE FOR
SCHOOLS. ME ONLY SUPPORT A
PORTION OF ELEMENTARY STUDENTS
STATEWIDE. AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT EXPANDING STATEWIDE
TESTING CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD REQUIRE
NOT PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. AND WOULD BE
DIFFICULT TO ACCOMPLISH MY
CAREER FIRST. I THINK WITH THAT
I WILL CONCLUDE MY REMARKS AND
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS LEE. MEMBERS I'D
DAHLE NOW LIKE TO TURN IT BACK
TO YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OF ANY OF OUR
PANELISTS. DR PAMELA WITH YOU
AND THEN DOT ON CENTER LAYERED
GO AHEAD RICHARD. OKAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATIONS FROM BOTH A
FINANCE BOARD EDUCATION AND THE
L. A. L- YES MY FIVE FIRST
QUESTION IS- BUT MAYBE TO THE
STATE- TO- MISTER ALAN AT THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION NICE
TO TALK TO YOU WE HAVE THE
SCHOOL SAFETY TEAM THAT'S
GREAT- I'VE I THINK AN
OPPORTUNITY TALKED. TO SOME OF
THE- FOLKS ON THEIR- YOU KNOW
ALIA IS BROUGHT UP AND- AND I
AM. SERVING GREENMAN I MEAN
WHAT'S THE CAPACITY OF THIS
TEAM TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SO WE HAVE A
THOUSAND THIRTY SEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE SO LAW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. I REALIZE
THAT MANY OF THEM- PERHAPS HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON VARIOUS SAFETY.
PLANS BUT- IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO MEET SOME OF THE
PARAMETERS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SEPARATE FIRST BUT JUST AND ON
ANY TIMELINE- YOU KNOW YOU TALK
ABOUT. TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SO FORTH. HAVE AND WE'RE GONNA
BE HEARING FROM SCHOOL SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL IN THE
NEXT PANEL BUT- CAN YOU MAYBE
SPEAK TO THE CAPACITY OF THIS
GROUP TO PROVIDE TO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO. THAT MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN YOU SPEAK TO FOR
EXAMPLE HAS TECHNICAL SYSTEMS
BEEN AVAILABLE I REALIZE THAT
WE HAVEN'T PASSED THIS PROPOSAL
YET BUT ANTICIPATION. HAVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THREE REACHED
OUT OF THE REACHED OUT TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND AT LEAST
GOTTEN ASSESSMENT OF WHERE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS GENERALLY ARE
HE SAID MANY OF THEM WORKING ON
SAFETY PLANS IN TERMS OF THEIR-
OWN CAPACITIES THESE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO- TO FIGURE OUT
MANY OF THE LOGISTICS INVOLVED
IN TRYING TO IMPLEMENTSUCH A
PLAN SO FOR EXAMPLE STE.
SETTING UP RETAIL SURVEILLANCE
TESTING AT ITS ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. IN A PLACE WHERE
THEY VERY WORK SOME OF THAT OUT
THERE FREE ARE IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BILLS FROM GROUND UP AND- DO
THEY EVEN HAVE ANY IDEA. HOW TO
DO IT- WITHOUT IT- TELL ME THAT
NEED TO. SAYS TO FIGURE OUT
EVEN JUST TO STAY UP AND THAT'S
ONE COMPONENT THIS WHOLE
PROPOSAL SO. I CAN JUST SPEAK
TO THE S. SCHOOL SAFETY TEAM
CAPACITY. AND UNDER. THE TO
ASSIST. POTENTIALLY UP TO A
THOUSAND THIRTY SEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND PROVIDING GOOD.
SUFFICIENT GUIDANCE. PRACTICAL
GUIDANCE WOULD ACTUALLY STAND
UP THERE ARE THINGS THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO READ THIS
PROPOSAL. YEAH ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I WOULD
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THERE'S
OF THE STATE SCHOOL SAFETY TEAM
IS ONE KEY COMPONENT AND
OBVIOUSLY WHEN DEALING WITH THE
SCALE ON. YOU JUST HIGHLIGHTED.
ALL WE HAVE TO TAKE ON MULTIPLE
STRATEGIES AND SO ONE THING I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
HIGHLIGHT IS THE FACT THAT.
THERE'S BEEN A GREAT DEAL WORK
THIS HAS BEEN HAPPENING EVER
SINCE LAST MARCH. WE'VE HAD OF
BOTH DISTRICTS COUNTY OFFICES
ARE WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS I PROVIDE A LOT
OF ASSISTANCE. IN THESE AREAS
INCLUDING A WITH THE SUPPORT OF
ASSISTANCE AND GUIDANCE FROM
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS ISN'T ISN'T NEW RIGHT IT
IS I THINK WE ALL KNOW- WHAT WE
CREATE IS PART OF THE STATE'S.
SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL TEAM IS TO
PROVIDE A HOME FOR WHEN YOU
HAVE THOSE PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING QUESTIONS THAT
THEY'RE HEARING. IN THEIR
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE HAVE WITH OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- INCLUDING USING
EFFICIENCIES LIKE MEETING. AS
WE RECENTLY JUST DID THAT TWO
DAYS AGO WITH ALL THE
SUPERINTENDENTS AND ONE COUNTY
WITH THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT.
OUGHT TO ANSWER ALL THE
QUESTIONS ARE COMING UP THROUGH
A VARIETY OF DISTRICTS- DANCES
QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
THE- THE TOUGHEST DANCER. ALSO
THE STATE SCHOOL SAFETY SCHEME
CAN HELP PROVIDE THAT GUIDANCE
TO BOTH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
TO DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION- THIS IS DONE AT
SCALE BOTH BY DOING. WEBINARS
THAT WE DISCUSSED HOSTING
VIDEOS AND TRAINING. ONLINE ON
STILL SCHOOLS HUG AND THEN
HAVING THIS INTAKE PROCEDURE
WHERE YOU HAVE VERY SPECIFIC
INSTANCES WHERE YOU HAVE TOUGH
QUESTIONS THAT COME UP. HOW
THEY CAN BE TACKLED AND IT HAS
BEEN A DIRECT ONE ON ONE
ASSISTANCE WITH DISTRICTS TO DO
THAT BOTH ON ISSUES AROUND
DISTANCING. MASKS ARE STABLE
GROUPS ACCORDING. OUT BUT ALSO
SPECIFICALLY TO THE QUESTION
AROUND TESTING. OUR OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM HELD HIM.
SERVICE AGENCY HAS BEING- YOU
KNOW FROM BEEN WORKING WITH.
ACCOUNT INTO TO HOW ON THEM
WITH THE LANDSCAPE LAB PROVIDE
THAT ASSIST. I'LL PROVIDE
BIGGIO'S. I TO DO HAPPEN ALSO
DOING A LOT ONE ON ONE AND HOLD.
BUT DO YOU SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS IS WE A WORK WITH OUR
ACCOUNT HOUSE THAT. THANK REACH
OUT TO LOCAL. I'VE IN THEIR JR.
SO I GUESS JUST A FOLLOW ON
THAT AND WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
FROM STE. AT LEAST SUPER- OR
THE BOARD PRESIDENT TO SEE.IF
I GO IN. TALK TO MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE. IN ASSAM
STUDENTS SAY DO YOU HAVE ALL
YOUR QUESTIONS ANSWERED- HAVE
YOU GOTTEN ENOUGH HELP FROM.
THE SCHOOL SAFETY TEAM AND THEY
ANSWERED ALL THE QUESTIONS YOU
NEED IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT IT
WITHOUT STUDY CEDARS OTHER
THINGS THEY HAVE TO DO TO
IMPLEMENT IT- THE ANSWER SHE
TEARS YES. IT WOULD CERTAINLY
BE OUR HOPE YES AND INDICATES
THAT THEY DON'T KNOW WE HAVE A
GREAT RESOURCE WHERE THEY CAN
GO BOTH. ON THE WEBSITE WHERE
WE HAVE CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
TO DEAL WITH THOSE QUESTIONS IN
A SYSTEMATIC WAY- I WILL SAY
THAT WE HAVE PROBABLY SOME NEW
QUESTIONS THAT COME OUT JUST
FROM LAST THURSDAY AND WE'VE
BEEN HAVING- NEARLY DAILY AT.
BAILEY WEBINARS AND A DIRECT
INTERACTIONS HELP ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS SO. WE KNOW THAT
CERTAINLY SOME QUESTIONS
PERSISTING THE GIVEN ON SOME OF
THE NEW CONSOLIDATE GUIDANCE.
WE ANSWERING THOSE BUT BUT
CERTAINLY I WOULD HOPE THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY ARE QUESTIONS
HAVE BEEN CLEAR. OKAY SO I-
YEAH I THINK SOMETIMES. TOP
LEVEL LIKE YOU PULSE BUT I MEAN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TRYING TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT. AND I GUESS
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS A
HERE YOU SAID YOU TALKED YOU
KNOW METHODS TO PRETEND
INSTANT. COMING OFF THE
EDUCATION THOSE ARE CERTAINLY
VERY IMPORTANT. BUT CERTAINLY
THE CORE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS. THIS ALSO A
COLLABORATION WITH LABOR LET'S-
THE BARGAINING UNITS. IS THERE
ALSO EQUAL- EFFORT BEING MADE
TO MEET WITH- BARGAINING UNITS
WITH REPRESENTATIVES FROM
TEACHERS AND- SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
AND OTHER STAFF AT CETERA. TO
ALSO. TALK ABOUT THE EVIDENCE
AROUND. SCHOOL SAFETY.
TRANSMISSION ETCETERA SO THAT
WERE SO THAT AS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE- UNIONS ARE-
AND ACCORDING TO THIS EXCERPT
OF A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT- JUSTIN OR- WHATEVER
TO SUCCESS THE APPLY. THAT
THEY'RE WORKING FROM THE SAME
SET OF FACTS ABOUT RISKS AND SO
FORTH- I THINK THAT. SOMETIMES
I AM A LITTLE CONCERNED THAT.
PEOPLE ARE. KILLED THE N.
RIGHTFULLY SO PEOPLE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THE RISKS TO- TO
TEACHERS AND STAFF. BUT
SOMETIMES BY THE SUSSMAN OF
THOSE RISKS- BECAUSE OF LACK OF.
INPUT FROM PUBLIC HEALTH. MAY
BE THE OVERLY ELEVATED ARE NOT.
CONSIDER AND SO AS URBAN
OUTREACH TO- THOSE EMPLOYEES OR
UNIONS- AND THEN ALSO EVEN THE
GENERAL PUBLIC BUT LET'S START
OFF WITH THE MAYBE YOU CAN
ANSWER BOTH OF THOSE BUT- I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PART
SO. PARENTS NEED TO KNOW SAID
AND THIS IS A SUPER TENSE AND
THEN ALSO THE- THE UNIONS AND
THEIR MEMBERS NEED TO KNOW SO
WHAT HAVE OUT REACHES BEEN DONE
TO- THAT THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING UNITS AND THEN ALSO
TO PARENTS ARE THE PUBLIC IN
GENERAL. ABOUT THIS. YEAH I
KNOW ITS- BACK TO IT. I HOPE MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE FOLLOWING
PANELS. WHO HAVE BEEN JOIN US
FOR MANY WEBINARS OVER THE LAST
FEW WEEKS- I WOULD AGREE WE'VE
HAD EVER SINCE THE ROLLOUT OF
THE SAFE SCHOOLS PLAN. WHICH
INCLUDES. A COUPLE OF DOCUMENTS
SENT TO YOU REFERENCED IN TERMS
OF BOTH EXPLAINING THE
RATIONALE BEHIND THE PLAN.
AGAIN THE BILL ON ALL SCHOOLS
ARE A GOOD SAFETY HARBOR AS
WELL AS- OTHER DOCUMENT THAT
PROVIDES A DISTILLATION OF THE
LATEST STUDIES AND RESEARCH.
ALL PUT TOGETHER. BUT BALK AT
DOCTOR BARDOCK AND LEADING
EXPERTS WE HAVE A DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY- SO THOSE
ARE BOTH PART. THEY'VE BEEN
SHARED THROUGH THESE WEBINARS
INSURANCE OUR GAUGE MEANT- WITH
OUR CRITICAL LABOR PARTNERS-
DURING THE ROLLOUT IN
DISCUSSIONS. ON IN THEY'VE BEEN
SHARED- BOTH NOW ON THE WEBSITE
AND I KNOW THAT. WE'RE ACTUALLY
JUST ME WITH A GROUP OF THE
SUPERINTENDENTS- BELIEVE ON
TUESDAY OF THIS WEEK AND THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT ME THESE
MATERIALS ARE NOT MAKE IT INTO.
THE AIRPORT PACKETS. ON BEING
SHARED OUT WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS SO I THINK WE ARE
SEEING SOME SUCCESSFUL
DISSEMINATION. OF THESE
RESOURCES. ARE BOTH TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC AS WELL AS
RESTORE LABOR PARTNERS. AS WE
ALL CHEN THIS DISCUSSION TRY TO
KEEP UP WITH. THE LATEST
STUDIES AND REYES SEVERANCE.
OKAY SO I GUESS THE DAY I GUESS
ONE OF THE CONCERNS I HAVE IS
FOR EXAMPLE I'VE HEARD. AT
LEAST READ THE NEWS MADE. THAT
FOR EXAMPLES AND SOME SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- THERE OF PEOPLE SAID
THAT UNTIL. ALL THEIR- TEACHERS
AND STAFF ARE VACCINATED.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA REOPEN. SO IS
THAT IT MEANS THAT TO BE A LOOK.
TO THE- IS SO I. I'M TRYING TO
GET SENSE OF YOU SAID SHARED
THIS INFORMATION BUT- AT. THAT
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE ARE ASKING FOR OUR SAY
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
STANDARD- GUIDE. US TO REOPEN
IT WOULD INDICATE THAT PERHAPS
THE SHARING HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH.
IS THAT A CONCERN TO YOU. I
THINK WE CONTINUE TO SHARE THE
BEST INFORMATION WE HAVE AND
YOU KNOW WHETHER IT WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS- THE A LOT OF
APPROPRIATE CONCERN- FROM.
PARENTS FROM STAFF. IN CERTAIN
HAVING UNCERTAINTY ABOUT SAFETY
AND SO IT'S BEEN CERTAINLY ONE
OF THE CORE COMPONENTS SAYS
WE'VE BEEN ROLLING OUT THESE
PIECES TO TRY TO PROVIDE. THE
BEST EVIDENCE TO BUILD THAT
CONFIDENCE AROUND WHAT IS SAFE
AND HOW THESE MITIGATION
MEASURES WOULD PUT TOGETHER A
PARTICULARLY FOR THE EARLIEST
GRADES I CAN PROVIDE FOR A SAFE
WORK ENVIRONMENT AND A SAFE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT. SO WE
CONTINUE TO DISSEMINATE THAT
INFORMATION WE TRY TO. STILL
BUILD THAT OUT BUT CERTAINLY WE
KNOW THAT- THAT CONTINUES TO BE
AN AREA THAT WILL NEED MORE
TIME TO FOCUS. OKAY WELL I
THINK THAT- THAT YEAH I JUST
WANNA MAKE THE- THEN WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE SOME OF
THESE THINGS OUT AND- I
APPRECIATE. SHARING PROVIDES
SOME PLAYS SOME POINT. WE'VE
GOTTA DO SOME PERSUASION TO
AND- IT IT AND WHETHER THAT
MEANS MORE TIME MORE EDUCATION-
IT'S ADDRESS AND IT'S A BIG
STATES SO I JUST I ALSO WONDER
ABOUT CAPACITY TO. BECAUSE WE
CAN PUT SOMETHING ON A WEBSITE
SAID WE'VE NOW SHARED IT TO
EVERYBODY BUT- I DON'T KNOW
THEY'VE READ IT HOW CONVINCING
THAT IS. OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY ENGAGE PEOPLE ON MORE
ON ONE ON ONE- TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THOSE TYPES OF
CONVERSATIONS. SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
COME TO AGREEMENT IN THE ONE
THOUSAND THIRTY SEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE HAVE- TO SAY OKAY
WE'RE ALL THAT COMFORTABLE TO
REOPEN AND BY THE WAY I ALSO.
MENTION THE PARENTS TO THAT
THEY HAVE TO FEEL COMFORTABLE
TO SEND THEIR KIDS. AS WELL AS
WELL AND- JOBS AND SO THERE
NEEDS TO BE ALSO A PUBLIC
CAMPAIGN. AS WELL AND RESOURCES
YOU KNOW L. A. L. MENTIONED
THAT- AND- WE HAVE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL- IS
THERE YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO BUILDTHAT CAPACITY IN BOTH. A C. P.
H. AS WELL AS THE PART OF
EDUCATION TO DO THAT LEVEL OF
EDUCATION. THAT'S NECESSARY SO
YOU KNOW THE SCHOOL SAFETY TEAM
DO WE NEED MORE PEOPLE THAT IS
A ON THE TEAM BUT IT AND THE
STAFF TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT THAT WE
NEED. IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS
SUCCESSFUL. AND THAT'S WITHOUT
AND THAT'S BEYOND JUST THE
LOGISTICS. OF LIKE HOW WE'RE
GOING TO STAND UP TO DEAL DOING
SURVEILLANCE TESTING EVERY WEEK
AND- AND SO FORTH SO- SO I
THINK- APPRECIATE THAT I GUESS
THE ONE LAST THING IS THAT I
SOON I DON'T KNOW ARE DEAD
THESE WITNESSES FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ARE GOING TO
STAY IN THE HEARING SO THAT WE
CAN ASK THEM QUESTIONS AND
FOLLOW UP AFTER WE HEAR FROM
THE SUPERINTENDENT'S INFINITY.
YES I BELIEVE THEY'LL BE
STAYING FOR THE WHOLE OKAY
EXCELLENT SO I'VE MAYBE THERE'S
SOME OPPORTUNITIES THEN FOLLOW
UP ON SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS
WHEN WE HEAR FROM OTHER PEOPLE
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH MANAGER.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN CENTER
LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MANAGER. I WOULD LIKE TO PAY UP.
ON OUR QUESTIONS AT CENTER. PAN
ASTON WOULD LIKE TO THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT. BECAUSE I AM
HEARING FROM LOTS OF DISTRICTS
THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO APPLY
IN THE WAY THAT THE PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED AND- IN MY
HOME COUNTY OF SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT ANNOUNCED
ON BEHALF OF ALL THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE COUNTY THEY
WILL NOT BE APPLYING FOR LOS
ANGELES- PROBABLY THE LARGEST
DISTRICT IN THE STATE SAYING
THEY'RE NOT APPLYING HER
PODCAST. FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF FRESNO THAT
SOUNDED LIKE THEY WERE NOT
COMPLYING. AND I THINK IN THE
PRESENTATION TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE IT WAS SAID THAT THE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS
REQUESTED TO FUND THIS PROGRAM
WAS PREDICATED ON TWO THIRDS.
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
APPLYING SO IF MOM. IF A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT MARKUPS LINE-
ARE YOU GOING TO BE REVISING
THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THERE WILL
BE APPLICATIONS FOR WHAT IS
PROPOSED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR LAYERED I JUST GOT HOME
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT YOU'RE HEARING
FROM SUPERINTENDENTS WHO DON'T
INTEND TO APPLY WE CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT YOU- AND- I RECOMMEND
THAT THEY REACH OUT TO MYSELF.
MISTER ALAN- YOU KNOW TO
DISCUSS WHAT THEIR SPECIFIC
CONCERNS ARE- BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE HAVE FOUND THAT IN SPEAKING
WITH INDIVIDUAL SUPERINTENDENT
TO THE EXTENT THAT WERE ABLE TO
DISCUSS THEIR- INDIVIDUAL
SITUATION AND HOW THE PROGRAM
CAN WORK FOR THEM. WE'VE BEEN
RELATIVELY SUCCESSFUL IN
HELPING PEOPLE FEEL LIKE. THAT
THE PROGRAM CAN HELP THEM AND
SERVE THEM SO I'M PLEASED YOU
KNOW PLEASE STAND AND YOUR
SUPERINTENDENT OUR WAY WE WERE
HAPPY TO DISCUSS THE PROPOSAL
WITH THEM AND- THEN WORK WITH
THEM ON THEIR PARTICULAR
BARRIERS. AND YOUR SECOND
QUESTION ON THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS- AND HOW IF IT'S UNDER
IF THE PROGRAM IS UNDERSTOOD
SCRIBE HOW WE WOULD ADDRESS
THAT. THERE IS LANGUAGE IN THE
TRAILER BILL THAT SPECIFIES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAVE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON AN EXPANDED
FUND- IN THE PROGRAM BY MARCH
THIRTY FIRST THAT THOSE FUNDS
IF THERE. AND USED CAN BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION AND REINCORPORATED
INTO THE BUDGET SO WE DO HAVE A
MECHANISM IN PLACE. ON TWO TWO
SWEET THOSE FUNDS IF THEY'RE AN
EXPANDED AND RE ALLOCATE THEM
QUICKLY. AND THAT MEANS THAT
THEY WOULD BE UNUSED BUT IT
WOULD COME IN THE MAY REVISION
AND REQUIRE LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL. TO RE APPROPRIATE FOR
ANOTHER PURPOSE. CORRECT OKAY
IN. OUR MAINTAIN A- LIST OR IS
THE SOMETHING IN POWER. WERE WE
CAN FIGURE OUT WHO IS GOING TO
APPLY BECAUSE IT. NOT A FORM OF
CONTACTED ME. AND I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IF I'M GETTING A
FAIR READ- BECAUSE I'M ONLY
HEARING FROM THOSE THAT ARE NOT
COMPLYING AND IT'S A LONG LIST.
CERTAINLY SO NO THERE IS NO
PUBLIC LIST AND WHERE WE ARE
KEEPING TRACK OF WHO IS OR WHO
ISN'T APPLYING BUT- IN TERMS
THAT WE CAN WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN GET
YOU CONNECTED UP WITH FOLKS WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN APPLYING FOR
THE PROGRAM SEVENTY COULD IT IN
ANOTHER QUESTION. I DID ASSUME
WITH TWENTY- PRESIDENTS OF
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS TEACHERS
UNIONS IN THE NORTHERN HALF OF
MY DISTRICT. AND THERE WASN'T A
ONE THAT THOUGHT THEY COULD
COMPLETE THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING OF THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED IN TIME. FOR THIS
APPLICATION PROCESS EVEN IF THE
DISTRICT WANTED TO APPLY. IS
DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO
REFLECT ON THAT ARE THEY WRONG.
WHICH IS THE THIRD CERTAINLY WE
HAVE- WE HAVE RECEIVED. SIMILAR
FEEDBACK THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE ABILITY OF
SPOKE TO MEET THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT
REQUIREMENTS I THINK- IT'S A
LITTLE IT'S A LITTLE MORE
COMPLICATED JUST BECAUSE THERE
ARE ONLY EIGHT OUT THERE WHO
CURRENTLY HAVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS- THAT DO
ALIGN WITH THEIR SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS- AND WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
WITHOUT NEEDING TO RENEGOTIATE
CLAPS THAT'S ONE I THINK
IMPORTANT THING. TO KEEP IN
MIND ARE THEY- ARE THEY IN
GENERAL ARE ONES THAT HAVE A
HYBRID. A PROBE IF DOCTOR WITH
PARTIALLY REOPENED SCHOOLS. SH
IT IS NOT SUPER CONSISTENT- BUT
YES MANY OF THEM ARE HYBRID
MODELS WHICH ARE AND WITHIN THE
DEFINITION OF OPEN AND FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THE GRANT.
CONSISTENCY THERE I THINK
THERE'S A CONCERN THAT'S BEEN
EXPRESSED IN PEOPLE THAT HAVE
TALKED TO ME. THAT THE HYBRID
SCHOOLS ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IN MORE AFFLUENT DISTRICTS AND
THEREFORE IF THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT HAVE THE EXISTING SAVINGS
A SAFETY PLANS AND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS THEY HAVE
A LEG UP IN THISPROCESS BEFORE
YOU GET TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT MIGHT BE MORE
DISADVANTAGED. SO THAT IS A
CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN EXPRESSED.
BERMAN BE JUST ONE MORE BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT WILL HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS. COMING OUT OF THE
PANEL. THAT RUN SOME OF THE
SUBJECTS AND LET ME JUST ASK IT
AGAIN I THINK I KNOW WHAT THE
ANSWER IS. BUT WHEN YOU
PREPARED THIS PROPOSAL WHEN
THERE WAS THE MONEY FOR THE
SUPPORTS AND THERE WAS THE
MONEY THE TWO BILLION FOR RE-OPENING AND IT'S ROUGH IF I
REMEMBER RIGHT AT SIX POINT SIX
BILLION TOTAL. AND THEN A
COUPLE OF DAYS LATER HERE COMES
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS SIX
POINT SEVEN BILLION. AND I GOT
THE IMPRESSION THAT YOU THINK
NOT A DOLLAR. FROM THE FEDERAL
MONEY WOULD DISPLACE ANYTHING
THAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR AND
STATE MONEY FOR SCHOOL SCHOOL
RE OPENING IS THAT CORRECT. SH
SAID WE SEE OUR PROPOSAL AS
BEING- COMPLEMENTARY TO THE
FEDERAL FUNDS. L. AS AS I'M
SURE YOU KNOW ON THE FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED BASED ON
TITLE ONE NUMBER TITLE ONE
STUDENTS BETTER BEING SERVED BY
ELEAZAR. OUR PROPOSAL ALLOCATE
FUNDS BASED ON TOTAL SELF
INTERFACE GRANT CENTURY I'M
THAT ADJUSTED FOR LTSS OF METAL
CONCENTRATION GRANT FACTORS- SO
WE WOULD GET OUR OUR GRANT
ENSURES THAT MORE LEDS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING ON A
GREATER AMOUNT OF FUNDING-
WHERE AS THE TITLE ONE FUNDS.
AT THE FEDERAL AFTER FUND AND
ALLOCATE ON TITLE ONE- ARE A
LITTLE MORE TARGETED AND TO
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES AND SO
I THINK WHEN YOU PUT THE TWO
PIECES TOGETHER YOU'RE ENSURING
THAT NOT ONLY IS THERE A STRONG
EQUITY COMPONENT IN ENSURING
THAT THE LOWEST INCOME. AREAS
YOU'RE GETTING THE MOST FUNDING
BUT ALSO THAT EVERYONE IS
GETTING ACCESS TO FUNDS TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS FOR THE COST
OF IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. THREE
ONE OF THE INTERESTING THINGS
THAT HAPPENED LATER IN THE
BUDGET A COUPLE. A. WAYS INTO
SENATOR MAN. S. ABOUT HIGH
RIDGE. FOR AND THE FOR THAT THE
PROPOSAL IN THE BUDGET DOESN'T
BRING IT BACK TO WHERE IT WAS
PRETTY PANDEMIC. AND THE ANSWER
WAS. WHAT THEY'RE GETTING
FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE FEDERAL
FUNDS WILL BRING THEM HIGHER.
AND IS THAT A DIFFERENT CASE
WHERE WHAT COUNTING THE FEDERAL
FUNDS TO HELP PEOPLE IN HIGHER
EDUCATION BUT NOT IN K. THROUGH
TWELVE BECAUSE- IT'S TIED ONE
IN K. THROUGH TWELVE AND
THEREFORE. IT'S A DIFFERENT
BROUGH BURKE BECAUSE IT SEEMS
TO ME THE PRINCIPLES THE SAME
IT'S JUST THE OPERATION IS
DIFFERENT BETWEEN THE TWO. NO I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT WAS OUR-
THAT WAS NOT OUR THOUGHT
PROCESS AND IN TERMS OF
COMPARING THE TWO BECAUSE IN
IN. IN PRACTICAL SENSE AND
WE'RE NOT HAVING THE SAME
EXPECTATIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS OF THE
ARCADE TWELVE. LOOK SCHOOLS WE
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR K.
TWELVE STUDENTS TO BE BACK IN
SCHOOL AND IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND THAT THEY HAVE
UNIQUE AND SIGNIFICANT NEED-
BEYOND OBVIOUSLY OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION TUDENT HAVING IT AS
WELL BUT I THINK THAT THEY NEED
TO K. TWELVE STUDENTS ARE MUCH
MORE SIGNIFICANT SO IN OUR MIND
FOR K. TWELVE IT'S NOT ABOUT
GETTING BACK. TO WHERE WE WERE
IT'S ABOUT ENSURING THAT THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO
SERVE THESE KIDS AN IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
THESE DOLLARS I APPRECIATE THAT
I WAS JUST OPERATE ON THE
PREMISE OF THE FEDERAL MONEY
DISPLACED ONE AND DIDN'T
DISPLACE THE. NO MORE ABOUT TO
HEAR PANELISTS THAT ARE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT THIS BUT I
THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD CONTEXT
FOR THE PANEL SAYS AS THEY
PERCENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR INTO OUR
PANELISTS AS WELL AND I DO
APPRECIATE MEDICARE YOU BRING
TOGETHER ALONG WITH THAT YOUR
LAYERED AS WELL FOR THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING. AMEND CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TOJUST TO ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS- WITH MISS HOLMES
ALRIGHT IN JUST WANNA. TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU KNOW WE
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE ARE IN AN INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING TIME- IN WITHIN THE
PORTFOLIO THAT MISS HOMES HAS.
SOME OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
TO GREATLY APPRECIATE HER WORK-
AND ALSO THE OF FOUR BILLION
pTO THE LEARNING LOSS.
MITIGATION IT WAS CRITICAL BUT
CANDIDLY MORE STILL NEEDED.
VENTURA TAKE THROUGH- A FEW
QUESTIONS HERE REAL QUICK- SO
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING ON THE TWO
BILLION IN THE FOUR FIFTY. PER
STUDENT AND HOW THAT WAS LANDED
UPON. CERTAINLY AND FIRST IN A
REQUIRED THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR KIND WORDS THEY'RE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED- SO IN TERMS
OF THE CALCULATION OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PER STUDENT-
WE- WERE LOOKING AT- AND- IN
KEEPING IN MIND THAT. WE'RE
WE'RE BUILDING ON A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT HALF OF WHAT
THE TAKE UP RATE IS GOING TO BE
WITHIN THE GRANT I THINK IT'S
MISTER LAYARD. MENTIONED
EARLIER- WE'RE LOOKING AT WE
WERE SENDING A TAKE UP RATE OF
ABOUT 70% AND WITHIN THE TWO
BILLION- INTO LOOKING AT THAT
AND- ASSUMING A BASED GRANT.
FOR FIFTY AND THREE THIRTY
SEVEN FIFTY RESPECTIVELY FOR
THE FEBRUARY FIRST APPLICANTS
IN THE MARCH FIRST APPLICANTS.
AND THEN- TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
THAT YOU PERHAPS ABOUT HALF
WOULD RECEIVE THE FEBRUARY RATE
IN ABOUT HALF OF. THE MARCH
RATE- WE KIND OF TOOK THE
FUNCTIONS TOGETHER WE ALSO LOOK
AT- WHAT THAT THE COSTA NEEDS
WE'RE GOING TO BE- FOR AND- FOR
PROVIDING THAT THE NAME OF THE
CARD YOU HEALTH AND SAFETY
PURSUANT TO THE MOST RECENT
HEALTH. AND SAFETY GUIDANCE
THAT WAS RELEASED. AND
OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT GIVEN THE FACT THAT
MANY ELEAZAR- HAD INVESTED IN
DIFFERENT PRIORITIES- PRIOR TO-
COMING TO THIS POINT PRIOR TO
THE CHANGES IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY GUIDANCE SO- MAKING SOME
KIND OF RUSSIA'S FUNCTIONS
ABOUT THE COST AND THEN ALSO
MAKING SOME ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
THE FACT. THAT THE FUNDING THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING IS GENERATED ON
A TOTAL PER PUPIL- EIGHTY EIGHT
BASIS. TELL HER A FOR ALL.
STUDENTS AND A LOOK LIKE YOU. A
WITH EXCEPTION OF STUDENTS.
STUDY BUT WOULD ONLY BE USED.
FOR STUDENTS AND STAFF WHO ARE
PROVIDE INCREASED INSTRUCTION
KNOWING THAT. THE GENERATION OF
THE FUNDS- THE ACTUAL IMPACT
PER PUPIL OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION WOULD BE
HIGHER. THAN THE PER PUPIL
AMOUNT PROVIDED AND THEN ALSO
RECOGNIZING THAT WE ARE WAITING
IT YOU KNOW SIMILAR TO LCS
FASTER AND DUPLICATED STUDENT-
THAT THAT WOULD BE. IN PERFECT-
YOU KNOW HIGHLY ASSUMPTION
BASED. ON METHODOLOGY THAT WE
USED IN COMING UP WITH THOSE
NUMBERS- AND THE TWO BILLION
AND THEN ALSO YOU KNOW WE BUILT
THIS WE DIDN'T KNOW THAT
FEDERAL FUNDS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE BUT- YOU KNOW WE HAD-
SOME INDICATION THAT THERE
THERE COULD BE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL RESOURCES. SO I'M
TRYING TO KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
WELL AS THE BRICK BUILDING NEXT
TO ENSURE THAT WE WEREN'T- YOU
KNOW NOT NOT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE FACT THAT THERE
WOULD BE. ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
IN APRIL A DEEP DIVE I THINK
THAT THE CONCERN IS IN WOULD
LIKE BE TO GET YOU TAKE ON THE
AS WE HAVE MOVED FORWARD- AND-
SEEN THE CHALLENGES THAT
DISTRICTS FACING NINETY WANT TO
USE AN EXAMPLE. SO IF WE'RE TO
LOOK AT WHAT THE STATE IS
PAYING POTENTIALLY FOR TESTING
IS THIRTY EIGHT DOLLARS TO
FIFTY BUCKS FOR TEST. IN FOR
PROVIDING A SMALL DISTRICT
WHICH IS SAY IT'S A THOUSAND
STUDENTS. THAT FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY JUST ON TESTING AND ON
THE REGIMENT THAT IS- IN THE RE
OPENING PLAN- IT IS GOING TO
EAT UP THAT FOR FIFTY JUST ON
TESTING. SO IT HAS THERE BEEN
SOME ADDITIONAL ASSESSMENT ON-
FIVE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS ARE
GOING TO BE NEEDED TO BE ABLE
TO ASSIST DISTRICTS I JUST USE
THAT ONE EXAMPLE. ON TESTING
BECAUSE THE CHEAPEST AND ALL
THAT I JUST GOT OFF THE PHONE
WITH THE MENDOCINO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SUPERINTENDENT. THE CHIEF IS
TODAY BEEN ABLE TO FIND ON THE
SALIVA BASED TEST IS BETWEEN
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT AND FIFTY
DOLLAR. FIGURE SO IF YOU COULD
JUST. COMMENT ON THAT BECAUSE
THAT I'M VERY CONCERNED IN
REGARDS TO WHAT THAT'S GONNA
MEAN IN THE REQUIREMENTS. ON
DISTRICTS JUST. ON THE TESTING
SIDE TO BE ON MAKE IT WORK.
ABSOLUTELY AND COMMON ECHO
OTHER THAT THAT WE HEARD IT
WELL AND- IT. I THAT- I THINK
THAT WHEN GENERALLY SPEAKING
WHEN- CBO THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
BASICALLY REGARDS TO THE
TESTING- I THINK- YOU KNOW I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT
COOKER TAKING TO ACCOUNT A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT THINGS TO
MANY AT THAT THE MODELS THAT.
THAT COULD HAVE APPROACHED ME
ABOUT- REALLY LOOK AT AND
PROVIDING. A TESTING FOR EVERY
STAFF AND EVERY STUDENT-
KNOCKING NOT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE FACT THAT- YOU KNOW
NOT ALL STUDENTS. AND STAFF ARE
GOING TO TEACH YOU TO GO BACK
TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION BLACK
ONE PIECE- OR NOT AFFECTED THE
NECESSARY TO GO BACK TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION- LEAD YOU
KNOW. FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS WITH THE BASE GRANT
PARK YOU PAUL BUT THAT AMOUNT
IS INCREASED- WHEN YOU'RE
SERVING AND YOU LOOK AT IT.
STUDENT THE STUDENT TO OUR LOW
INCOME ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE- UP TO AROUND THE SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLAR CRISTINA RANGE
DEPENDING ON YOU KNOW THIS
DIDN'T GENERATE SUPPLEMENTAL.
AND CONCENTRATION GRANTS- AGREE.
YEAH THAT'S THAT'S WITH THE
PIECE OF THAT THAT WE CAN BE
HIGHER AND THEN- EMPHATICALLY
GO AHEAD NOT TO HEAR THAT BUT I
GUESS IT CAN AYE AYE. SO IF IS
SEGMENTED BURN THIS IS. HOW OF
THE POT. IS DOING. THOUSANDS
TO. FIVE TOTAL STAFF AND
STUDENTS ARE TESTED WE- THAT'S
A BURN RATING. THAT A WEEK. IN
ESPECIALLY SMALL DO. THAT ARE
IN. SOME TYPE OF AND POOL
SANDRA. DADDY'S GOING TO BE A
C. CHAO TO BE ABLE TO MEET. OUR
IN THE TESTING REQUIREMENTS IS
CURRENTLY INDICTED WITH THE RE
OPENING PLAN SO HAS THERE BEEN
SOME ADDITIONAL THOUGHT AFTER
HEARING FEEDBACK FROM SCHOOL
LEADERS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
THERE MAY NEED TO BE. A SECOND
THOUGHT ON FOR EXAMPLE THE
TESTING. AND THE ONE OTHER
THING THAT I WOULD MENTION- IS
THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE- WE ARE
SEEKING A WAY A MEDIC HOW LABOR
TO ALLOW SCHOOLS. TO YOU KNOW
PAY FOR MUCH OF THEIR STUDENT
TESTING DRAMATIC HOW FOR THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
THAT'S JUST ANOTHER PIECE IN
ALL OF THIS THAT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IS PUBLIC AND PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW I THINK I
THINK WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE
FUNDING FOR THIS GRANT- IN
ADDITION TO FUNDING- THAT.
LEADS ARE GOING TO RECEIVE
THROUGH THE FEDERAL AND ESTHER
FUND. WE FEEL LIKE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES- AND SUFFICIENT.
RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED TO PROP
UP. A HEALTH AND- STRUCTURE
THAT IS THAT SIMILAR TO AS
OUTLINED IN OUR GUIDANCE- IN
TERMS OF THE TESTING ITSELF YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR YOUR YOUR
YOU'RE SPOT ON WITH YOUR THIRTY
EIGHT FIFTY DOLLARS THAT IS
THAT IS WHAT I UNDERSTAND TO BE
THAT THE RATE FOR TESTING BUT-
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT THINGS
LIKE. FOOLING TESTING- TO TRY
TO BRING DOWN THE COST YEAH
EVEN MORE SO- SO WE ARE WE ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO ENSURE
THAT CASTING CAN BE- DONE AS AS
EASILY AND AS INEXPENSIVELY AS
POSSIBLE I'M ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT FOLKS HAVE
APPROACHED ME ABOUT IS THE COST
OF INFRASTRUCTURE. RELATED TO
YOU I'M PUTTING A TESTING SITES
ON THEIR SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING INTO IS THE POSSIBILITY
THAT TEST TEST CAN BE TAKEN
HOME- AND ENDED MINISTERED AT
HOME AND THEN BROUGHT BACK SO.
WE ARE WORKING VERY HARD TO
ENSURE THAT THE TESTING
COMPONENT IS NOT THE BIGGEST
BARRIER IN ALL OF THIS AND THAT
IT MADE AS- AN EXTENSION AND
EXPANSION OF POSSIBLE FOR
SCHOOL AND- TEN MANAGER ONNA
KEEP MOVING HERE I THINK MY- MY
CONCERN AT THIS POINT IS WILL
MEDICARE NOW. THAT BILLION
REIMBURSEMENT BE UP AND RUNNING
BY FEBRUARY FIRST SO- IT'S NOT
I TRIED TO TRUST BUT VERIFY BY
THE DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO
TRUST US TO BE ABLE TO GET IT
DONE IN THE SECOND PIECE IS- IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. PULLING
TESTING I JUST DON'T HAVE A
FALSE START I DON'T THINK ANY
OF US WANT TO HAVE A FALSE
START WE DON'T WANT TO OVER
PROMISE AND UNDER DELIVER END
ACROSS THIS NATION WE SEE THAT
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AND-
TERRENCE THE LAST THING THEY
NEED IS A FALSE START. SO MANY
PARENTS WANT TO GET THEIR KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL TEACHERS WANT TO
REMAIN SAFE TO BE TO KEEP THEIR
FAMILY SAFE AND IF WE DON'T
HAVE TESTING UP AND RUNNING AS
IS REQUIRED THEN I'M DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT IT WILL BE A
FALSE START AND I JUST WANTED
TO PUT THAT OUT THERE AND I
KNOW THAT CAN YEAH DISCUSSIONS
ARE GONNA CONTINUE. MANAGER
VERY QUICKLY- ON THE
REQUIREMENTS IN REGARDS TO- IN-
REAL OPENING PLAN WHEN IT. TO
IN TO CONNECT. SO I. IS
DISTRICTS ARE GONNA HAVE TO
SEARCH THAT EACH OF THIS. IT'S
BEEN A DISTANCE LEARNING HAVE
TO CONVENE A COMPUTING DEVICE
SOFTWARE AND HIGH SPEED
INTERNET THAT'S NOT HAPPENING
NOW. SO IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
RURAL CALIFORNIA AND ESPECIALLY
HELLO EASE HUMBLED DOWN OR
COUNTY TRINITY COUNTY. STUDENTS
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET IN FACT THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND PLAN WITH A SATELLITE
PROVIDER- WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
SIGN UP HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS BECAUSE OF THE PRICE
TAG. SO IF THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT DISTRICTS ARE
GONNA TO CERTIFY THAT STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO
BE ABLE TO CERTIFY. YES I AM
I'M NOT SURE IF THAT QUESTION
WAS DIRECTED AT ME BUT I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND YOU KNOW I
MEAN IT'S A IT'S A COMMON IN
ITS THE TRUTH I MEAN FOR RURAL
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE STILL DOING. PACKET
PICK UPS BECAUSE STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS. YOU CAN'T GET A
HOT SPOT. YOU CAN'T GET A
SIGNAL FOR WIFI IN YOUR HOME.
IN MOST ARE LOW INCOME SO I
JUST THAT REQUIREMENT IN THERE
THAT DISTRICTS GRANT TO CERTIFY
INTO THIS DEPENDENT ON THAT
CERTIFICATION DEPENDING ON RE
OPENING THIS IS MORE OF A
COMMENT- THEY'RE JUST NEVER
GOING TO BE A MEET THAT HURDLE.
SO I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME AYE I'M- THOUGHT OF A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH- I THINK
EVERY DISTRICT HAS BEEN TRYING
LIKE HELL TO BE ABLE TO GET
THERE. IT'S JUST AT NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN. RULE REMOTE AND
CANDIDLY. FOR KIDS AND- THE
IT'S- THIS. PANDEMIC IS ONLY
MADE THE CRISIS MORE CUTE. ON
THAT QUICKLY I'M GONNA GO TO
THE NEXT. ON THE OTHER CONCERN
THAT I HAVE IS THAT DISTRICTS
ARE PUTTING ALL THEIR APPLES
INTO ONE BASKET I'M SAYING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BASE OUR RE
OPENING AND WILL USE ON
VACCINATIONS IN BECAUSE OF A
VARIETY OF CHALLENGES BOTH
NATIONALLY AS WELL AS HERE IN
THE STATE. ON THERE NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO HIT THOSE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IN THERE
AND- YOU- SO I'M ALSO VERY
CONCERNED THAT WE HAVE THIS
PATCHWORK ACROSS THE STATE OF
SOME- DISTRICTS OPENING UP
BASED OFF OF WEALTH SOME
DISTRICTS OPENING UP THAT HAVE-
HIGHER VACCINATION REGIMEN
THAT'S FOCUSED. ON AND IF WE
LOOK AT THE CHANGING
VACCINATIONS- DEPLOYMENT BASED
OFF OF THE NUMBER OF
VACCINATIONS AVAILABLE THERE'S
DISTRICTS IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL
AND WILL USE IT WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO OPEN IF IT'S ALL BASED
OFF OF GETTING THEIR STAFF
VACCINATED. SO IF YOU DON'T
MIND COMING HERE NEXT I THINK
THAT IS A GROWING FIRE CANDIDLY.
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FACE.
I ITEMS HOMES IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT. AS CERTAINLY I
THINK PERHAPS AND MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER ALLEN MIGHT AND BE ABLE
TO SPEAK A LITTLE MORE-
ELOQUENTLY TO THAT TO THAT
QUESTION SURE THANK YOU. YEAH I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT I THINK OR
WHAT BECOMES CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT YOUR POINT CENTER IS
THAT. AS WE LOOK AT THE
CHALLENGES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON HIS PLACE FUNDS
IN TERMS OF SUPPLY. FOLLOWING
BACK SEEN. IT UNDERSCORES THE
NEED TO REALLY CONTINUE HAVE
SUCH AS THE ALL THE MITIGATION.
MEASURES THAT WORKS ARE PART OF
THE STATE SCHOOLS FOR ALL PLAN
CONTINUE TO BE CRITICAL AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE CRITICAL.
TALK ABOUT EVERYTHING FROM
ASKING TO DISTANCING- TO WEAR
APPROPRIATE YOU KNOW USING THE
SURVEILLANCE TESTING. ALL THOSE
MEANS EVEN WITH VACCINES- WILL
HAVE TO BE PART OF THE
EQUATION- WELL WE TRY TO FIGURE
OUT AND GET THE SUPPLY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS STEP. UP
AND BE A PART OF A PLEA. I
THINK THE CHALLENGE WITHOUT CAN
TALK MASK NOW WE WANT THERE ARE
DAYS. HUNDRED TODAY ARE THE
STATE RIGHT NOW BASED THEIR MO
OPEN PLANTS WITH THEIR
BARGAINING UNITS BASED OFF OF
VACCINATIONS. SO I AM THAT.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH SUPPLY SO IF
WE'RE BASIN AND IN PLEASE YOU
KNOW BETTER THAN AYE YALL- IN
REGARDS TO HAVING COMMUNICATION
WITH THE PUBLIC EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AT I'M COMMUNITY. BUT
YOU TALK TO CERTIFICATED
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
ADMINISTRATORS THERE'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH SUPPLY THERE ARE SOME
COUNTIES ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO NAIL IT THERE ARE OTHER
COUNTIES ARE NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO GET CLOSE. SO I JUST I WORRY
ABOUT THAT I THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER FRANKLIN I'M NOT TRYING
TO THROW STONES IT IS FOR JUST
BEING PRACTICAL. I'M VERY
CONCERNED IN REGARD TO IT FOR
BASING. ALL OF OUR RE OPENING
PLANS OFFER VACCINATIONS SHOULD
WE ALSO BE LOOKING AT READ AND
HAVING AN EITHER OR WHATEVER-
BASED OFF OF INFECTIONS FOR
HUNDRED PEOPLE. ORG IN THE
PURPLE AND GETTING EVERYONE
VACCINATED MIGHT MY LAST PIECE.
WILL BE- ON. CDPH A- I WANT TO
SAY DOCTOR GOLLY IS THE BEST
AND SO GRATEFUL. WE HAD A- A
CALL AS SOON WITH FIFTY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND MENDOCINO
AND HUMBOLDT COUNTIES. CDPH
DIDN'T HAVE THE BANDWIDTH TO BE
ABLE TO JOIN THE ZOOM. I TO BE
A TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE- I ONLY
SAY THAT IS THIS IS NOT THROWN
A STONE AS HE PH BECAUSE
THEY'RE INCREDIBLY BUSY. BUT I
JUST WORRY IF WE'RE LOOKING AT
ALL THE DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE. MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
VERY CLEAR GUIDANCE BEFORE WE
GO BACK IN BECAUSE I AGAIN I
FALL START- IS JUST GONNA ROYAL
THE PUBLIC- EVEN MORE THAN
ENOUGH FOLKS ALREADY ARE AND
ESPECIALLY PARENTS AND I SAY
THAT PERSONALLY BECAUSE- MY
WIFE IS AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
PRINCIPAL IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL
DISTRICT- AND- OBVIOUSLY
TEACHERS CLASS FIND PARENTS ARE
FACING INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH VENTURE I
APOLOGIZE WE'RE GOING SO LONG
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU.
TO MR- IS HOMES AS WELL AS MR
ALLEN. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE WE'RE GOING TO GO
REMOTELY NOW. TO SENATOR
GLAZERS SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK
YOU AT YOUR LEYVA THANK YOU DID
YOUR COMMITTEE BOTH COMMITTEES
FOR PROVIDING THIS OPPORTUNITY
FOR AN IMPORTANT. CONVERSATION
THE MAJESTIC KNOWLEDGE NOT
CHALLENGING IT HAS BEEN FOR OUR
ENTIRE SCHOOL COMMUNITY. YEAH
WE ALL CARE. ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN IRAQ UNHAPPY- AND
EVERYBODY'S WORKING VERY HARD
AND I WANT TO APPRECIATE. ALL
THOSE EFFORTS. AND CERTAINLY I
SURE THE GOALS OF THE GOVERNOR
TO GET. KIDS BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM WITH A- WITH THAT
TYPE OF UP MUCH MORE VALUED-
INSTRUCTION. I SURE CENTER
REQUIRES CONCERNS ABOUT
TESTING. THE COST OF TESTING
AND HOW THAT REALLY PRACTICALLY
IT CAN REALLY HAPPEN. AND I'M
NOT GOING TO GO ANY FURTHER
THAN I THINK HE'S A GOOD JOB OF
LAYING THAT ISSUE OUT. I DO
WANT TO BRING UP ANOTHER-
ISSUE- REGARDING THE ON SITE
INSTRUCTION. CRITERIA. FOR THE
GRANT MONEY. THERE ARE NONE
CLASS BAY. SCHOOL THAT- SERVE
HIGH- AT RISK STUDENTS- EDIBLE.
IN CLASSROOM AS WELL AS AN
ONLINE MODEL. AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE-
CRITERIA THAT THAT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS ESTABLISHED
WOULD PREVENT. ANY OF THOSE.
HYBRID PROGRAMS FROM BEING
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE GRANTS SO
I'D LIKE TO ASK. I GUESS THE
REP FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAYBE TO SPEAK TO THAT.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER SO- WHEN WE WERE LOOKING
AT HOW TO ALLOCATE FUNDS ONE
THING THAT WE CONSIDERED WAS-
YOU KNOW WHICH- WHICH ELEAZAR
HAS FAMILIES LOST THEIR CHOICE
ESSENTIALLY AN IN PERSON OR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION- YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY FAMILY TO OUR TO THE
NON CLASSROOM BASED MODEL ARE
CHOOSING- LEN EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. THAT THAT THEY'RE
CHOOSING TO FORGO AND IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND WHILE I
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS ALSO HAD IN PERSON
COMPONENTS. AND THEY WERE
CERTAINLY ABLE THEY ALREADY HAD
THE- PROGRAMS AND- FOR JUSTIN
LEARNING AND A FAMILY TO ME TO
TRY REALLY PARTIALLY TO.
LEARNING I'M PRIOR DEPEND. WE
DEFINITELY LOOK AT THAT WHEN WE
WERE KINGS ALLOCATION THE TWO
BILLION IT THAT I'D LIKE TO
MENTION HOWEVER IS THAT WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT IN. THE IS THE
SETTING- THAT THERE COULD BE
LEARNING LOST OR OR LOSS OF
SERVICES- RELATED TO GOING TO A
FULL DISTANCE LEARNING MODEL AS
OPPOSED TO A HYBRIDISED
INCURRING MODEL WHICH MANY
ATTENDEES. AS YOU MENTIONED SH-
AND THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
INCLUDED THEM AND AS BEING
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION IN EXTENDED LEARNING
TIME ACADEMIC INTERVENTIONS
GRANT SHE TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE ALSO ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM
THE PLAN. AND TO ADDRESS ANY
GAPS THEIR STUDENTS HADN'T
SERVICES AND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. THAT WE REALLY
BOUNCED AS THOSE PRIORITIES AND
CONCERNS AND LOOKING AT BOTH.
OF THOSE WHAT THE FUNDING. WHAT
THANK THANK YOU FOR THE EXPO-
IT JUST SEEMS THAT IF THE IF
GOAL. A TO. PROVIDE GRANTS ON
AND IF. YOU HAVE SCHOOLS THAT
ARE PERFECT GOING TO. THAT
THEY'RE GONNA MEET THAT- THEY
SHOULD BE DISCRIMINATED. JUST
BE THEY'VE- THIS SO CALLED NOT
CLASS FROM. MODELS IF THEY'RE
PROVIDING THAT INSTRUCTION IN
THE CLASSROOM IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
SHOULD BE CONSISTENT ACROSS THE
BOARD AND REWARD THAT EFFORT.
AND THE COST THAT THAT GO INTO
PROVIDING FOR THAT. THAT
BENEFIT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BUT I'M SURE. THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER CENTER CORTESE. THANK
YOU- FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT
TO SAY THAT- EIGHT WITHOUT THE
TRYING TO MAKE A LOT OF-
REDUNDANT COMMENTS I JUST WANT
TO SAYS SO SHE- OF MOST ABOUT I
WOULD SAY WITH WHAT I'VE HEARD
THUS FAR FROM MY COLLEAGUES
HERE- AMADEUS. IT STRIKES ME
THAT THERE'S- A SEQUENCING
ISSUE HERE THAT IT JUST JUST
SEEMS LIKE IT. I THOUGHT
THROUGH IN TERMS OF IN TERMS OF
THE PLAN AND WHEN THEY SAY THAT-
I I'M CERTAINLY A BELIEVER IN
IN PLANNING IN. YOU KNOW BY
BACKING INTO A CRITICAL PATH
PUTTING THE DATA OUT THERE AND
SAYING HERE'S WHAT WE NEED TO.
TO DO. A TO ACCOMPLISH DELIVERY
ON THAT DATE OR AT THAT THE- I
DON'T THINK THAT'S WITH THIS IS
STILL BASED ON. HOW IT'S BEEN
EXPLAINED TO US. IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S BEEN A DATE THE
STARBURST. A F. CUT WHICH-
JOINT. SOMEBODY MISTER ALAN I
THINK YOU KNOW YOUR YOUR SHOP
IF YOU WILL- MAY BE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE BUT
THERE'S A DATE THAT'S UP
WANTING TO BE OUT THERE AS THIS
IS THE DAY WE WANT TO TELL THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS CAN RE OPEN. BUT.
YOU KNOW A MUCH OF WHAT'S BEEN
SAID HERE TODAY IS NO SECRET-
TO ANYONE INCLUDING THOSE WHO
PARTY PRESENTED COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS. HAVE THE
IN SERVICING OF TEACHERS BUILT
INTO THEM AND THERE'S A CERTAIN
NUMBEROF IN SERVICING DAYS AND
OTHER EMPLOYEES. SO WHY WOULD
WE CREATE LOAD WE SET UP A DATE
AND AGAIN I DON'T MEAN TO BE
CRITICAL BUT I'M TRYING TO USE
LEARNED LIVED EXPERIENCE OVER
THE LAST. ELEVEN MONTHS WHY
WOULD WE DO ANYTHING WITH
REGARD TO COALBED BY SETTING UP
A DATE- WITHOUT ACKNOWLEDGING
THE CRITICAL PATH THAT WE KNOW
EXISTS ON THE CRITICAL PATH IN
THIS CASE WOULD BE. PUBLIC
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THEY HAVE TO
GO BACK IT'S IS NOT A QUESTION
OF WHETHER THERE. WHETHER
THEY'RE THEIR UNIONS- ARE ARE
BEING OBSTRUCTIONISTS OR
ANYTHING ELSE IN TERMS OF THE
TRAINING IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT'S GONNA NEED TO BE
NECESSARY TO OPEN THOSE DOORS
UP. THEIR CONTRACTS.
HISTORICALLY AND ALWAYS IS FAR
AS I KNOW WILL HAVE. AN IN
SERVICE DATES THAT ARE SET UP
AND ESTABLISH AHEAD OF TIME FOR
VARIOUS DISCIPLINES KNOWN
ANTICIPATED THIS- SO THERE IS
NO ONE. KNOWS CONTRACTS ARE
GONNA ARE GOING TO. SCRIBE BUT
IN SERVICE TRAINING FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES. FOR THIS.
SO WE KNOW THAT. SO WOULD MAKE
MORE SENSE TO INVEST IN IT AND
BY THE WAY AS WE ALL KNOW IT
TAKES MONEY TO DO THOSE IN
SERVICE DATE SO WOULD MAKE MORE
SENSE. TO START OFF Y SAYING
OUR FIRST INVESTMENT WE REALLY
WANT TO GET SCHOOLS OPEN WE ALL
AGREED THAT AND HEARD ANYONE
SAY WE DON'T WANT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION START AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BUT IT. WOULD MAKE
MORE SENSE TO SAY OUR INITIAL
INVESTMENT. NEEDS TO BE TO GO.
FUND THAT THE IN SERVICING THE
INSERVICE TRAINING THAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN. IT CAN THAT. I THINK
WE CAN SET A DATE THAT'S
REASONABLE FOR WHEN THAT SHOULD
BE ACCOMPLISHED IN SOON. MS ALL
SAYING YOU HAVE TO GO SLOW TO
GO FAST BUT I'M NOT SUGGESTING
WE GO SLOW WOULD MAKE MORE
SENSE. TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
OBVIOUS PLEASE IT'S NOT AS IF
WE HAVE. I'M A- YOU KNOW SOME
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS OUT
THERE THAT DON'T HAVE THAT
REQUIREMENT. SO WOULDN'T WE
JUST ATTACKED THAT. FIRST AND
THEN SOMEONE CAN BEGIN WITHOUT
BEING REDUNDANT BECAUSE I SAID
I AGREE WITH MUCH OF WHAT HAS
BEEN SAID IF YOU TAKE. THE
PUBLIC RELATIONS ISSUE IF YOU
TAKE THE CALL CENTER ISSUE
THERE'S GOING TO BE. THOUSANDS
THOUSANDS OF CALLS COMING INTO
THE SCHOOLS IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THAT ARE YOU CLIP
WITH MAYBE ONE ATTENDED
SECRETARY. AND ONE TRUANT
OFFICER. THE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ANSWERING PEOPLE'S QUESTIONS
ABOUT HIS MY COULD SUPPOSED TO
BE IN SCHOOL OR NOT- SO WHAT
MAKES SENSE. TO INVEST IN IN
THAT PIECE FIRST AND AGAIN
PARDON ME IF THAT EXIST THERE
SOME. HOTLINE AT HELLO YOU KNOW
AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT IS
GOING TO BUILD THAT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO ANSWER THOSE CALLS
ON BY WAY OF- EXAMPLE HAVING
BEEN A COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN.
ONE OF THE LARGEST COUNTIES IN
THE STATE TOWARDS CUTTING THE
BAY AREA. WHICH WAS AN ORIGINAL
HOT SPOT I JUST CAME FROM THE
ENVIRONMENT. OF HAVING TO
HANDLE IN MY OWN OFFICE. AS DID
FOR OTHER COUNTY SUPERVISED
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND. EMAILS AND-PHONE CALLS PER MONTH MOST OF
WHICH WERE NOT DIRECTLY IN OUR
DAILY WORK AND HAD TO BE
REFERRED OUT ELSEWHERE. THAT'S
WITH TEN STAFF DEVOTED TO
CONSTITUENT RESPONSE HOW DOES
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT DO THAT HOW
DOES THE SCHOOL DISTRICT TO
THAT CERTAINLY THEY'RE GONNA
GET THOSE CALLS OR IS OUR
EXPECTATION THAT THE COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. ARE
CERTAINLY GOING TO BUILD THAT
CAPACITY. AND SOMEHOW HANDLE
THOSE CALLS. FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT SO. MY FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION IS DOES ITEMS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY.
SENATOR PENN SENATOR LAYERED
CENTER MCGUIRE THIS FORMS
CONVERSATION AS TO THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE DONE. IT WOULDN'T
MAKE SENSE TO GO BACK AND BUILD
THAT SEQUENCE AND THEN SEE WORK
WHERE THE DAY. WHAT DATE WE CAN
LAND ON IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY
GETTING THE WORK DONE. AND I
THINK THAT QUESTIONS HONEST
ROMAN BUT THE HOME PART OF IT
MAY BE FOR FINANCE OF THE
SERVER GRAYSON COOKE A BURNING
ISSUE SIR. SO AND WELCOME TO IF
I KNOW IF YOU DON'T. SENATOR I
LIKE TO TAKE A FIRST STEP BACK.
AND CERTAINLY AND MISTER ALAN
CAN. ADAM I'M I CAN'T SPEAK. TO
HOW- SO THAT YOU CAN HANDLE-
THAT THE MANY THAT
COMMUNICATION THAT THEY
RECEIVED FROM. FROM COMMUNITIES
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE- THANK
DISTRICT ADMIN. WHO ARE ON THE
NEXT PANEL. I WOULD DEFINITELY
DEFERRED TO THEM ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE HANDLING MATCH. BUT
YOUR LARGER QUESTION ABOUT
ABOUT BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FIRST PRIOR KIT
COMMITTING TOWARDS RE. OPENING
AND IT'S AN EXCELLENT QUESTION-
AND WE- THEN WE HAVE BEEN. IN
INTO TO BILL OUT THE- AND YOU
KNOW TO BE FAIR TO EVERYONE ON
IT HASN'T BEEN A PERFECT
PROCESS BECAUSE AS AS YOU WELL
KNOW THE SITUATION AT IN
CHANGING IT'S BEEN VERY FLUID
AND ALL BEEN TRYING TO KEEP.
KEEP UP WITH BUT THE CHANGING.
ENVIRONMENT BUT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACTUALLY PROVIDED
THE COMPLAINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS TO SCHOOL DON'T YOUR
TOTAL FEDERAL AFTER FUN- AS
WELL AS LEARNING LAST
MEDICATION FUNDS TO ADDRESS
STUDENT NEEDS- AND- HELP. HIM
AT THE ACT THAT WERE. RIGHT NOW-
TO HELP SCHOOL YOU KNOW PLAN
ANY JUST Q. THE COMPANY TEN.
ANY DISTANCE LEARNING THAT
ALLOW OF. BOOKS FOR. AND AS
WELL AS- KEY IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION BECAUSE- WE ALSO
PROVIDED AND- DELIVERIES. AS HE-
SO THAT DISTRICTS ACCESS RIGHT
AWAY THE BEGINNING THE LAST
YEAR. I'M IN OF THESE ISSUES
AROUND CASTING. A PARTY. YOU
KNOW WHAT WE TALK TO THE
LARGEST DISTRICT- AND WE TALK
TO THEM ABOUT THE BLANKS. THEY
HELENS WE DON'T NEED THAT WE
ALREADY OUR TEST YOU KNOW I
TESTING. UNPLANNED AND AN
AGREEMENT IN PLACE AND THAT WE
NEED THE WHOLE A LOT WE KNOW
THE IF RUSSIA A LARGER. MANY OF
THE AND- ALREADY IN PLACE. IN
ADDITION REGARD TO VALENCIA LAB
UNDER PART IN A PUBLIC IS
ALREADY SET UP A HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR. AND PILOTS ON CAMP. I'M
GONNA BE MENTORED THE LUNCH THE
A LOT. I JUST I MENTION ALL OF
THE- TICKLER. THAT HAS. BEEN A
GOOD DEAL. OF IN. BILL IMPROPER.
FOR COMING BY AND PER AND-
UNTIL I KNOW THAT THAT I CAN
GIVE IT HIGH. AND TO WRECK. IN
TURN OF. YOUR CONCERN ABOUT THE
TIME LINES AND OR NOT RELIGION.
ARBIT DEFINITELY NOT AND YOU
KNOW WE'VE WE BEEN THING ABOUT
WE CAN THAT HOW WE CAN GET AND
PER INSTRUCTION CLASS MARCH-
AND WE UNDERSTAND BASED ON OUR
CONVERSATIONS AND CERTAINLY ONE
THING THAT'S WONDERFUL ABOUT
THE K. TWELVE SCHOOL COMMUNITY
IS THEY'RE NOT QUIET ABOUT-
THEIR CONCERNS AND THAT THE
ISSUES AND BARRIERS THAT THEY
FACE NOT A GOOD THING BECAUSE-
THEY MAKE SURE THAT WE KNOW IT.
AS WELL AS THE BUILDING TOWARDS
OUR PROPOSAL. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU KNOW IT WHEN YOU SEE THAT
THE FEBRUARY FIRST AND MARCH
FIRST DATE AND THEN THE SORT OF
THE- THE- THE ROLLING EVERY
OPENING FOR HIGHER TRANSMISSION
AND- AND DISTRICT AND ONLY
EIGHT. CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE
HAD IN MIND WHEN WE BUILT THIS
PROGRAM OUT. AT THE SAME TIME
WE ARE REALLY TRYING TO BALANCE
THAT WITH A SENSE OF URGENCY WE
HAVE AROUND GETTING KIDS BACK
INTO THE INTO THE QUESTION A
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THIS
SCHOOL YEAR. IS ENDING QUICKLY
AND AS SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN
WORKING IN THIS SPACE AND LAST
MARCH- AND HAS HAD BEEN THERE
SINCE WE WERE THINKING YOU KNOW
BECAUSE YOU'RE ONLY GONNA LAST
A COUPLE WEEKS AND INSTEAD
THEY'RE GONNA COME BACK- THE
SCHOOL YEAR GOES BY VERY
QUICKLY. AND BEFORE YOU KNOW
IT- YOU FINISH THE SCHOOL YEAR
INDISCIPLINE BURNING AND THEN
HE STARTED ANOTHER SCHOOL YEAR
AND DISTANCE LEARNING. AND THEN
YOU FINISH THE FIRST SEMESTER
AND- LEARNING AND I THINK WHAT
WE'RE REALLY REALLY TRYING HARD
TO DO IS TO TELL THE JUDGE MUCH
OF THE SCHOOL YEAR AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN KNOWING THAT WE
ARE ALREADY IN JANUARY. AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DON'T HAVE PLANS IN
PLACE TO OPEN OKAY BYE. APRIL
VERY UNLIKELY THAT THEY WILL
OPEN. AT ALL. FOR THE REST OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR- AND THAT WE
JUST. IF WE ARE IN JUST
LEARNING AT THE END OF THE YEAR
WHICH THAT MEAN FOR NEXT SCHOOL
YEAR AND THAT IS THE- GOOD.
HEARING THAT WE HAVE. SO IN
TERMS OF I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THAT YOU YOU WONDER. THAT THIS
IS THAT IS NOT OUR. ISRAEL HAS
HAD A LOT OF. GOING INTO IT.
AND THEN I WILL TURN OVER TO
THE- ALLEN. FURTHER IN. THE
QUESTION. AT MISS HOLMES GOT.
TH MAJORITY OF WHAT I WOULD
SHARE AYE ONLY JUST. TACK ON
THE- IT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THESE DATES THE ARE MADE. RIGHT
THIS ISN'T THE HAVE TO BY THIS
THIS IS WITH TO HELP FOR. A
MEMBERS STRUCTURE GRANT IN HIS
MID HOLMES NO. ON THAT WILL
MOVE IN TERMS OF DEPENDING ON
THE CASE RATE IN COUNTY LOCAL
HEALTH FIRST OF. BUT WHEN
YOU'RE A TO BRING THE BACK AND
WAS JUST LIKE OUTSIDE THIS IS
REALLY ON BOTH. A SUPPORTING
THOSE WHO- OPEN TO ENSURE THAT
CAN BE TO OPENED SO. PROVIDING
THE PRODUCTIONS. THEIR AND
STAFF IN STUDENTS I AS WELL AS
AND IN WAITING REALLY. ON VERY
INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO BUILD I
THINK IN THE WAY THAT YOU
HIGHLIGHT SENATOR A VERY. UP
THOUGHTFUL- PHASED IN APPROACH
THAT FOLKS ON. BACK THIS TO IN
THE EARLY IS GREAT WERE THOSE
ARE NOT YET OPEN. WHEN YOU'RE
UNDER THOSE CASE REYES ARE
PUBLIC EXPERTS HAVE TOLD IS
RIGHT. TO LOOK AT. AND TO. THAT
MOMENTUM. A WITH THOSE EARLIEST
BASED ON THE SIZE ABOUT- THERE
ABILITY- TO TRANSMIT AND THE
FACT THAT SLOWER. I AS WELL AS
INSTANT A PRIORITY IN TERMS OF
THE LEARNING NEEDS I IN THOSE
EARLY AS GRADES AND WITH OUR
MOST DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
STUDENTS. AND SO THE GRANT IS
STRUCTURED IN A WAY THAT REALLY
EMPHASIZES THEIR NEEDS AND
MEETING THEM AND THEN BUILDING
THAT UP IN A PHASE WAY. ON
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU ARE. IN
YOUR CASE RAISING YOUR COUNTY.
I HAD TAKEN THAT FORWARD SO
BUILDING ALL THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT I'M IS HOMES HIGHLIGHTED
IT'S BEEN. A BUILT IN FUNDING
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED SINCE
LAST. LAST MARCH AND LAST
BUDGET- THIS IS REALLY QUITE
INTENTIONAL AND THE DATES ARE A
SIMPLE WAY OF. PROVIDING THAT
THE URGENCY FOR THAT PHASE IN
PROCESS. OF THE MISS HOLMES
IOWA. IT YOUR BY YOU SAY. BUT
THEN AGAIN I WANT TO CLARIFY
I'M COME FROM ON SIDE OF IT IS
I IT'S NOT A MAY- I THINK MORE
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM AND MOST
PEOPLE THAT ARE. I TO VIRTUALLY
HERE UNDERSTAND ALL THE FACTS
AND WHAT'S GOING ON AND HOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WORK I WAS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER. IN THE
LARGEST HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR EIGHT
YEARS- I GET IT. BUT WHAT. THE
PUBLIC DOESN'T UNDERSTAND AND
THIS GOES BACK TO SOME COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUES HERE
REGARDING. THE PUBLIC
COMMUNICATIONS I CAN MENTION
THAT TO. HIS THEY HEAR THAT
SCHOOLS CAN OPEN NOW. AND IN IN
ORDER TO HANDLE THE RESPONSE TO
ALL THE CLASSROOMS SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
OPEN THERE NEEDS TO BE CAPACITY
BUILT FOR THAT- IT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO JUST SAY WE CREATED
SOMETHING HERE. AT CENTRAL
COMMAND THAT'S NOT MANDATORY.
BUT WE JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW.
THAT YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN
OPEN UP IF THEY WANT TO. OR IF
THEY'RE READY. WITHOUT BUILDING
THE CAPACITY TO ANSWER ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT COME ALONG WITH
IT NOW I THINK HONESTLY AND I
DON'T MEAN THIS TO BE FACETIOUS
AT ALL BUT IF THE ROLLOUT OF
THIS GRANT PROGRAM WANTS TO
SAVE EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE
DISCLOSED THAT'S BEEN DISCLOSED
TO US TODAY AS AS A AS A
FOOTNOTE AS A AS A FULL LAUNCH
RAMPS MATTER FOR TRANSPARENCY.
YES YOUR SCHOOL THIS IS CAN
OPEN UP NOW BUT ONLY IF THEY'VE
SET. BUT ONLY IF THE CERTIFIED
THEIR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
REQUIREMENTS I'M OLY IF THEY
PROPERLY IN SERVICE AND TRAIN
THEIR EMPLOYEES. I'M ONLY IF
THEY'VE BEEN APPROVED FOR THE
GRANT MAY HAVE BEEN A FUNDING-
ONLY THERE'S ONLY THERE'S ONLY
THERE'S ONLY THIS AND ONLY THIS
AND- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC YOU
HE SHOULD UNDERSTAND. THE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS WILL NOT
BE OPENING I MEAN IT'S ALMOST
BURYING THE LEAD TO DO IT ANY
OTHER WAY. RENDON C. SCHOOLS
CANNELLA OPEN THE FALCONERS
WERE REALLY SEEN AS MOST
SCHOOLS WON'T OPEN. BUT WE WANT
YOU TO KNOW WE HAVE A PROGRAM
FOR THE FEW THAT ARE ABLE TO
MEET THESE GUIDELINES THAT'S A
MUCH DIFFERENT PUBLIC RELATIONS
STATEMENT AND FRANKLY I DON'T
WANT TO BE PUT IN A POSITION.
AS A MEMBER A NEW MEMBER THE
STATE SENATE. TO BE TRIED TO
EXPLAIN WHY WE ROLLED OUT A
PROGRAM. THAT IS GOING TO THE
VERY NOBLE THING THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. OPENING UP
CLASSROOMS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
SO KIDS DON'T GET. FURTHER
BEHIND. ONLY ONLY TO HAVE WHAT
HAPPENS ON THE GROUND. COME
BACK THROUGH CONSTITUENT
CASELOAD IN MY OFFICE THE
COUNTY SUPERVISORS IN MY
DISTRICT. IN SAN JOSE THE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND CITY
CENTERS IN FOURTEEN OTHER
CITIES THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS FROM THIRTY DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS TRYING TO ANSWER. THE
QUESTION. WELL IF. IF THE STATE
SAYS THIS CAN HAPPEN BEEN
HAWKING IT'S NOT HAPPENING. IT
CAN ONLY ASKING ON THAT PIECES
WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY IS IT TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY TO ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS. FOR THE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND KIDS
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY ALONE I
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE NUMBER
IS IN THE REST OF STATE. IN AND
I'M NOT HEARING THAT ANSWER BUT
I THINK WHAT I'M HEARING IS.
THE LOCALS WILL TAKE CARE OF
THAT. YOU KNOW WE'VE- WE'VE
WE'VE WORKED ON THIS FOR A YEAR
AND THEY KNOW THIS IS COMING
THEY'LL TAKE CARE OF IT I DON'T
THINK THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
TAKE I KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY CARE OF IT. SO WHERE
WERE WORD IS THAT. WHAT WHAT
HAPPENS THEN IT IT JUST LOOKS
LIKE A KICK OF COMMUNICATIONS
TRAIN WRECK TO ME IF WE DON'T
IT LEAST TAKE CARE OF THAT
PIECE SO- I KNOW IT WAS A
COMMENT REGISTER- WANT TO GET
THAT OUT THERE. THANK YOU AND I
WOULD LOOK FOR TO ANY KIND OF
CONSTRUCTIVE. OUR POLICY
RESPONSE WOULD BE THAT'S COMING
FROM THE LEGISLATURE THIS
COMMITTEE. YOU KNOW FOR THE
DEPARTMENT ITSELF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE THANK
YOU TO ALL OF OUR MEMBERS WHO
HAD QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS I
WANT TO WRAP UP WITH A COUPLE
QUESTIONS MYSELF. I WANT TO
DRILL DOWN A LITTLE BIT ON
SOMETHING SENATOR LAYERED
PRODUCT- JUST A THIS WOULD BE
FOR YOU MS HOMES WHICH AND HOW
MANY ELEAZAR TOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY WILL
APPLY FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
GRANTS. I THINK WE NIBBLED
AROUND THE EDGES BUT I'M SURE
YOU GUYS HAVE AN IDEA OF WHO'S
GOING TO USE AND HOW MANY. I
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION I'D
HAVE TO GO BACK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FIND OUT WHO
THEY'VE BEEN TALKING TO BUT I
CAN WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH THAT
INFORMATION. OKAY BECAUSE I
ALSO HAVE NOT HEARD FROM
ANYONE- IN MY DISTRICT AND
SURROUNDING DISTRICTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
GUIDELINES. AND TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE MONEY SO I'M JUST. JUST
I THINK I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OUT THERE. THAT WANT
THAT THINKS THIS PLANET IS
WORKABLE BECAUSE I HAVE NOT
FOUND ONE- AND CONSIDERING THAT
THE VERY FEW L. ET. IT LIAISE-
TO BE. IN ON INTERESTED IN
PURSUING THESE GRANTS- AND
TIMING IS A MAJOR MAJOR
OBSTACLE. WHY IS IT
MINISTRATION HOLDING FIRM TO
THE ACCELERATED TIMELINE LINES.
CERTAINLY SO AGAIN AND WHEN WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE FEBRUARY
FIRST ST AND THEN THE MARCH
FIRST ST AND WE THINKTHAT YOU
KNOW FOR ITS FIRST GOLD WHO ARE
MORE PREPARED- WHO ARE MOSTLY
ALL THE WAY THERE ARE PERHAPS
ALREADY OPEN- BACK HAVE YOU
WORRY FIRST DATE- OBVIOUSLY- IT
IS IT'S REACHABLE ARE
ATTAINABLE BECAUSE THEY ARE YOU
KNOW VERY CLOSE TO THAT TO THE
ONLINE ALREADY- IN TERMS OF THE
MARCH FIRST DATE THAT IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE DISTRICTS
WERE NOT CURRENTLY READY
ADDITIONAL TIME TO MEET THE-
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS. AND THEN
AND THEN HERE TO YOUR COMMENT
ABOUT WHY THEY'RE STILL
XCELERATED AGAIN I THINK I
WOULD JUST REFER BACK TO MY
PREVIOUS COMMENTS AROUND.
TRYING TO SALVAGE AS MUCH OF
THE SCHOOL YEARS AND POSSIBLY
CAN. NO ONE DISAGREES WITH THAT
WE ALL WANT OUR KIDS BACK
LEARNING MY CONCERN IS THERE
ARE SCHOOLS THAT ARE OPEN WHICH
DO WE HAVE A LIST OF WHICH
SCHOOLS ARE ACTUALLY OPEN AND-
AND- DOING INSTEAD AND PERSON
INSTRUCTION. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
NO WE DO NOT HAVE OR I'M SORRY
GO AHEAD JOHN. I WAS ON SITE-
ONLY DO. SO I WAS JUST GONNA
RECORD. THAT ONE OF THE DIRECT
THE CAME OUT THURSDAY ON THAT
WE WILL HAVE THAT INFORMATION
STARTING WITH FOLKS REPORTING
NEXT MONTH UP SENATE THAT
DIRECTIVE ON BECAUSE THAT IS A
QUESTION THAT WE KNOW IS THAT A
VERY MUCH OF INTEREST YOURSELF
AS WELL AS US. SO WE MADE THIS
PLAN NOT KNOWING WHAT SCHOOLS
ALREADY OPEN. OKAY SO MY OTHER
QUESTION IS ABOUT VACCINES I
DID NOT SEE ANYTHING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON HOW WE
WOULD GET TEACHERS AND STAFF
VACCINATED FOR IN PERSON
LEARNING HOW IS THAT GOING TO
WORK. A DIFFICULT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I WOULD WANT TO DEFER
TO SOME OF MY PUBLIC HEALTH
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE NOT HERE
WITH US TODAY ON THAT QUESTION.
AND WE CAN CETAINLY RELATE
THAT QUESTION TO THEM AND HAVE
THEM CONTACT YOUR STAFF. SO IF
IT'S NOT BUT IF IT'S NOT IN THE
PLAN DOES THAT MEAN THERE IS NO
PLAN TO VACCINATE TEACHERS AND
STAFF. RIGHT I JUST DIDN'T SEE
ANYTHING IN- SAY SCHOOLS FOR
ALL PLAN REGARDING VACCINES-
THE PLAN DOES NOT INCLUDE A
REQUIREMENT AROUND VACCINES- IT
REALLY WERE INCLUDED SAID THAT
THE FOCUS REALLY IS A MORE
ROUND AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
MEASURES LIKE MASKING- AS WELL
AS YOUR MAILING TESTING- THAT
DOES NOT MEAN THAT- IN THE
STATE IS NOT AND YOU KNOW
ANTICIPATING AND ENSURING THAT
BACKS NATION CAN BE PROVIDED-
TO TEACHERS AND STAFF AND BUT
IT'S JUST NOT PART. OF THIS
PARTICULAR PLAN OKAY I JUST
PERSONALLY THINK IT'S HARD TO
ASK- TEACHERS AND STAFF TO GO
BACK WHEN THERE'S NO PLAN TO
VACCINATE THEM AND WE DO KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNOR CHANGED THE
PLAN NOW FOR VACCINES TO BE
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT OUR FRONT
LINE WORKERS. ARE GOING TO BE
LEFT OUT OF THAT NEW PLAN. TOP
I'LL JUST LEAVE IT IS A CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
ALL OF OUR QUESTIONS I HOPE YOU
CAN STAY WITH US- TO THE NEXT
COUPLE PANELS IN CASE WE HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS. BUT WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL. AND WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH- SHELLEY. MAYER MONTEZ WHO
IS THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
CAMPBELL UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT
WELCOME DOCTOR VIA MONTEZ.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE HERE AND I- REALLY
THOUGHT I WOULD START WITH
TELLING JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
OUR STORY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
LIKE MANY DISTRICTS AND- WE
BEGAN LOOKING TO RE OPEN AND
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF.
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AND
ANYONE IN MY DISTRICT WOULD SAY
THERE HASN'T BEEN ANYONE MORE
COMMITTED TO THAT AND I'VE BEEN
BUT I'VE ALSO. REALLY WANTED TO
HONOR OUR LABOR RELATIONS- AND
WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR AND WE
WERE PARTNERS AND SO AS A
RESULT WE DEVELOPED A DISTRICT
WIDE RE OPENING COMMITTEE WAY
BACK IN THE SUMMER WHICH WAS
COMPRISED OF. OUR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM OUT OUR
DISTRICT INCLUDING OUR PARENTS
AND WE WORKED WITH THE
GUIDELINES THAT WERE PUT OUT BY
ERICA COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. AND I AM HAPPY TO
SAY THAT AFTER THIRTEEN
NEGOTIATION SESSIONS WITH OUR
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND FOUR
SESSIONS WITH OUR- CSEA
CLASSIFIED UNITS AND WORKING
WITH OUR PARENTS. WE WERE ABLE
TO COME UP WITH A REAL OPENING
PHASE PLANET VERY MUCH MIRRORS
WHAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED HERE-
THAT WE WOULD START WITH OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS FIRST
AND THEN WE WOULD START WITH
OUR YOUNGEST AND- GRADUATE THAT
UP. THAT IS ALL PREDICT ON US
BEING IN THE RED TIER IN OUR
COUNTY AND SO. WHEN I FIRST
HEARD ABOUT THIS TWO BILLION
DOLLARS I WAS QUITE EXCITED
BECAUSE WE HAD MATT MOST OF THE
METRICS AND THEN AS WE STARTED
LOOKING CLOSER AT IT I BECAME.
VERY DISILLUSIONED- I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SURVEILLANCE REQUIREMENT FOR
STUDENTS I HAD NOT. IN ANY OF
BY MEETINGS HEARD THAT THAT WAS
GOING TO BE PART OF THE
EXPECTATION WE WERE ABLE TO
STAND UP SURVEILLANCE TESTING
FOR ALL STAFF. AND THAT HAPPENS
MONTHLY. BUT THE REQUIREMENT
FOR THE TUDENT TESTING REALLY
MADE NO SENSE TO ME BECAUSE WE
WERE PUSHING OUT THE SCIENCE
FROM UCSF AND FROM STANFORD TO
OUR FAMILIES SO THAT THEY WOULD
FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE THAT WHEN
WE'RE READY FOR. THE PHASE AND
REOPENING. THE OUR OUR STUDENTS
TWELVE AND UNDER JUST AREN'T AS
IN AS MUCH DANGER AND SO WE
WORK TOGETHER UNDERSTANDING OR
TEACHERS UNION OUR CLASSIFIED
STAFF HAVE NOT EVER. SUGGESTED
THAT WE SHOULD TEST STUDENTS SO
THEY WOULD FEEL MORE SAFE AND
SO THEN LOOKING AT. THE EXPENSE
FOR SURE BUT ALSO JUST THE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITY I
MEAN WE'VE ALREADY HAD TO STAND
UP TRACKING AND TRACING WHICH
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
ADDITIONAL PERSONNEL FOR THESE.
REQUIRE REST BUT WE HAVE
FIGURED IT OUT AND SO WE HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN OPEN WE
RUN PRESCHOOLS. WE ALSO RUN
EXPANDED LEARNING AND WE HAVE
HAD LEARNING LABS WHERE OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS ARE
COMING IN AND THEY'RE EITHER
BEING SUPPORTED. BY CLASSIFIED
STAFF- SO THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO ENGAGE IN THEIR
DISTANCE LEARNING BEING
PROVIDED BY A CREDENTIALED
TEACHER OR WE HAVE SOME OF OUR
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS. WHO
EVEN BEFORE WE WERE IN RED
WE'RE WILLING TO BRING THEIR
STUDENTS END BUT WE DID THAT ON
A VOLUNTARY BASIS RATHER THAN-
REQUIRING OUR WHOLE SYSTEM TO
COME BACK PRIOR TO WHAT WE ALL
HAD AGREED TO. AND I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IN ADDITION
TO THE STUDENT TESTING
REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD BE
EXTREMELY ONEROUS. AND I WAS IN
A MEETING WHERE IT WAS
DESCRIBED THAT STUDENTS COULD
SELF ASSESS WELL SOMEONE'S
GOING TO HAVETO MONITOR THAT
PROCESS SELF ASSESSING
SOMEONE'S GONNA HAVE TO COLLECT
ALL OF THAT SOMEONE'S GOING TO
HAVE TO TRACK THEM THAT'S- IN-
THEN ALSO MINORS. IS THERE
WOULD BE NO REQUIREMENT IF IT
IF A PARENT DECIDED THEY DIDN'T
WANT THEIR CHILD TESTED. THE
CHILD WOULD STILL BE ALLOWED TO
COME INTO THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
WHICH I'M CONCERNED THAT WOULD
CREATE. OF A SENSE OF- WORRY BY
THE TEACHER THAT DIDN'T EXIST
PRIOR TO THIS SO IF THEY HAD
THREE STUDENTS TO REFUSE TO
TEST NOW THEY BECOME SUSPICIOUS
OF WHY THAT FAMILY WOULD.
REFUSE TO TEST WHEREAS BEFORE
IT WAS NEVER EVEN GOING TO BE
AN ISSUE SO I HAVE THAT CONCERN
I ALREADY HAVE THE CONCERN FROM
A SCHOOL SYSTEM. THAT JUST THE
CADENCE OF TESTING THAT WE'RE
DOING WITH OUR STAFF WILL
CERTAINLY PROBABLY INCREASED.
CERTAINLY PROBABLY THAT DOESN'T
SOUND VERY CONVINCING I BELIEVE
WILL INCREASE OUR INSURANCE
PREMIUMS WHICH WILL BE A
ANOTHER ADDITIONAL COST TO US
LOOKING FORWARD- AND SO MY ASK
WOULD BE THAT THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IS. FROM PROP NINETY
EIGHT MONEY AND WHILE YOU KNOW
I'VE HEARD THAT DISTRICTS CAN
CHOOSE NOT TO APPLY FOR IT.
IT'S NOT MY TRADITION TO LEAVE
MONEY ON THE TABLE. I'M AND I
DO BELIEVE THAT THAT WAS MONEY
THAT WOULD GO TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT'S BEING RE
PULLED FOR CERTAIN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND I AM- AS SENATOR
CORTESE OUT ALREADY SHARED
SANTA CLARA COUNTY HAS ITS-
MANY DYNAMICS AND- YOU KNOW OUR
PLAN DOESN'T REQUIRE
VACCINATIONS BUT I WILL SAY I
WAS VERY DISHEARTENED. TO LEARN
THAT IN OUR COUNTY. I'M WE'RE
NOWHERE NEAR GETTING TO THE
LEVEL ONE BEAT FOR EDUCATORS
JUST DOESN'T A PERSONALIZADO
CAL FATHER WHO'S EIGHTY FIVE
YEARS OLD AND HAS EMPHYSEMA WHO
HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET HIS
VACCINATION IN OUR COUNTY- AND
SO. THERE ARE MANY WORRIES AND
I ALSO APPRECIATE THE COMMENT
ABOUT WHO ACTUALLY CONVEYS THIS
INFORMATION AND TRIES TO BREAK
IT DOWN TO OUR- AND COMMUNITY
AND TO OUR STAFF AND SO WE'VE
DEVELOPED THIS COMMUNICATION
CADENCE AND IT'S TAKEN- ELEVEN
MONTHS TO GET TRUST. THAT WE'RE
NOT JUST MAKING THINGS. AND SO
I WILL SAY THAT. I WAS VERY
EXCITED THAT WE HAD OUR PLAN
WE'RE SIMPLY WAITING FOR THE
CONDITIONS TO IMPROVE AND WE'RE
READY TO MOVE FORWARD AND IT
FEELS LIKE YET AGAIN. THE GOAL
POST MOVED AND LIKE THINGS HAVE
CHANGED AND THERE ARE NEW
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE NEVER
KNOWN BEFORE YOU KNOW THAT
TWENTY FIVE CASE RATES PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT HAD NEVER
EVEN BEEN A TERM THAT WAS USED
BEFORE. SO WE WERE GOING OFF OF
THE FOUR TIER SYSTEM I APPLAUD
MY- RIGHT. LABOR PARTNERS FOR
BEING COMFORTABLE TO COME BACK
EVEN WHEN IT'S IN A SUBSTANTIAL
RANGE. AND ALSO THE THIS SORT
OF FALSE EXPECTATION IN MY
OPINION. THAT IT'LL BE TOTALLY
UP TO PARENTS WHETHER OR NOT
THE KIDS ARE GOING TO RETURN OR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION BECAUSE
AGAIN I'M JUST SHARING MY STORY
WITH YOU BUT- BACK IN THE
SUMMER THREE WEEKS BEFORE
SCHOOL STARTED. WE ALLOWED
FAMILIES WE LAID OUT OUR RE
OPENING PLAN. AND WE ALLOWED
FAMILIES TO SELECT IF THEY
LEARNING OR IF THEY WANTED TO
GO WITH A PHASED IN APPROACH AS
IT WAS LAID OUT BASED ON THE
TEARS AND ALL OF THAT. AND WE
WERE THREE I'M IN ROLLED OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM. AND WE MOVE
STAFF AND EVERYTHING SO THAT
OUR PARENTS HAD THAT LEVEL OF
COMFORT. AS I LOOK AT WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED. I READ IT AS
THOUGH THERE WOULD BE AN
EXPECTATION THAT WE WOULD YET
AGAIN THIS LATE IN THE SCHOOL
YEAR UP HE'D EVERYTHING ONCE
AGAIN AND ALLOW PARENTS A
SECOND CHOICE OF WHETHER THEY
WANT TO DO THE FACE AND- RE
OPENING THAT THEY AGREED TO BE
FOR. WHICH WOULD REQUIRE US TO
MOVE STAFF AND ALL OF THAT AND
THERE'S BEEN MUCH CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH. OF OUR
STUDENTS ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
DEVELOPING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
OUR FAMILIES AND WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REALLY GARNER AND
LEVERAGED. A SYSTEM THAT
SENATOR CORTESE IS VERY
FAMILIAR WITH ITS CALLED
SCHOOLING SERVICES WHERE WE CAN
GET OUR FAMILIES CONNECTED TO
RESOURCES. SO ONE OF MY BIGGEST
CONCERNS WOULD BE TO CHANGE
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS SO FAR INTO
THE SCHOOL YEAR BY BASICALLY
ALLOWING PARENTS TO CHOOSE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE GOING TO
STAY WITH THAT TEACHER THAT
THEY'VE BEEN WITH. FOR THESE
SIX MONTHS OF THIS SCHOOL YEAR.
SO YOU KNOW I HAVE MANY MORE
THINGS THAT I COULD SHARE AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. BUT I JUST WANTED TO
LAY OUT. THE PRICE THAT WE'VE
WORKED THROUGH WE WORK THROUGH
EACH PHASE OF THAT WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PLAN THAT
HAD BEEN PROVIDED TO US AND SO
TO HAVE THAT PLAN CHANGE AND TO
HAVE THINGS MOVE. AND TO BE
TOLD WELL IT'S OKAY YOU COULD
JUST NOT GO FOR THE MONEY. THAT
THAT MAKES ME FEEL LIKE I'M NOT
DOING THE MOST FOR MY STUDENTS
AND MY FAMILIES TO LEAVE MONEY
ON THE TABLE. SO BUT I ALSO
VALUE A LONG TERM RELATIONSHIP
WITH MY LABOR GROUPS MORE THAN
THAT THAT FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLARS PER STUDENTS. AND
SO WE HAVE AGREEMENTS WE'RE
GOING TO STAY WITH THE
AGREEMENTS. BUT I'D ALSO LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO GET SOME OF THAT
FUNDING WHEN THE CONDITIONS
ALLOW FOR US TO DO SO. THANK
YOU DR VERMONTERS THAT WAS
REALLY ENLIGHTENING TESTIMONY
AND I SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION I
HAVE NOT BEN ABLE TO FIND A
PLACE TO GET MY PARENTS
VACCINATED EITHER I TRY EVERY
DAY. SO WE WILL ALL KEEP
TRYING- NEXT- WE WILL HEAR FROM
RICHARD BARRERA WHO IS THE
BOARD PRESIDENT FOR THE SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WELCOME MR PERERA. THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SO. SO
MUCH OF. WHAT I'VE HEARD IN
TERMS OF THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
SENATORS AND THE COMMENTS FROM
DR PETER MANTAS AND ALSO YOU
KNOW THEY THE COMMENTS. I FROM
I MISS HOMES AND IN THIS
ROLLAND. ARE SO CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WE HAVE EXPERIENCED EYES
SINCE MARCH SO AND JUST BACKING
UP A LITTLE BIT SO IT'S SENATOR
UNIFIED WERE THE SECOND LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA
AND- WE- ARE EDUCATE DIRECTLY A
LITTLE OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS. I APPRECIATED TWELVE
WE HAVE ANOTHER TWENTY THOUSAND
OUR STUDENTS AND. IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN OUR DISTRICT. ABOUT
THREE PER. OF OUR STUDENTS
QUALIFY FOR FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH ABOUT A QUARTER OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE ENGLISH LEARNERS
ABOUT 15% OF OUR STUDENTS. I
HAVE I EAT PEAS. AND OUR
DISTRICT FOR OVER A DECADE NOW
HAS HAD A CONSISTENT FOCUS ON
EQUITY. YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS ASK
OURSELVES WHY DO WE NEED TO BE
DOING AS A SCHOOL SYSTEM FOR
THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE NO BACK
UP. TO SCHOOLS I'VE BEEN THERE
AND BEING EFFECTIVE WE HAVE A
DIVERSE DISTRICT AND SO WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE. OUR FAMILIES IN
OUR DISTRICT THEY TO HAVE BACK
ABSENT IN CERTAINLY IN THE CASE
OF THE PANDEMIC HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GO AND PAY FOR TUTORS AND
ESTABLISH PODS- BUT- THE SUB
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT. I
NEARLY 90% OF OUR STUDENTS
QUALIFY OF OUR STUDENTS QUALIFY
FOR FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH HIGH
PERCENTAGES OF ENGLISH LEARNERS
THERE IS NO BACK UP I TO OUR TO
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS PROVIDING.
OUR STUDENTS WHAT. THEY NEED.
AND SO. TAKING THAT ON ACT IN
THIS. WE YOU KNOW I IT IT WAYS
I SOMETHING THAT KEPT UP AT
NIGHT. I CLOSING IN FIRST.
BECAUSE WE KNEW WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF I IF I IF OUR
STUDENTS WERE IMAGE EVEN TWO
WEEKS A MONTH I'VE HAD SCHOOL.
AND THE OF BAD WE QUICKLY
JUMPED INTO. PROVIDING I THREE
DAYS A WEEK HI I THREE THREE
MEALS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
TO ALL OF OUR STUDENTS WE
DISTRIBUTED OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND HI COMPUTER DEVICES WE
TALKED OUR STUDENTS UP TO. UP
TO THE INTERNET WE MAINTAIN
THIS CONSTANT FOCUS ON MEETING
THE NEEDS OF ESPECIALLY OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND
THEN AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH I
DEALING WITH THE PANDEMIC. TO
BE FRANK ARE WE WERE GETTING
VERY VAGUE AND IN SOME CASES
CONTRADICTORY I ADVICE I
WHETHER IT WAYS THAT CDC OR
THAT IT'S GUYS CD P. H. R. OR
OTHER I YOU KNOW I ENTITIES.
AND SO WHAT WE DID IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR UNIONS
I'M RATHER THAN ARGUE OVER
SCIENCE AND HAVE YOU KNOW EACH
OF US INVENTING OUR OWN SCIENCE
AND CHERRY PICKING OUR OWN
RESEARCH WE WENT TO A TEAM AT
UC SAN DIEGO. OF
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERTS IN KERALA G. IN AT THE
GENEALOGY IN PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THAT TEAM CAME TOGETHER AND WE
ASK THEM FOR CLEAR GUIDELINES
ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO
SAFELY REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS AND
THEY LAID OUT VERY CLEAR
GUIDELINES FOR US IN EARLY
AUGUST. AND THOSE INCLUDED
COMMUNITY SPREAD METRICS.
POSITIVITY RATE NEEDS TO BE
BELOW 8% I YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT A
LOOK AT HOSPITALIZATION
HOSPITAL CAPACITY ICU CAPACITY.
ALL OF THOSE METRICS. ARE THE
TEAM AT UCSD LAID OUT FOR US
AND THEN THEY SAID NOW IF THE
COMMUNITY IS MEDIAN THOSE
METRICS AND HERE'S WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO IN SCHOOL. FIRST OF
ALL YOU HAVE YOU'VE GOTTA PUT
ALL OF THE SAFETY PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE YOU'VE GOT A REVAMPS
AWAIT YOUR CLASSROOMS YOU GOTTA
PROVIDE MASKS YOU'VE GOT TO
PROVIDE SMALL COHORTS OF
STUDENTS IF YOU COME BACK IN
WHEN YOU COME BACK. I YOU'VE
GOT TO BE CLEANING YOUR
CLASSROOMS EVERY DAY YOU'VE GOT
TO SET UP. I STATION AS- STAGE
IN EVERY. AND WE DID THAT. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE DID WITH YOU
KNOW SOME OF THE FUNDING THAT
CAME. AT THE STATE GENEROUSLY
PROVIDED I YOU KNOW THROUGH
THAT HI I'D THROUGH THE CARES
ACT. WE SPENT FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS PUTTING INTO
PLACE THE MEASURE IS NECESSARY.
TO PROTECT OUR STUDENTS WHEN
THEY COME BACK ON CAMPUS AND
THEN. WE WENT TOGETHER WITH OUR
UNIONS TO UCSD AND WE SAID HOW
FREQUENT SHOULD WE BE TESTING
OURS OUR STUDENTS AND STAFF. IN
ORDER TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS
SAFE. AND OUR MODEL WAS
PROVIDED THAT I THINK IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN THE GOVERNOR'S GUIDELINES.
THAT SAID IF YOU WANT TO
ACTUALLY USE TESTING AS A
PREVENTIVE STRATEGY YOU SHOULD
BE TESTING ONCE TO TWICE A
WEEK. I'M SORRY MARC ONCE A
WEEK TED SAID TO TWICE A MONTH.
AND SO WE SET UP A TESTING
SYSTEM WITH UC SAN DIEGO HEALTH
AND WE HAVE SINCE DECEMBER.
I'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTING THAT
TESTING SYSTEM BUT I WILL TELL
YOU IT TAKES TIME. TO PUT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE FULLY IN PLACE
AND BY THE WAY THIS IS A
TESTING SYSTEM WHERE. UC SAN
DIEGO HEALTH. PROFESSIONALS
COME ONTO OUR CAMPUS IS
DIRECTLY ADMINISTER THE TEST
AND THEN TAKE CARE OF THE
BACKEND INFRASTRUCTURE WE'VE
PUT THAT IN PLACE AND WE'RE
PAYING FOR IT. OUT OF OUR OWN.
OUT OF OUR OWN FUNDS. AND NOW
TOGETHER WITH UCSD AND R. I.
I'D- OUR OUR OUR- I. HEALTH.
ADMINISTRATOR WE'RE GOING TO
THE COUNTY AND WE'RE SAYING
WHAT WILL IT TAKE TO ACCELERATE
GETTING OUR EDUCATORS
VACCINATED. AND WE'RE CLOSE TO
HAVING AN AGREEMENT THAT WOULD-
I SPEED UP. THE PROCESS FOR
GETTING. OUR R. EDUCATORS.
VACCINATED AND WITH ALL OF THAT
IN. ALL THE THAT WE BEEN DOING
A COLLABO WITH ARE YOU. TO GET
US THIS. AND BY THE WAY OF
COURSE WE TO GO. YOU KNOW
AGREEMENTS WITH OUR UNION. TO
FULLY TRANSFORM OUR SISTER INTO
A FOR SYSTEM IN THE SPRING. WE
MAY GO NEW AGREEMENTS I'D SAY
CREATE MORE ROW. DISTANCE
LEARNING MORE WE STARTED IN THE
FALL. I WE HAVE NICK. AN
AGREEMENT WHERE WE ALLOW OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS TO
COME ONTO OUR CAMPUS FOR IN
PERSON. SERVICES WHETHER IT'S
STUDENTS WITH IEPS ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS ARE HOMELESS STUDENTS.
OR STUDENTS WHO SIMPLY ARE
IDENTIFIED BY THEIR TEACHERS AS
FALLING BEHIND IN MEETING IN
PERSON SERVICES AND WE BEGAN TO
BRING SOME OF THE STUDENTS ON
CAMPUS AND WE'VE DONE THAT. FOR
NEGOTIATION. WITH OUR UNIONS. I
HAVE BEEN DOWN ALL OF THE- WHEN
WE LOOK. THE PLAN THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S LAID OUT. THE PLAN
SIMPLY WILL NOT HELP US IT
WON'T HELP US GET TO RE OPENING
ANY SOONER BY THE WAY AND YOU
KNOW I'LL JUST YOU KNOW SAY
THAT AS YOU KNOW FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE DO NOT NEED
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES TO REOPEN.
WE NEEDED TO BE SAFE WHEN IT'S
SAFE WE ARE READY TO REOPEN AND
WE INTEND TO REOPEN WE
CERTAINLY NEED FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO PAY FOR ALL OF THE
THINGS OUR STUDENTS NEED BUT
IT'S NOT ABOUT. FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES WILL PUSH US I TO
REOPEN MORE QUICKLY THAN WHEN
WE BELIEVE IT'S ACTUALLY SAFE
TO DO SO OUR CASE RATE IN SAN
DIEGO OUNTY TODAY. ADJUSTED
CREEK CASE RATE IS OVER SIXTY
PER HUNDRED THOUSAND THE IDEA
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ANYWHERE
NEAR THAT TWENTY FIVE PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND. WITHIN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS WITH IT YOU
KNOW BY MID FEBRUARY IT'S
SIMPLY NOT GOING TO HAPPEN. THE
IDEA THAT IT WOULD EVEN GET
DOWN YOU KNOW INTO INTO THAT
LEVEL BY MARCH OR APRIL IS VERY
MUCH UP IN THE AIR OF COURSE WE
HAVE NOW A SECOND STRAIN. OF
THE VIRUS YOU KNOW THAT'S
MOVING FORWARD THAT MAY CREATE
FOR ALL WE KNOW A NEW SEARCH
AND BY THE WAY WE'RE NOT
WAITING WE'RE GOING BACK TO OUR
UCSD EXPERTS. INSANE LET US
KNOW HOW THE SCIENCE IS
APPALLED AND GIVE US NEW.
GUIDANCE ABOUT WHAT SAFE I
THREE OPEN. WITH ALL OF THAT IN
PLACE HE WHAT WE ACTUALLY DO
ANY. WE NEED. TO GET OUR AND-
BACK. AS QUICKLY AS- THAT HAS
TO. AND IT IS ENTIRELY UP. FOR
OUR EDGE. GIVEN THE RATE THAT
ARE IN OUR COMMUNITY TO STAY.
NOW THAT WERE ON THE VERGE OF
HAVING A VACCINE AVAILABLE. WE
SHOULD GET THAT VACCINE ARE
BEFORE WE TAKE A RISK AND GO
BACK SO WE NEED THAT VACCINE
AND WE NEED IT AS URGENTLY AS
POSSIBLE. WE NEED THE FUNDING
TO POKE FULLY PAY FOR THE
TESTING SOME OF YOUR QUESTIONS
WERE SO ON POINT. UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN IF WE WERE TO
TEST ONCE A WEEK THAT WOULD BE
ABOUT SIXTEEN TESTS. BETWEEN
MID FEBRUARY AND THE END OF
THIS SCHOOL YEAR. OUR
ARRANGEMENT WITH UC SAN DIEGO
IS FOR FORTY DOLLARS A TEST
WHICH IS THE ENTIRE TESTING
PLUS THE INFRASTRUCTURE. SO
THAT'S. SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
DOLLARS PER STUDENT. THAT'S THE
IN. REAL RIGHT RIGHT THERE IF
WE WERE TO SPUR ALL THAT
TESTING AND BY THE WAY WE DON'T
BELIEVE. THAT PROP NINETY EIGHT
SHOULD BE PAYING FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY MEASURES LIKE TESTING.
THAT SHOULD COME OUT OF THE
STATE RECEIVED OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE MOST RECENT
COVERED RELIEF FIND FOR TESTING
WE KNOW THAT THE BY DID
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW IS
TRYING TO MOVE ADDITIONAL
TESTING AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOLS.
THAT'S THE APPROPRIATE PLACE TO
PAY FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY
MEASURES LIKE TESTING BECAUSE
WATER WE NEED THE PROP NINETY
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR. WE NEED IT
NOW. FOR OUR STUDENTS THAT NEED
SUPPORT NOW. WE HAVE A NEED FOR
THE EXTRA CANCELING WE HAVEN'T
NEED FOR EXTRA TIME WITH OUR
STUDENTS EVEN IF THEY ARE
CONTINUING A DISTANCE LEARNING
WE HAVE THE NEED FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS WHO CAN HELP OUR
FAMILIES NAVIGATE. I SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS THAT THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO THEM WHEN WE ARE
TRYING TO EXPAND OUR ON CAMPUS
I IN PERSON SERVICES FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND BY
THE WAY WE'VE- AYE THAT
INCLUDES PRESCHOOL ELEMENTARY
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. BUT THAT REQUIRES
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE THE KIND
OF I SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS NEEDS
SO IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH TO HAVE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS A PROP
NINETY EIGHT MONEY THAT WE WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO USE. THAT WE ARE
I WOULD BE VERY UNLIKELY BE
ABLE TO USE FOR MOST OF OUR
STUDENTS CERTAINLY FOR MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. ANY
TIME DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR TO
TAKE THAT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AND HAVE IT SITTING IN A POT
THAT WE CAN'T USE WHEN WE HAVE
REAL NEEDS RIGHT NOW. FOR OUR-STUDENTS SO OUR RECOMMENDATION
WOULD BE. IN ADDITION TO THE
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION DOLLAR
HI I PROPOSAL FOR INTERVENTION
FOR STUDENTS THAT WE CAN USE
NOW AND INTO THE SUMMER
ACTUALLY I PLAN FOR THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO NEED. TO
OVERCOME WHAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED IN THE PANDEMIC.
TAKE THAT FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS OF PROP NINETY
EIGHT BUNNY. ADD TO THAT THE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS THAT RIGHT
NOW IS IN A FRANKLY UNWORKABLE
PLAN. THAT THE GOVERNOR WAS PUT
INTO RE OPENING AND ALLOW US TO
USE THOSE RESOURCES TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS NOW AND
THEN TO PLAN FOR THE SUMMER AND
THEN TO FOCUS ON WHAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO NEED
GOING INTO THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
AND WHEN IT IS SAFE TO RE OPEN
WE. WILL RE OPEN AT THAT POINT.
WHEN WE HAVE THEIR BACKS. WHEN
THE FINE. I HAD TO DO FULL TEN
THAT. THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS ADVISE US TO DO. AND
WHEN THE CASE RATES. HAVE COME
DOWN TO A POINT. THAT IT WILL
ASK BE SO. YOU KNOW FOR OUR OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR STAFF TO RE
OPEN AND I WOULD JUST LEAVE YOU
WITH KIND OF YOU KNOW THIS.
THIS IS WHAT YOU KNOW KEEPS ME
UP AT NIGHT. IN MY DISTRICT WE
HAVE A LOT OF IMMIGRANT PARENTS
A LOT OF PARENTS WHO TRUST THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. WHEN WE
SAY TO OUR PARENTS. IT IS SAFE
FOR YOUR KIDS TO COME BACK TO
SCHOOL. AND WE HAVE THE RIGHT
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAM THAT'S
GOING TO HELP YOUR KIDS LEARN.
WHEN WE TELL OUR PARENTS THAT.
THEY WILL BELIEVE US. SO WE
BETTER GET IT RIGHT. AND WE
BETTER BE MOTIVATED BY WHAT
ACTUALLY WILL KEEP OUR STUDENTS
AND OUR STAFF SAFE WHAT
ACTUALLY IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAM FOR OUR
KIDS AND THAT BETTER BE OUR
ONLY MOTIVATION AS WE THINK
ABOUT MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS
PROCESS AFTER THE REST OF THIS
YEAR INTO THE SUMMER AND NEXT
YEAR. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
PERERA THAT WAS ALSO REALLY
HELPFUL TESTIMONY THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM CHRIS
EVANS WHO IS THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF THE NEW THOMAS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WELCOME
SUPERINTENDENT EVANS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS THIS
OPPORTUNITY SO I'M CURRENTLY IN
MY NINETY YEARS THE DOMES
INVITES YOU PRETEND IT IN MY
TWENTY NINE YEAR EDUCATION
CAREER I WORKED AS A CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEE SOCIAL STUDIES TEACHER
ATHLETIC COACH SITE LEADER AND
CABINET MEMBERS IN ELK GROVE
UNIFIED FRESNO UNIFIED LODI
UNIFIED AND NOW OF COURSE THE
THOMAS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THE THOMAS UNIFIED
IS LOCATED IN SACRAMENTO AND
IT'S TWICE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
THE NEW YORK TIMES IS THE
SECOND MOST DIVERSE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE NATION WE SERVE
ABOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
OVER HALF OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
ON FREE OR REDUCED LUNCH IN
BETWEEN 62263% OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE IDENTIFIED AS UNDUPLICATED.
FOR ELSE IF THAT PURPOSES OUR
GRADUATION RATE IS CONSISTENTLY
BETWEEN 9495% AND A UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY RATE IS AS HIGH AS
SIXTY TWO PERCENT. SINCE LAST
MARC RICH OUR STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN IN DISTRICT LEARNING IT
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY WE TOOK
WHAT WE ORIGINALLY CALLED A
LONG WEEKEND TO CLOSE SCHOOLS
THE FIRST EXAMINE THE FIRST
STATE GUIDELINES ONCE WE GOT A
CHANCE TO REALLY DIG IN AND
TAKE A LOOK WE REALIZED IT WAS
GOING TO BE A WHILE BEFORE IN
PERSON CLASSES RETURNED. WE
QUICKLY ACTED TO FEED OUR
STUDENTS PROVIDED LAPTOPS TO
EVERY STUDENT WHO NEEDED ONE
DISTRIBUTED MOBILE INTERNET HOT
SPOTS TO ANY FAMILY WHO ASKED
ONE BY ACQUIRING THEM VERY
QUICKLY AND WE EVEN HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME
EXTRAS. WITH OTHER NEIGHBORING
DISTRICTS YOU RANCHO YOUR- AS
THE SIDE NOTE. PROVIDING THIS
IN ACCESS. IS COSTING A TERMS
YOU KNOW. A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLAR A MONTH. BY APRIL WE
MANAGED ELIMINATE DIGITAL IN
THE TRUMP UNIFIED BY SAYS. JUST
YOUR LAPTOP AND HOSP. LIKE WERE
TEXTBOOK BUT THIS TIME USING
YOUR THROUGH UP. LOW AT OUR
SCHOOL SITES WE WILL ONE AS FAR
AS TO TRACK DOWN STUDENTS WHO
ARE HOMELESS AND AT TEMPLE
RELOCATED TO HOTELS IN
NEIGHBORING STATES SAYS CITIES
DELIVERING- THE TECH NEEDS TO
OUR STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY
WHEREVER THEY WERE LOCATED. WE
NEVER EXPECTED THOUGH AT THAT
TIME THAT THIS WOULD CONTINUE
FOR ALMOST A YEAR. DISTANCE
LEARNING WAS PUT TOGETHER
QUICKLY IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY IT WAS ALMOST AN
EMERGENCY ACTION FOR US. IT
TOOK MULTIPLE NEGOTIATION
SESSIONS BUT WE HAD ONE OF THE
STATE'S FIRST MO USE ON
DISTANCE LEARNING WE REMAIN
GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK THAT ARE
DISHONEST TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
ENGAGE WITH. ON THAT. EVEN
UNDER A TWO YEAR CLOSE CONTRACT
WE FOUND OURSELVES NEGOTIATING
TIME AND TIME AGAIN IN THESE
PAST TEN MONTHS. HEADING INTO
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL
YEAR IT WAS UNANIMOUS TEACHERS
PARENTS ADMIN AND OUR BOARD ALL
AGREED THAT DISTANCE LEARNING
NEED TO BE APPROVED. IT TOOK
ALL SUMMER IN A TWO WEEK DELAY
OF THE NEW SCHOOL YEAR TO
NEGOTIATE A NEW FORM OF
DISTANCE LEARNING. THAT WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER THAN THE
EMERGENCY ACTIONS WE'VE TAKEN
IN THE SPRING. WE REMAIN IN
THAT FORM OF DISTANCE LEARNING
TODAY WE DO HAVE SOME SMALL
COHORTS THAT FOR THAT EXIST FOR
SOME OF OUR FIRST RESPONDER
FAMILIES WORKING FAMILIES. AND
HIGH SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS. OR
PARENTAL INTEREST HAS CHOI OVER
TIME. LAST SUMMER IT WAS ABOUT
THE MID 707374% OF OUR PARENTS
WANTED SOME FORM OF IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION BY THE TIME THE
MOST RECENT SURGE BEGAN TO
CLIMB IN LATE OCTOBER EARLY
NOVEMBER THAT IT ACTUALLY
DROPPED 2403% WE ENGAGE OUR
COMMUNITY ON A FREQUENT BASIS
TO GET A POLLS FOR WHAT THEY'RE
SEEING AND FEELING AND THINKING.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE DEVELOPING WHAT
WE CALL AN EIGHTEEN MONTH PLAN
TO ADDRESS LEARNING DISRUPTIONS
AND THE PROPOSAL THAT IS OUT
THERE TO PROVIDE NEW RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS- WHAT IS OFTEN
REFERRED TO IS LEARNING LOS. IS
ESSENTIAL TO FULLY PROVIDE A-
WITH WHAT OUR STUDENTS NEED. WE
BELIEVE THAT LEARNING HAS NOT
BEEN LOST JUST DISRUPTED. WITH
YOUR HELP WE CAN FILL THE GAPS
THAT EXIST FOR OURS ARE OUR
KIDS BECAUSE OF THESE
DISRUPTIONS. WE USE MULTIPLE
DATA POINTS STUDENTS STAFF AND
PARENTS FEEDBACK TO IDENTIFY
THOSE STUDENTS FOR WHOM
DISTANCE LEARNING IS NOT
WORKING OR THERE MAY BE EITHER
ACADEMIC PHYSICAL OR SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DISRUPTION. IN THE
FALL THIS PAST FALL THE NEW
THOMAS UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD DID
VOTE TO REOPEN SCHOOLS AFTER
RENEGOTIATED YET AGAIN ANOTHER
AGREEMENT WITH OUR TO THOMAS
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. THAT
AGREEMENT REQUIRED JUST TWO
WEEKS OF RED STATUS REMAIN OPEN
IN FACT SACRAMENTO WAS TRENDING
TOWARDS ORANGE AT THE TIME SO
RELIGION AMID HOPE AND
OPTIMISM. THEN CAME THE SURGE.
AND WE REMAIN IN DISTANCE
LEARNING. OF THE MAJOR
OUTLINED- ITEMS OUTLINED IN THE
NEW PROPOSAL AND THE
CONSOLIDATED GUIDANCE WE HAVE
NEARLY ALL OF THEM COVER. THE
BUDGET DECISIONS MADE BY
CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR ALLOWED US
TO CONTINUE IN DISTANCE
LEARNING IMPROVE DISTANCE
LEARNING STARTED NUMBER OF NEW
ACTIONS AND PREPARE FOR AN
EVENTUAL IN PERSON RE OPEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR BUDGET
APPROACH LAST YEAR WE HAVE THE
PEAVEY WE NEED WE HAVE REPLACE
ALL OLD FILTERS WITH TALK
POSSIBLE QUALITY FILTERS. WE
ARE PLACE PORTABLE THE FILTERS
AND CLASSROOM AND WORK SPACES
AND WE HAVE HAND SANITIZER SOAP
AND TOILET PAPER TO KERRY IS
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS. WE HAVE
BROUGHT IN A THIRD PARTY
ENGINEER TO CREATE CLASSROOMS
SPECIFICATIONS DESIGN TRAFFIC
FLOW ON CAMPUSES AND DISTRICT
BUILDINGS AND HELP WITH SIGNAGE
SO EACH SCHOOL AND WORK SPACE
WILL BE CERTIFIED AND HAS BEEN
CERTIFIED. BY AN ENGINEER THAT
OUR PLAN IS EFFECTIVE AND SAFE.
FOR OUR EMPLOYEES AND STUDENTS.
WITH THE ADDITION OF RIVER. WE
HAVE OPEN VIRTUAL DURING.
HIGHER MULTI NEW SOCIAL.
FOCUSED FOR HOME AND FOSTER
YOUTH EVEN GOING AS FAR AS
HELPING SH. OUR SOME OF OUR
UNSHELTERED HOMELESS FAMILIES
OF FIND SHELTER FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME WHEN IT WAS EXTREMELY COLD
AND RAINY IN AN EFFORT TO RE
ENGAGE THEIR STUDENTS BACK INTO
SCHOOL AS WE WERE MONITORING
DATA NOTICED THOSE STUDENTS.
OBVIOUSLY BEGAN TO NOT ATTEND
DISTANCE LEARNING WE'VE CREATED
VIRTUAL EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES AND FOLLOWING
SPORTSCARD GUIDELINES WHEN WE
CAN WE'VE KEPT STUDENTS SAFE
DURING SPORTS CONDITIONING WITH
AN AMAZING GROUP OF COACHES WHO
OF ALL THE GUIDANCE AND
CONTINUED TO HAVE A ATHLETIC
CONDITIONING IN PLACE. WE'VE
EXPANDED A TWENTY FOUR HOUR A
DAY THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DAYS A YEAR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT NETWORK THESE ARE JUST
A FEW THE ACTIONS. THAT WE'VE
TAKEN WITH THE RESOURCES MOSTLY
THE ONE TIME MONEY WE'VE. BEEN
PROVIDED IN THE PAST YEAR. IT
BACK I WAS THIS- THE MONEY AND
THE THAT THE STATE TOOK-
DEFINITELY CHANGE LIVES AND
MOST DEFINITELY SAVE SOME LIVES
HERE AND IT'S ALMOST. WELL THE
GOVERNOR SAFE SCHOOL PLAN FOR
ALL HELP SCHOOLS OPEN SAFELY.
TO BE HONEST MUCH OF WHAT IS IN
THAT PLAN IS WHAT WE NEEDED
THIS PAST SUMMER TO OPEN MORE
SAFELY ON TIME FOR THIS PAST
FALL. I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
CRITICAL I'M JUST PROVIDING
ASSESSMENT FROM THE FIELD FOR
SOMEONE WHO IS HELD MULTIPLE
JOB CLASSIFICATIONS IN SCHOOLS
OVER THE PAST THREE DECADES.
AND SHARE THAT PARENTS ARE NO
LONGER LOOKING TO COVER TESTING
THEY'RE LOOKING TO COVERT
VASTLY VACCINATIONS. AND YES
PARENTS HAVE HEARD THE
PROPOSALS FOR RE OPENING IN
PERSON AND WE HAVE BEGIN TO SEE
THE LARGEST INCREASE. OF
COMMUNICATIONS TO OUR
CONSTITUENT CUSTOMER SERVICE
OFFICE OR BOARD MEMBERS AND
MYSELF SAYING QUOTE NOW THAT WE
CAN OPEN. DOT DOT DOT. THEY ARE
NOT AWARE OF ALL THE
STIPULATIONS AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO WORK AND
TRY TO EDUCATE. THE PARENTS ON
WHAT AND WHEN- IT IS POSSIBLE
FOR US TO OPEN BECAUSE AS OF
RIGHT NOW WE ARE AT FIFTY FOUR
POINT 6% BERMAN FIFTY FOUR
POINT SIX CASES. OUT OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND STILL VERY
CLEARLY FAR AWAY FROM THE
TARGET A TWENTY FIVE- FRANKLY-
WE RECOGNIZE THAT- MORE TESTING
IS NOW AVAILABLE- COMPARED TO
LAST SUMMER AND WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE WE UNDERSTAND MORE
ABOUT THE VIRUS AND WE HAVE
MORE ACCURATE NUMBERS ABOUT
WHERE THE BUDGETS ARE. SO IT'S
A LOT EASIER TO DO A LITTLE
BACKSEAT DRIVING NOW TODAY THAT
AND- BACK INCIDENT IN SUMMER
TWENTY TWENTY. SO HOW DO WE
OPEN SCHOOLS SAFELY CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO FOCUS ON A WAY TO GET
VACCINATIONS IN THE ARMS OF OUR
CITIZENS IN A WAY THAT WILL
TRULY ALLOW FOR SCHOOLS TO
REOPEN ITS ESSENTIAL EDUCATORS
ARE PRIORITIZED BECAUSE LIKE IT
OR NOT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EDUCATION IS LARGELY AT IN IN
PERSON STAND STILL FOR A
MULTITUDE OF REASONS. IF WE
HAVE TO FULLY NEGOTIATE THE NEW
GUIDANCE I FOR LITTLE CHATS FOR
EQUITABLE IN PERSON CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION IN THE NEXT FOUR TO
FIVE MONTHS I AM VERY GRATEFUL
THAT IT THOMAS E HAVE A STRONG
LABOR- PARTNERSHIP. WITH RCS
LOCAL SEVEN FORTY FIVE AND NOW
THIS INCREASING PATTERN OF
REALLY DELIBERATE SUCCESS AND
INCREASING POSITIVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR TO
THOMAS. ASSOCIATION LEADERS.
ARE IMHO YOU THAT WAS ACTUALLY
APPROVEDBY OUR TEACHERS AND
OUR BOARD OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY SAYS THAT IF NEW
STATE GUIDANCE IS PRODUCED. THE
TWO PARTIES WILL MEET AND
CONFER. THAT IS LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO BE MORE
NIMBLE TO GET TOGETHER AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS GINS. IF THE OPEN
RE OPENING PLAN REQUIRES
ANOTHER MO YOU ANOTHER PERIOD
OF NEGOTIATIONS THAT AND I DO
NOT BELIEVE THE THOMAS UNIFIED
WOULD BE ABLE TO OPEN. MY CHIEF
ACADEMIC. OFFICER WHO'S IN
CHARGE OF ALL OF ACADEMICS IN
THE THOMAS UNIFIED AND I HAVE
HONESTLY SPENT THE BULK OF THE
LAST YEAR NEGOTIATING THROUGH
THIS PANDEMIC. THIS IS WHY WHEN
WE TALK TO YOU ABOUT OUR
EIGHTEEN MONTH PLAN TO ADDRESS
LEARNING DISRUPTION. WE'RE
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT A PLAN
BECAUSE IS NOT YET DONE. WE ARE
SPENDING TIME- NEGOTIATING AN
ADJUSTING EVERY TIME NEW
GUIDANCE COMES OUT. ON SOCIAL
MEDIA WE CAN SEE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT IN SMALLER
COUNTIES AND EVEN IN
NEIGHBORING COUNTIES. THAT
EDUCATORS ARE BEGINNING TO GET
THE VACCINE. IN AT IN THE
THOMAS WE HEAR WELL SACRAMENTO
IS URBAN. SO IT'LL TAKE MORE
TIME AND THERE ARE MORE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WHEN I HEAR
PEOPLE SAY URBAN I WONDER WHY
THE SECOND MOST DIVERSE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE NATION AND ONE
OF THE MOST INTEGRATED CITIES
IN THE NATION SACRAMENTO IS NOT
WITH OTHER REGIONS IN FRONT OF
THE LINE. TO ME IT'S AN EQUITY
ISSUE A COLLECTION OF
SUPERINTENDENTS WERE INFORMED
THAT THE COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO
NOT NECESSARILY THE HEALTH
PROVIDERS IN SACRAMENTO BUT THE
COUNTY ITSELF RECEIVE JUST NINE
HUNDRED AND CHANGE VACCINES
LAST WEEK. JUST NINE HUNDRED
AND CHANGE VACCINES IN THE
COUNTY'S LARGE OF OURS MEANS
THAT- AS I HEARD A FEW PEOPLE
MENTION EARLIER. I AM NOW
CONCERNED ABOUT THE OPENING OF
SCHOOLS IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SO WHAT CAN OPEN
OUR SCHOOLS WHAT WE REALLY NEED
IS THAT VACCINATION PLAN TO GET
THOSE MILLION THAT ARE STILL
WAITING TO BE DISTRIBUTED OUT
TO URBAN AREAS. LET'S TAKE THIS
PROPORTIONALITY IN DISPARITY
HAD ON. NUST HAS HAD THEIR OWN
TESTING SITE WITH THIS
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND WE'VE
TESTED OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
PEOPLE FOUR COVE ED. WITH JUST
ONE DAY A WEEK OF TESTING
MATERIALS AND WE DO DO OUR OWN
CONTACT TRACING FOR EMPLOYEES
AND STUDENTS. I KNOW THAT'S
FAIRLY UNIQUE. I HEAR FROM
COLLEAGUES AT THE CADENCE OF
TESTING THAT'S BEING PROPOSED
FOR MANY DISTRICTS WILL PREVENT
THE RE OPENING AND MAYBE EVEN
FOR SOME THAT ARE ALREADY OPEN
A RETURN TO DISTANCE EARNING.
I TO OF HEARD THAT MANY WILL
NOT APPLY FOR THE GRANT. IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE OF THE
CADENCE OF TESTING. I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT THIS THIS STATE IS
WORKING ON THAT CADENCE WELL
BASED ON SOME OF THE TESTIMONY
TODAY- POTOMAC COVERED TESTING.
IN OTHER DISTRICTS IS NOT A
CONCERN IT THOMAS UNIFIED
BECAUSE OUR EXPERIENCE AND
COMMITMENT WE HAVE EARNED A
STATE CLIA WAIVER TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A GRANT THAT THE
STATE PROVIDED. THEY HAVE FREE
RAPID COBIT TESTING IN ADDITION
TO OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COUNTY- THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. WE
ARE TO BE ABLE TO TEST OUR
STUDENTS AND WE HAVEALREADY
BEEN TESTING STAFF AND A BROAD
RANGE OF COMMUNITIES MEMBERS.
MARGIN WHAT WE COULD DO FOR
VACCINATIONS. IN THE THOMAS
UNIFIED AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE WILLING WITH ACCESS TO
FOOTBALL STADIUMS. GYMS AND
AMAZING STAFF THAT WOULD BE
WILLING TO STEP UP AND HELP. I
BELIEVE IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE READY TO
RAPIDLY INTO THE BEST OF OUR
ABILITY AS A STATE TO EQUITABLY
EXPAND THE VACCINES AS FAST AS
THE FEDS IN THE PHARMACEUTICALS
WILL PROVIDE US WITH THEM. WE
MUST REMEMBER THAT PERFECTION
IS OFTEN THE ENEMY OF PROGRESS
LET US PROVE WE CAN BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION WITHOUT JUST MORE
MORE REQUIREMENTS BEING GIVEN
TO US FOR A TASK AND RE OPENING
THAT MAKES REAL OPENING IN
PURSING AND- LESS LIKELY. GIVE
US A HUNDRED VACCINES AND WE'LL
GET A HYBRID VACCINATIONS IN
WHOMEVER CALIFORNIA WANTS US TO
SENIORS EDUCATORS WHOEVER THEY
PRIORITIZE GIVES A THOUSAND
WILL DO THE SAME THING. LET US
MAKE A DIFFERENCE THERE ARE
DISTRICTS POSITION TO HELP
VACCINATE AND ASSIST OTHER
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITIES WHILE
PLANNING FOR STUDENT SUCCESS
FIRST WE NEED THE OPPORTUNITY
SECONDLY WE DO NOT NEED MORE
REQUIREMENTS WITH INTRACTABLE
IN PRACTICAL BOLD TIMELINES.
THIS IS THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LET'S SHOW EVERYONE
WHAT WE CAN DO AND GET OUR
SCHOOLS BACK. IN PERSON AGAIN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
EVANS MORE GREAT TESTIMONY
THANK YOU VERY UCH MEMBERS
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR NEXT PANEL
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BEFORE WE MOVE ON.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU I WANT
TO THANK THE PANEL FOR THE
PRESENTATION. I ALSO WANT TO
PROTECT RECOGNIZE THAT CHRIS
EVANS WHO'S THE SUPERINTENDENT
SCHOOL DISTRICT MY CHILDREN
ATTEND AND THEY ARE DISTANCE
LEARNING. SO CERTAINLY MY
CHILDREN ARE NOT IN DOING ANY
IN PERSON. I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT THAT SINCE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT VACCINATIONS- THAT-
MEMBER MY FAMILY IS A HEALTH
CARE WORKER. I GUESS YOU CAN
PUT YES WHO IT IS BECAUSE- AND-
SHE HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NOTICE
WHEN SHE'LL GET HER VACCINE AND
MY MOTHER. IS ALSO. THIS IS IN
THE HIGH RISK CATEGORY AND HAS
NOT RECEIVED ANY NOTIFICATION
WHEN SHE'LL GET HER VACCINE AS
WELL SO. JUST DOES THE COMING
ABOUT MAXINE DISTRIBUTION- SO
AGAIN I WANNA THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR- TESTIMONY- I DID HAVE
A- AND I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING ABOUT THE VACCINES AND-
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK TO GET.
PEOPLE VACCINATED BUT THERE'S
ALSO SUPPLY ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT TO PREVENT
EVANS MENTIONED IT WAS THE-
THIS WEEK- SECOND THE ENTIRE
COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO. AT LEAST
SECOND COUNTY BBC DAVIS OR SOME
OTHER SCOTT AND I KNOW THEY'RE
PUSHING THEIR VACCINES OUT
CLEARLY GOT UNDER THOUSAND
DOSES VENTURA COUNTY. SO IT'S
GONNA TAKE AWHILE- BUT LET'S
TALK ABOUT TESTING AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- BOTH- SUPERAR
BOROUGH SAN DIEGO ANSWER PRINT
EVANS IN A THOMAS TALKED ABOUT
THE WERE ABLE TO SET UP TESTING
REGIMENS INTER SCHOOL DISTRICT
BUT SOUNDS LIKE ONE WITH THE
HELP OF. THE UC SAN DIEGO. THE
OTHER ONE OF THE HELP OF THE
LOCAL COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
AND THEN- SUPERINTENDENT-
MONTEZ I PRESUME DO YOU SINCE
YOU DIDN'T MENTION THAT- THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE A TESTING
REGIMEN. OVER AND CAMPBELL THE
MOMENT I GUESS THE QUESTION I
HAVE TO ALL THREE OF YOU IS
EARLIER ON I DID ASK- MR ALLEN
FROM STATE FOR THAT. ASIAN
ABOUT. YEAH THE TECHNICAL SO
AND- AND THE SCHOOL SAFETY TEAM
AT THE AT THE- AND THEIR CUP TO
THE OF US- BOTH TECHNIQUE AND
INFORMATION TO HELP SCHOOL SET
UP TESTING CAPACITY AND US AS
ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS AS WELL
AS OTHER THINGS AND PERHAPS-
CAN YOU COMMENT ON IT IS TO
HAVE HAVE YOU GOTTEN ENOUGH
INFORMATION OR ASSISTANT AND I
JUST INFORMATION BECAUSE IT'S
NOT JUST INFORMATION IT'S
ACTUALLY THE CAPACITY DO YOU
FEEL THAT THERE'S ENOUGH
CAPACITY. IN THIS THAT THAT THE
STATE IS PROVIDING IN TERMS OF
ASSISTANCE TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND NOT ONLY YOUR OWN BUT ALSO
PERHAPS OTHER ONES THAT YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH IN YOUR AREA- TO
BE ABLE TO WELL FOR EXAMPLE ONE
REQUIREMENTS IS THIS TESTING
CAPACITY IS THAT THE OF THE DO
YOU HAVE THAT INFORMATION AND
THEN I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION
IS THAT IN YOUR RELATIONSHIPS
AND WE ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM.
ME THE BARGAINING YOU KNOW
REPRESENT BARGAINING UNITS- AND
THE NEXT PANEL I FEEL LIKE
THERE'S BEEN ENOUGH WORK DONE
TO EDUCATE BOTH THE- EMPLOYEES
AS WELL AS THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDELINES AND
THE EVIDENCE NECESSARY TO BE
ABLE TO REOPEN SAFELY ARE
PEOPLE LITTLE BIT LOST AT SEA
ABOUT IT AND SPECULATING ABOUT
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO SO- IF YOU
DON'T MIND IF I CAN ASK EACH OF
YOU TO BRIEFLY TRY TO THOSE.
QUESTIONS I JUST SENATOR PAM I
JUST WANTED TO RISK TO THE FACT
THAT- WE DO HAVE A LOOK AT
TESTING CADENCE FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES. AND WE TEST ALL
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES OUR SCHEDULE
IS ONCE A MONTH- MY CONCERN WAS
WITH ANY TYPE OF STUDENT
TESTING. AND SO AND WE WERE
ABLE TO WORK WITH OUR COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO GET A- I
CONTRACT. WITH SECURE CURETIS
AND- SO THAT'S WHO WERE USING
AT THIS POINT AND THEN WE'RE
ALSO LOOKING AT COLOUR. AND
FORWARD THIS STUDENT TESTING IF
THAT DOES BECOME A REQUIREMENT
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF DOING THAT.
WATER TESTING AND WORKING FROM
THERE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION I SPENT.
APPRECIATE IT- IN TERMS OF- ITS
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE
SCHOOL SAFETY TEAM. FEEL LIKE
YOU HAVE ENOUGH SUPPORT. I'M
OUT IN HONEST I THINK WE SHOULD
THAT. IT'S A VERY NEW I'M
COMMITTEE AS I UNDERSTAND IT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I WOULD
HAVE. WOULD STILL REALLY
APPRECIATE IS SOME SORT OF
TEMPLATE THAT ESSENTIALLY SHOWS
THIS IS WHAT WAS IN THAT-
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUIREMENTS THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WERE WORKING FROM
PREVIOUSLY AND THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
ADJUSTED WHERE YOU COULD JUST
QUICKLY CROSSWALK THAT. BECAUSE
N. AS YOU'RE KEENLY AWARE WE
ALSO HAVE OUR COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUIREMENTS SO WE HAVE
TO LOOK EACH TIME AT WHICH IS
MORE STRINGENT AND FOLLOW THOSE
MOST STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS AS
WE'RE DEVELOPING THE PLAN AND
SO EACH TIME THERE'S AN UPDATE
THEN WE UPDATE THE PLAN PUT
THAT OUT TO OUR COMMUNITY. TO
CALL THEIR ATTENTION TO
UPDATES- SO THE COMMUNICATION
PROCESS DOES GET CONFUSING AND
AS I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL AWARE
SOCIAL MEDIA DOESN'T HELP US ON
THESE THINGS BECAUSE THERE
SEEMS TO BE SOME SORT OF
RESEARCH STUDY THAT SAYS. ALL
KINDS OF DIFFERENT THINGS- SO
WE'RE CONSTANTLY TRYING TO GET
WHAT WE UNDERSTAND TO BE THE
FACTS IN FRONT OF OUR FOLKS. I
APPRECIATE I KNOW YOU'RE ALSO
TO HAVE A THEIR- BE THE CAL IN
THE STATE. AND THE BIGGEST WE
CAN DISCUSS OUR- PERHAPS SUPER
DAMPER DO YOU WANT US TO THE
AND ALSO WHAT DO YOU SOMETIMES
FOR CONFLICTS BETWEEN WHAT YOU
SEE SAN DIEGO WHO YOU'RE
WORKING WITH. AND THE STATE ARE
I MEAN THAT SO JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND- THE TERMS OF HOW
EFFECTIVE IS A SCHOOL SAFETY
TEAM GUIDANCE IN TERMS OF.
PROVIDING SUPPORT AND
INFORMATICS FOR YOU TO FOR YOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND INFORMATION
T EMPLOYEES AND PARENTS. FOR
YOU GOT THIS. THANK YOU SENATOR
PANFILO YOU KNOW BACK IN AUGUST
WHEN I CDPH PUT OUT ITS- ITS
GUIDELINES AT THAT POINT I.
WHAT A TIME. WHAT ADVISED WAS
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS WOULD DO
YOU HAS SEEN EMPLOYEES. ONCE.
EVERY TWO MONTHS. AND- AND
BECAUSE OF THAT ARE ON BOB
VEGGIE AND OUR ARE COUNTY GOT.
SET UP I ITS FIRST TO ALASKA
DISTRICTS TO DO THAT. BUT BASED
ON FEEDBACK YOU KNOW WE HAVE
BEEN GETTING FROM. OUR OUR OUR
EASIEST SCIENTISTS WHAT THEY
WERE SAYING IS THAT IS NOT AN
ATTIC FREE. OF TESTING.
ACTUALLY I. YOU KNOW GET THE US.
THAT WE CAN I WHO ACTUALLY IS
CARRYING A FIVE ON OUR CAMPUS.
AND SO WE SPENT REALLY A COUPLE
OF MONTHS WORKING TOGETHER WITH
OUR OUR TEACHERS UNION. TO AND-
I DE WHAT WE BE THE RIGHT.
FREQUENCY AND I'M THAT I'VE
EASIER DEFINE CAME WITH
BASICALLY CHAU BAD. IF YOU WANT
TO USE TESTING AS AN ACTUAL
PREVENTIVE STRATEGY USED TO BE
TESTING EVERYBODY ON CAMPUS
STUDENTS AND STAFF ONCE EVERY
TWO WEEKS MINIMUM. AND BASED ON
THAT I A GUIDANCE WE WENT WENT
ABOUT AND DEVELOPED APR A
PROGRAM WITH YOU SAN DIEGO
HEALTH I AND WE HAVE A CONTRACT
WITH UC SAN DIEGO HEALTH
ACTUALLY COME ONTO OUR CAMPUS
AND PROVIDE THAT LEVEL OF
TESTING BUT I WILL SAY WE BEGAN
THAT TESTING PROGRAM IN
DECEMBER. AND WE ARE RIGHT NOW
BUILDING IT UP TO GET TO THE
POINT THAT WE COULD HAVE IT ON
EVERY SCHOOL WE'VE BEEN DOING
AT TEN NEW SCHOOLS A WEEK BUT
WE KNOW IT WILL TAKE US TIME TO
GET TO THE POINT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE THAT LEVEL OF TESTING
AVAILABLE AND THIS IS. YOU
KNOW- IF THIS IS YOU KNOW HI
FOR PARTNERS IT'S ACT NOW I YOU
KNOW FOR SEVERAL MONTHS AND THE
OTHER THING I WOULD JUST ADD IS
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WERE IN A
PRIVILEGE SITUATION AS A SCHOOL
DISTRICT BECAUSE WE'VE GUIDE
INTERNAL RESOURCES YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'VE GOT AT SCHOOL NURSES
WE'VE GOT IT ON. A STAFF
PEDIATRICIAN I AND WE'VE GOT A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH UC SAN
DIEGO HI WHERE THE CHANCELLOR'S
BEEN VERY COMMITTED TO THIS AND
OUR OUR CONTRACT WITH UCSD
ALLOWS US TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
AS TESTING TECHNOLOGY EVOLVES
AND WE THINK UCSD WILL BE ON
THE FOREFRONT OF DEVELOPING
THAT TECHNOLOGY THE DISTRICT
GETS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
I AS WE GO FORWARD THAT'S A
PRIVILEGED POSITION FOR A
DISTRICT TO TAKE I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY DISTRICTS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE YOU KNOW HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THAT KIND OF I
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THOSE KINDS
OF RELATIONSHIPS ANY PAIN IN
OUR SITUATION. WE WILL
CERTAINLY NOT BE IN A POSITION
THAT WE WOULD BE READY TO DO
THAT KIND OF FREQUENCY OF
TESTING WITHIN YOU. KNOW
ANOTHER MONTH IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TIME TO ROLL THIS OUT. AND
IN JUST THE UP- NOW THAT THE
CURRENT RECORD DIRECTLY
GOVERNOR'S. FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
SAID DAVE RECOGNIZING SOME OF
THE THAT YOU FROM YOU SEE TO
ASK THAT DO SURVEILLANCE
TESTING AT IS EVERY RIGHT THE
PROPOSED- SO YOUR EXPIRY AND
YOU HAVE THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
YOU SEE. TO SET UP SPEED UP
YOUR TESTING REGIMEN- AND SO
I'M HEARING FROM YOU YOU'RE
SAYING THAT WELL FIRST OF YOU
HAVE THIS ALL SEEM TO REALLY.
WITH A LONG TIME TO STAY IT UP-
YOU ARE YOU GETTING. AND THEN
PERHAPS SINCE YOU'RE HAVE THIS
I MEAN IT IS DO YOU THINK THE
SCHOOL SO TEAM ARE THE STATE IS
ABLE TO HELP OUT WHETHER IT'S
YOU OR OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AROUND YOU MAY NOT HAVE THAT
RELATIONSHIP TO STAND UP THE
TESTING REGIMEN. AS QUICKLY AS
BEING PROPOSED. WELL WORSE WERE
AND WE HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH TI BEFORE WE YOU KNOW
FINALIZE OUR DECISION TO WORK
WITH UCSD IT. YOU KNOW IN OUR
TESTING PROGRAM WE DID HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE STATE-
REGARDING MALE REPUBLICANS ARE
CONTRACTING THE BLIND SEALAB.
IN QUITE FRANKLY THERE ARE A
LOT OF AND I AM QUESTIONS THAT
WE A KNACK. WHEN WOULD YOU BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY TEST STUDENTS
ON WHAT IS YOUR INFRASTRUCTURE
YOU KNOW NOT JUST ON. PROTEST
BUT THE PRICE YOU HAD SET SAID
WHO'S GOING TO COME ON AND
DELIBERATE ARE YOU GONNA BE
ABLE TO COME ON AND WEBER AT ON
CAMPUS. THAT WAS A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO THAT WE HAD THAT
CONVERSATION BUT WE FELT THAT
THE ANSWERS WEREN'T IN PLACE AT
THAT POINT. AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT. YOU KNOW WE
WERE EAGER TO MOVE FORWARD IF
YOU SEE A STATE IN ADDITION TO
THE FACT THE UCSD IS A PUBLIC
RESEARCH UNIVERSITY WITH A
PUBLIC MISSION. I AND WE FEEL
LIKE WE CAN BENEFIT AS- AS YOU
CST YOU KNOW PROGRESSES IN
THEIR IN IN AND DEVELOPING
BETTER TESTING TECHNOLOGY. I'M
SO YOU KNOW. I DON'T DOUBT THAT
I THE TIME THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT THE STATE IS SETTING UP
RIGHT NOW TO YOU. I PROVIDE
INFORMATION DISTRICTS IS THAT I
DON'T DOUBT THAT THEY HAVE THAT
THAT'S THE RIGHT INFORMATION
AND THAT THEY'VE GOT VERY YOU
KNOW CREDIBLE I PEOPLE. I'M
WHAT I. WOULD BE SKEPTICAL OUT
IS WHETHER IT BACK
INFRASTRUCTURE WOULD ACTUALLY
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THAT
HAVEN'T EVEN BEGUN YET TO DO
DEVELOP A- PER. SIR S. TAX YOU.
THE FREAK THAT THE RIGHT. THAT
WOULD BE A TO DO IT I YOU KNOW.
AND I. THANK YOU AND I GUESS UP
SILVA AND- DID YOU HAVE ANY
BRIEF. COM GIVEN YOUR- SURE I
IN INTO OF THE ACCESS TO THE
STATE- MY AT MY STOP MOSTLY
INTERACTS THE STATE AND THEY
NOT HAD ASKED ME WHY. TO STEP
IN A TRY TO GET EXTRA SOME TO
GUIDE THEY'VE VERY BY. OUR
SACRAMENTO PA HEALTH BEEN SENT-
THE DEATH NEED MORE BODIES MORE
BE THEIR OWN. BUT EVERY TWO. I
CALL DOCTOR CONSIDERING IT
SHOULD PICK UP THE PHONE- SHE
WILL CALL ME BACK IMMEDIATELY
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW SHE'S
DOING THAT- KNOWING THAT I'M
JUST ONE OF PROBABLY HUNDREDS
OR CALLING HER EACH DAY. IN
TERMS OF PARENTS AND STOP BEING
ADEQUATELY EDUCATED ABSOLUTELY
NOT I MEAN I DON'T KNOW FOR
SURE IF THIS IS OUR FOURTH OR
FIFTH- GUIDANCE FOR SCHOOLS- IT
CHANGES SO MUCH. AND THEN AND
THEN PURPLE THEN BECAUSE I PER.
AND YOU KNOW START. WE WORK ALL
BUT THEN WE WERE ASKED TO CLOSE
DOWN AND THEN WE WERE ALLOWED
TO EAT OUTSIDE AGAIN AND- AND I
CAN'T EVEN EXPLAIN IT TO MY OWN
FAMILY. AND SO WHEN IT COMES TO
THAT KIND OF CONFUSION- IT'S
VERY FRUSTRATING I ALSO NEED TO
POINT OUT THAT AS WE TALK ABOUT
TESTING IS A MAJOR PART. I SAID
OUR DISTRICT EXECUTED- I AGREE
WITH RICHARD YOU SAID IF THE
COMMUNITY HAS STARTED ALREADY
THEY'RE- CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO IT. IN IN LITTLE
ON THE SHORT TIME FRAME IT TOOK
US MONTHS TO POLITICALLY
CONVINCED PEOPLE WE CAN DO IT.
AND THEN WE STARTED IT AND THEN
WE HAD A SHORTAGE OF TESTING
AND THEN WE NOW WE'VE WE'VE HAD
A CADENCE. BUT IT IS NOT AN
EASY THING TO DO AND YOU HAVE
TO HAVE TALENTED PEOPLE. WITHIN
YOUR DISTRICT WHICH IS TALKED
ABOUT HOW GIFTED. HE IS OUR
DISTRICT I FEEL THE VERY SAME
WAY WE HAVE EXTREMELY TALENTED
PEOPLE. PEOPLE ARE BUYING
TESTING IS THE ANSWER AND ALL
POLITICS ASIDE. I THINK THE
WHITE HOUSE TESTING PLAN AND
HOW SOUTH THAT WENT SO QUICK-
AND HOW MUCH THAT WS COVERED-
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND IN
SOCIAL MEDIA. PEOPLE ARE BUYING
TESTING IS THE ANSWER- THEY ARE
THEY ARE ASKING ABOUT THE
VACCINES THE READING THE
NEWSPAPER THAT SAYS THERE'S-
YOU KNOW 90% OF THEM STILL
SITTING. IN THE FREEZER
SOMEWHERE. THEY WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT VACCINATIONS MORE THAN
THEY WANT TO KNOW ABOUT TESTING
AND WHETHER OR NOT HAT'S THE
REALITY OR NOT. WHEN WE TRY TO
ARTICULATE THIS PLAN TO THEM
THEY DON'T HEAR THE TESTING.
THEY THEY WANT TO KNOW WHEN THE
VACCINATE VACCINATIONS AND
QUITE FRANKLY SUPERINTENDENT
EVANS WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO GET
THOSE FOR US. OKAY AND SO THAT
I THINK THAT'S THE REALITY OF
WHERE OUR COMMUNITY. AND
PROBABLY MOST OF OUR STATE IS.
RIGHT NOW. THANK THANK YOU- I
IT REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THOSE
ANSWERS- YOU KNOW. I THINK THAT
UNFORTUNATELY. I HOPE THAT WITH
THE NEW LEADERSHIP AT. THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WERE WE'RE GOING
TO BE L. THE RAMP UP ON THE
BACK. BUT AT THE SAME TIME I'M
NOT SURE. WE CAN. MESS WAIT FOR
THE JACKSON- I WILL TELL YOU
THAT- CERTAINLY PURSE. I WOULD
LIKE TO STEAL TO SEE KIDS BACK
TO SCHOOL. EARLIER POSSIBLE- AS
A PEDIATRICIAN IS SOMEONE WHO-
FOLKS ON CHILD DEVELOPMENT. BUT
I WAS ALSO A- PHYSICIAN
CONSULTANT TO SCHOOL DISTRICT
BEFORE I CAME INTO LEGISLATURE
AS WELL. AND UNDERSTAND- MANY
OF THE CHALLENGES ABOUT- TRYING
TO BE SURE WE KEEP. THOSE KIDS
AND STAFF SAFE AND- AND SOME OF
THOSE THOSE CHALLENGES AS WELL.
AND I THINK THAT- SO. BUT WOULD
SAY IS THAT I'M VERY
SYMPATHETIC TO WHAT I THINK THE
GOVERNMENT'S TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
BUT I AM ALSO VERY CONCERNED
THAT WE'RE NOT BUILDING. ENOUGH
EVEN CAPACITY IN- YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE ABOUT OKAY YOU WHAT
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
HELP OUT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THOSE. SET UP. TESTING OR
YOU'RE GONNA GIVE SUPPORT TO
THE COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO
DO THAT I MEAN I JUST KNOW
WHAT'S GOING HERE LOCALLY
RIGHT. SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THEMSELVES THAN IN A I'M GLAD
TO HEAR FROM ALL OF YOU. THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY DONE IT BUT LOOKS
LIKE YOU KNOW YOU NEED MORE
SUPPORT TO BE ABLE TO T. THAT
UP. AND THAT'S ALSO INCLUDES
RESOURCES RIGHT AND- WE HAVE
MORE SPECIFIC PLANS FOR EXAMPLE
IF WE'RE GONNA TRY TO MAKE
TESTING CHEAPER. FULL TESTING
AND SO FORTH. DO WE HAVE
SPECIFIC PLANS WE LAID OUT FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AND THAT'S ONLY ONE
PIECE OF THIS WHOLE THING. AS
WELL. AND AND CERTAINLY- YOU
KNOW WE CERTAINLY WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE VACCINES BUT- AS WELL AS
WHEN WE GET THOSE SUPPLIES BUT
I THINK THAT- I WOULD. REALLY
LIKE TO HEAR BY TIME WE FINISH
UP MAYBE GOING BACK TO- THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN TERMS OF
HOW THE WHAT REALLY IS THE
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THIS I THINK IS
REALLY A CRITICAL QUESTION IS
NOW WE DON'T I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S GOALS. BYE
BYE AND- GONNA HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT CAPACITY. AND
SO I THINK WITH THAT ASSEMBLY
WHAT- APPRECIATE. AND- AND
THANKS SO MUCH MANAGE. THANK
YOU CENTER PAN TO ANY OF OUR
OTHER MEMBERS TO CALL. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA ON TO OUR NAY AND
LAST PAN WE'RE GOING TO WITH
THE CHIP. WHO IS A TO OF
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WELCOME
MR SHAPIRO. THANK YOU CHAIR
LEYVA GREAT TO SEE YOU ALL OF A
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I DON'T ENVY THE
POSITION THAT ALL OF YOU ARE IN
AS ELECTED LEADERS IN OUR STATE
IN MY DOZEN YEARS OF LIKE
LEADERSHIP. I NEVER FACE THE
SORTS OF CHALLENGES THAT YOU
GUYS ARE UP AGAINST RIGHT NOW
AND SO I'M NOT ENVIOUS OF THE
POSITION THAT YOU'RE IN BUT-
ANXIOUS AND EXCITED TO BE HERE
TO OFFER OUR PERSPECTIVE. AND
SO I JUST FOR THOSE WHO MAY NOT
KNOW WHAT TO JUST SHARE WITH
YOU ABOUT WHO WE REPRESENT. THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS-
INSTRUCTIONAL SYSTEMS PARA
EDUCATORS- BUS DRIVERS FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS CUSTODIANS
MAINTENANCE WORKERS. OFFICE
STAFF ATTENDANCE CLERKS MANY
OTHERS- WITHIN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM BASICALLY THE FOLKS WHO
ARE NOT CERTIFICATED. IN OUR
MEMBERS AS MANY MAY KNOW AND
SOME MAY NOT KNOW. BUT MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE BEEN WORKING
SINCE THE START OF THE CRISIS.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS- NEVER WENT
HOME IN MARCH WHEN COVERED HIT
OUR SHORES. AND HAVE BEEN
WORKING THROUGHOUT THE CRISIS-
IN SOME CASES OR FOOD SERVICE-
FOLKS HAVE BEEN PREPARING MEALS
FOR KIDS ON FREE AND REDUCED
LUNCH. OUR TRANSPORTATION FOLKS
HAVE BEEN DELIVERING MEALS ARE
I. T. FOLKS HAVE BEEN PROPPING
UP DISTANCE LEARNING. OUR FOLKS
HAVE BEEN VERY ACTIVE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THIS CRISIS IN
MANY CASES. I WANT TO. BE CLEAR
THAT OUR MEMBERS AND YOU KNOW
OUR OUR SISTER UNIONS I'M SURE
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THIS AS WELL.
BUT OUR MEMBERS FEEL STRONGLY-
THE SAME WAY THAT SOME OF YOU
ON THE COMMITTEE HAVE
EXPRESSED. THAT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IS FAR SUPERIOR TO
DISTANCE LEARNING AND WE WOULD
LOVE TO SEE OUR STUDENTS. BACK
IN SCHOOLS WE THINK THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO GET
THEM BACK IN PERSON-
DEVELOPMENTALLY- SOCIAL
EMOTIONALLY THAT IT IS- THAT
THAT IS THE SUPERIOR METHOD OF-
OF PROVIDING THIS SORT OF
INSTRUCTION WE NEED TO PROVIDE.
WE ALSO AGREE THAT HEALTH AND
SAFETY HAS TO BE OUR TOP
PRIORITY THAT HAS TO REMAIN OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY. LEDS NEED
THE RESOURCES TO ACHIEVE THESE
DUAL GOALS. OF PROVIDING THAT
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION AND
pOF STUDENTS AND STAFF ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. HUMAN RESOURCES ARE
CRITICAL TO ACHIEVING BOTH OF
THOSE GOALS. AND UNFORTUNATELY
DUE TO INEQUITIES THAT EXIST IN
OUR WAY OUT PROTECTION LAWS IN
THIS STATE. THOUSANDS OF
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES. ARE NO
LONGER IN THEIR POSITIONS ARE
HAVE BEEN LAID OFF OR OUT OF
WORK FOLKS MANY FOLKS WHOSE JOB
IT IS TO KEEP STUDENTS SAFE.
THE FOLKS WHOSE JOB IT IS TO
PROVIDE THE ONE THE ONE
INSTRUCTIONAL SUPPORTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY. MANY OF THOSE FOLKS
IN MANY PARTS OF OUR STATE HAVE
BEEN LAID OFF. AND SO WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE HUMAN
CAPITAL NECESSARY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS AND WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT. IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. MISS HOLMES
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
STARTING FROM SCRATCH. AND
THAT'S TRUE IN SOME PLACES-
DISTRICTS ARE AHEAD OF THE GAME.
BUT IN SOME PLACES DISTRICTS
ARE FAR BEHIND. IN CERTAIN
PLACES WHERE THEY HAVE LAID OFF
EVERY PARA EDUCATOR IN AN
ENTIRE COUNTY. THE NEEDS THAT
OUR STUDENTS ARE GOING TO HAVE
WHEN THEY RETURN. TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION TO GET THE ONE TO
ONE SUPPORT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
LACKING THE ENTIRE TIME THEY'VE
BEEN GONE IN DISTANCE LEARNING
IN PLACES LIKE THAT. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT IN PLACE
THE NEEDS THE HUMAN CAPITAL
NEEDS ARE NOT BEING MET. AND I
WILL SAY- YOU KNOW I REPRESENT
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES I
STARTED MY CAREER AS A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER I HAVE A MASTERS
IN EDUCATION AND IN STUDY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT. AND I
YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO. MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE'S AWARE AND
I KNOW THAT THE EDUCATION
EXPERTS ON THIS CALL ARE WELL
AWARE. THAT WHEN STUDENTS HAVE
LEARNING DEFICITS. WHEN
STUDENTS ARE BEHIND. WHEN WE
HAVE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS- WHICH
WE'D LIKE TO REFER TO MORE
ACCURATELY IS OPPORTUNITY GAPS
IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM. THERE IS
REALLY ONE SOLUTION ONE
SOLUTION THAT WORKS TO ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM. AND THAT IS
INDIVIDUALIZED SUPPORT. AND IT
IS OUR MEMBERS IT IS PARA
EDUCATORS PRIMARILY- WHEN THE
CERTIFICATED INSTRUCTOR DOES
NOT HAVE THE TIME OR RESOURCES
TO PROVIDE THAT INDIVIDUAL I
SUPPORT BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT A
CLASS FULL OF STUDENTS IT IS
PARA EDUCATOR TO PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT IT'S JUST. CRITICAL
THAT THAT BE A COMPONENT OF
THIS PLANET WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S TRAILER BILL-
FOR THE FOUR POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. MENTIONS THAT ONE OF
THE APPROPRIATE USES ONE OF I
BELIEVE NINE USES OF THOSE
FUNDS. IS TO INCREASE THE HUMAN
CAPITAL TO PROVIDE THAT ONE TO
ONE INSTRUCTIONAL SUPPORT THAT
OUR STUDENTS WILL BE IN
DESPERATE NEED OF. AND THAT'S
THAT'S APPRECIATED THAT'S
MENTIONED BUT IT'S JUST ONE OF
NINE OPTIONS THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT DISTRICTS WHO
HAVE BEEN OUT BEEN WITHOUT
THESE PERIGEE CATERS IN SOME
CASES FOR MONTHS THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY BRING
THEM BACK NOW. TO PROVIDES
SUPPORT TO STUDENTS IN DISTANCE
LEARNING AND THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY BRING
THEM BACK. WHEN WE BRING
STUDENTS BACK FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION THAT HAS GOT TO BE
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A PROBLEM NOW
THAT IN. MORE THAN A CENTURY OF
EDUCATION IN THIS STATE AND
CENTURIES OF EDUCATION IN THIS
COUNTRY. WE WILL PROBABLY NEVER
HAD BEFORE AND THAT IS THE
RANGE THE EDUCATORS ARE GOING
TO FACE IN TERMS OF THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE FROM THE
STUDENTS WHO ARE WHO ARE WHO
ARE AHEAD TO THOSE WHO ARE THE
FURTHEST BEHIND. IS GREATER
THAN IT'S EVER BEEN. BECAUSE OF
THE SITUATION WE'VE FACED OVER
THE LAST TEN MONTHS. AND IT'S
<c.cyan>ONNA TAKE ABOUT IN PERSON</c>
INSTRUCTIONAL SUPPORT. AND ONE
TO ONE SUPPORT. TO GET US BACK
TO GET OUR STUDENTS TO WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE. NOW OBVIOUSLY
HEALTH AND SAFETY AGAIN IS OUR
TOP PRIORITY IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN GET TO THAT POINT.
AND MANY OF US IN THIS MEETING
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SCHOOL RE
OPENING SINCE JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY- ODD. SOME EVEN BACK TO
APRIL IN MAY WHEN WE KNEW THIS
WAS GOING TO BE EXTENDED. MANY
OF US WERE INVOLVED IN A TASK
FORCE THAT MET TO DEVELOP A
FRAMEWORK IN A CHECKLIST. TO
MAKE SURE THAT SCHOOLS WERE
READY TO RE OPEN FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. BACK IN AUGUST AND
SEPTEMBER THAT WAS THE GOAL.
WAS TO START THE SCHOOL YEAR
WITH FOLKS IN PERSON. AND WE
CREATED SOME CRITERIA WE
CREATED A CHECKLIST THAT WE
FELT. GIVEN THE CONDITIONS ON
THE GROUND IN SCHOOLS ACROSS
THE STATE COULD BE IMPLEMENTED
TO MAKE SCHOOLS. PLACES THAT
WERE SAFE FOR STUDENTS AND
STAFF. AND UNFORTUNATELY THIS
STATE OF AFFAIRS IN TERMS OF
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS WAS
MUCH WORSE THAN WE EXPECTED IT
WOULD BE. IN AUGUST AND
SEPTEMBER AND MOST SCHOOLS DID
NOT REOPEN AT LEAST UNIVERSALLY
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. THIS
SITUATION TODAY IS SO MUCH
WORSE. IN NEARLY EVERY COUNTY
IN THE STATE WHEN IT WAS IN
AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER. THAT IT
JUST IT SEEMS SORT OF OUT OF
TOUCH WITH THE REALITY ON THE
GROUND. TO BE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT RUSHING TO
RE OPEN AND GETTING FOLKS TO
SUBMIT PLANS BY TEN DAYS FROM
NOW- WHEN THE REALITY ON THE
GROUND IS SO MUCH WORSE THAN IT
WAS LAST AUGUST AND SEPTEMBER.
SO WE HAVE TO BE COGNIZANT YOU
KNOW DIED MISS HOLMES MENTIONED
EARLIER THERE ONLY SIX COUNTIES
IN THE STATE THAT ARE EVEN
ELIGIBLE. AT THIS POINT TO
REOPEN. AT THE TWENTY FIVE CASE
RATE TWENTY FIVE NEW CASES PER
HUNDRED THOUSAND. AND SO IT
IT'S NOT THAT WE DON'T THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT INAPPROPRIATE
FOR US TO BE HAVING THE
CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW. ABOUT
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND HAVING A
CALMER CONVERSATION RIGHT NOW
ABOUT TARGETED INTERVENTIONS
FOR STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
LEARNING LOSS AND HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT GETTING KIDS
BACK. FOR INFRASTRUCTURE ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE APPROPRIATE
CONVERSATIONS TO BE HAVING
RIGHT NOW BUT WE HAVE TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE THE EXPECTATION THAT
WE'RE SETTING UP IN THE STATE.
AND WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN
CAME OUT. I WILL SAVE MANY
PARENTS FRIENDS OF MINE
NEIGHBORS. MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
ACROSS THE STATE I GOT AN EMAIL
JUST THIS MORNING. FROM ONE OF
OUR MEMBER LEADERS OFFER AND
FROM ONE OF OUR STAFF MEMBERS
SAYING HEY WE WERE HURRYING
WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUR PLAN
DONE BY FEBRUARY FIRST IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS NEW
PROGRAM. OF THE PERCEPTION OUT
THERE IS THAT THIS PROGRAM HAS
ALREADY BEEN PASSED. THAT THE
WORK OF THE LEGISLATURE IS
ALREADY BEEN DONE IT'S ALREADY
BEEN NEGOTIATED AND SIGNED INTO
LAW BY THE GOVERNOR AND THAT
THERE'S NEW MONEY THAT'S GOING
TO BE AVAILABLE TO SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE. WE'RE GOING
TO REOPEN AS SOON AS TEN DAYS
FROM NOW. SO WE HAVE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS EXPECTATION
SETTING IS ALSO IMPORTANT. AND
THAT. WE NEED OUR STAFF OR
MEMBERS OUR STUDENTS ARE
PARENTS OR EDUCATORS ACROSS THE
STATE TO UNDERSTAND THE
REALITY. THAT WE ARE NEAR THE
PEAK OF THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
IN CALIFORNIA. AND THAT. WE ARE
ENGAGED IN MAKING PLANS TO
ENSURE. THAT OUR SCHOOLS TO
REOPEN SAFELY AND OUR STUDENTS
CAN BETTER GET BACK FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION BUT THAT'S
JUST NOT WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
IS A STATE IT'S NOT WHERE WE
ARE WITH THIS FOR THIS VIRUS WE
ARE IN A MUCH WORSE POINT THAN
WE WERE. IN AUGUST AND
SEPTEMBER. WE SHARE THE CONCERN
OF SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES- IN
MANAGEMEN WHO HAVE RAISED.
THIS ISSUE OF. THE USE OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT FOX. WE SHOULD BE
CLEAR PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS
ARE MEANT TO BE SPENT FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL PURPOSES. AND THE
WAY THAT THIS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED. WHAT IS
ACTUALLY TAKE DOLLARS THAT
SCHOOLS SHOULD ALL BE RECEIVING
ANYWAY. WHAT HOLD THOSE DOLLARS
BACK. AND SAY THAT THOSE WHO
ARE ABLE TO RUSSIAN CREATE THIS
PLAN AND EXECUTE IT AND
NEGOTIATED BARGAIN WITH THEIR
EXCLUSIVE WRAPS AND SUBMIT IT
WITHIN THE NEXT TEN DAYS EVEN
THOUGH THIS BILL IS NOT EVEN. A
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE BEEN
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR. THAT
BOB THIS IS FOLKS WILL THAT
MONEY JUST ONLY MAYBE GET A
LITTLE MORE THAN THEY WOULD'VE
GOTTEN OTHERWISE. AND THE FOLKS
WHO ARE BEING MORE REALISTIC
AND DELIBERATIVE AND ENSURING
THAT THIS PLAN MAKES SENSE AND
I'M NOT GOING TO RUSH TO
SUBMITTED BY FEBRUARY FIRST.
WILL GET LESS MONEY THAN THEY
WILL GET IF THIS PROGRAM IS AN
PASSED. SENATOR GLAZER- I THINK
POINTED OUT WELL. THAT THERE
ARE SOME SCHOOLS THAT AREN'T
EVEN ELIGIBLE. THOSE SCHOOLS IF
THIS PROGRAM BECOMES LAW WELL
ACTUALLY GET LESS MONEY. THEN
THEY WOULD GET IF THIS PROGRAM
DOESN'T BECOME LAW BECAUSE IT'S
NOT A PROBLEM NINETY EIGHT
DOLLARS AND WE'RE JUST
REARRANGING DECK CHAIRS. AND
SO- DROP NINETY EIGHT IS NOT
THE APPROPRIATE REVENUE SOURCE
FOR THIS OR NOT THE APPROPRIATE
FUNDING SOURCE. FOR THIS
PROGRAM IF WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT THIS LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
USE OF. A DOLLARS BEYOND PROP
NINETY OR FEDERAL DOLLARS. AND
YOU KNOW LIKE MISTER BREYER
SAID- THE FACT IS THAT GIVEN
THE COST OF TESTING THESE FUNDS
WILL BE SPENT MOSTLY ON BACK.
LINE ITEM OF TESTING. SO JUST
ADDING TO THE POINT OF THE FACT
THAT THIS MONEY THAT IS MEANT
FOR INSTRUCTIONAL PURPOSES
SHOULD REMAIN AND CONTINUE TO
BE SPENT FOR THAT PURPOSE LET'S
ALLOCATE DOLLARS LET'S NOT TAKE
AWAY FROM THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS IN TERMS OF
INSTRUCTION TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS AND OUR STAFF
IN TERMS OF HEALTH AND SAFETY
LET'S MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS AND STAFF IN TERMS OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY BUT NOT
USING. INSTRUCTIONAL DOLLARS. I
THINK A LOT OF FOLKS HAVE
MENTIONED THAT THE TIMING IS
UNREALISTIC- AS I SAID ABOUT
EXPECT YOU KNOW CENTER CORTESE
THINK HIGHLIGHTED WELL HOW THE
EXPECTATION SETTING IS SORT OF
OUT OF WHACK WITH THE REALITY
ON THE GROUND. THIS CHECKLIST
JUST CAME OUT LAST THURSDAY.
WHICH MEANS ALLEY AS ONLY KNOWN
WHAT THEY NEEDED TO INCLUDE IN
THEIR COVERT SAFETY.
INFORMATION THEY GOT A WEEK AGO
TO DEVELOP A COVERAGE SAFETY
PLAN TO BARGAIN THE EFECTS OF
THAT PLAN WITH THEIR- EMPLOYEES.
TO HAVE THAT RATIFIED BY THOSE
EMPLOYEE UNITS TO SUBMIT THAT
PLAN TO THE STATE. ALL OF THAT
WITHIN THE NEXT TEN DAYS. IT'S
UNREALISTIC AND THERE'S JUST NO
POINT IN RUSHING TO CREATE
THESE PLANS ALL THE SUDDEN WHEN
THIS BILL IS NOT EVEN YET ALL.
TO ANSWER- THE CHAIRWOMAN'S
QUESTION EARLIER. TO HAVE IT
ANSWERED BY JESSICA HOMES INTO
TO HEAR THAT RESPONSE ABOUT
RELIEF US NOT EVEN KNOWING AT
THIS STAGE. OUR WHICH DISTRICTS
ARE OPEN FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WHICH DISTRICTS
HAVE COVERT SAFETY PLANTS WHICH
OF THOSE DISTRICTS HAVE THOSE
PLANS RATIFIED I THINK THE
THOSE ANSWERS TO THE CHURCH
QUSTIONS DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS
PLAN IS NOT READY FOR PRIME
TIME. NOW TO BE CLEAR I
APPRECIATE OUR MEMBERS
APPRECIATE. INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY THAT COMES FROM
THE SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL
PLANNED THE BROADER PLAN NOT
JUST THIS IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
GRANT PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE THE
DEFINITIONAL CLARITY THAT CDPH
HAS. PUT IN THIS CONSOLIDATED
GUIDANCE WHICH AGAIN IS
SEPARATE AND DISTINCT FROM THIS
GRANT PROGRAM WE APPRECIATE THE-
THIS REVELATION OR REALIZE
ATION BUT YOUNG KIDS ARE
ACTUALLY BETTER WEARING MASKS
THAT WE THOUGHT THEY WERE. IN
FACT IN MANY CASES ARE BETTER
AT DOING IT THAN ADULTS ARE
BECAUSE- THEY'RE THE WAY THEIR
BRAINS WORK THIS LEARNED
BEHAVIOR HABIT FORMING IS MUCH
EASIER FOR THAN IT IS FOR
ADULTS. WE APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION OF THE NEEDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PP IS
AVAILABLE TO THE STAFF THE
TESTING IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
INCLUDING SURVEILLANCE TESTING.
BUT WE'RE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
WORD VACCINE DOES NOT EVEN
APPEAR. IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. SO IT'S ONE THING TO
SAY THAT WE'RE NOT RECOGNIZING
THE IMPORTANCE OF VACCINES OR
HIGHLIGHTING IT SIGNIFICANTLY
THE WORD VACCINE OR VACCINATION
DOES NOT EVEN APPEAR IN THE
TRAILER BILL. AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT- AND I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FOR THOSE WHO DIDN'T
NOTICE. THE MANAGEMENT FOLKS IN
LABOR FOLKS IN THIS MEETING
SOUND SEEMS TO BE ARE LARGELY
IN AGREEMENT. THAT VACCINES
HAVE TO BE PART OF THIS
DISCUSSION. AND SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE OUR COLLEAGUES AND
MANAGEMENT WHO HAVE RECOGNIZED
THE IMPORTANCE OF BRINGING THAT
IN THE CONVERSATION WE ALSO
HAVE TO RECOGNIZE OURS WE I
THINK WE ALL KNOW THIS OUR
STATE IS BEHIND IN VACCINATIONS
WE ARE BEHIND IN DISTRIBUTIONS
OF THE VACCINE I HAVE MANY
COLLEAGUES WHO I. SERVED WITH-
FOUR WHEN I WAS AN EDUCATOR AND
ARIZONA THE VAST MAJORITY OF MY
EDUCATION FRIENDS TEACHERS
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
ADMINISTRATORS. ARE HAVE
ALREADY SCHEDULED THE
APPOINTMENT FOR THEIR SECOND
DOSE OF THE VACCINE. SO WE HAVE
TO GET VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
ROLLING THAT'S GOT TO BE A BIG
TOPIC OF CONVERSATION. WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THAT CONVERSATION.
BE PART OF THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT RE OPENING FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. ZERO ONE LIKE IF I
CAN ASK YOU TO WRAP UP YOUR
ABOUT TEN MINUTES OF YOUR FIVE
MINUTES. SORRY SO- YES ALL I
AND I YOU KNOW THAT THE BINS IN
CONCLUSION LET'S LET'S KEEP THE
COMMONSENSE PLAN THAT BRINGS
KIDS BACK FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AS SOON AS IT SAFE.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
HUMAN CAPITA TO MEET THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
INSTRUCTIONAL NEEDS LET'S DO IT
RIGHT NOT RUSSIA NOT BECAUSE OF
POLITICAL PRESSURE BUT BECAUSE
OUR STUDENTS NEED US TO GET IT
RIGHT FOR THEIR HEALTH. AND
SAFETY AND FOR THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OURS OF OUR MEMBERS
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. THE GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE NOW
GOING TO HEAR FROM LAURIE
EASTERLING WHO IS THE MANAGER
OF LEGISLATIVE RELATIONS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. AND WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO MOVE ALONG BECAUSE WE
DID ACTOR ASKED DR VERDICT-
FREE FROM CDPH TO BE ON AN
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND WE ONLY
HAVE HER UNTIL TWO- MISS
EASTERLING PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S LORI
STERLING MANAGER LEGISLATIVE
RELATIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I'M HERE
REPRESENTING OUR- THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PLUS EDUCATORS AND
SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS. I DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE I'M THANKING
OUR MANAGEMENT PARTNERS FOR
THEIR RECOGNITION THAT IT IS A
LABOR MANAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP
AND I TRULY. APPRECIATE THAT ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS. IT
NORMAL CO. NON IN. NON CO THE
TIMES- ARE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
PLUS PUBLIC SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
REACH NEARLY TWENTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS FIVE DAYS A WEEK.
AND THERE'S NO OTHER PUBLIC
SECTOR THAT THAT HAS THAT KIND
OF REACH AND WHAT I MEAN BY
THAT IS THERE'S OVER SIX
MILLION KIDS IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS EACH ONE OF THEM HAS TO
IMPORTANT CARE GIVERS. AND OUR
EDUCATORS HAVE A VERY UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE AND ARE CLASSIFIED
WORKERS AS WELL. AND THAT WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE ISSUES OF SAFETY
AND THE PERFECT WE HAVE A
PROFOUND CONSIDERATION THE
CONCERN FOR THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE WORK AND LIVE.
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED RESOURCES
TO LOWER THE TRANSMISSION. AND
A THOUGHTFUL XCELERATED PLANNED
FOR THE VACCINATION. BEFORE
DISCUSSING THIS ADMINISTRATION
SAFE SCHOOL FOR ALL PLAN
REFERRED TO AS THE SAP. WE NEED
TO TAKE A DEEPER DIVE INTO THE
CURRENT DATA AND JUST TO
PROVIDE CONTEXT TO THIS
CONVERSATION. I JUST WANT TO
REVIEW THE STATEWIDE CO THE
DATA ARE CTA STAFF BOB PRODUCES
REPORTS BASED ON THE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE C. T. PH. THE DATA
THAT'S OUT THERE AND DOES THESE
REPORTS FOR US WEEKLY. SO THIS
WOULD HAVE BEEN BASED ON THE
CASE RATES THAT WERE REPORTED
JUST THIS LAST WEEK. CASE RATES
ROSE AGAIN R. TWO HUNDRED FIVE
POINT FOUR PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE WE DID HAVE A
DIP IN POSITIVITY RATE THE
STATEWIDE SEVEN DAY AVERAGE WAS
FIFTEEN POINT TWO. HOWEVER THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
RECOMMENDS MAINTAINING THE TEST
POSITIVITY RATE AT 5% OR LOWER.
AND A PURPLE TRAPPED HERE
THRESHOLD INDICATES WIDESPREAD
RISK AT 8% ON THE AND IN EQUITY
B. HEALTH INEQUITY STILL
PERSISTS CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE AND HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO FACE
SERIOUS HEALTH INEQUITIES WITH
VERY HIGH DOUBLE DIGIT
POSITIVITY RATES REACHING AS
HIGH AS TWENTY SEVEN POINT
SEVEN PER THE STATE'S HEALTH
EQUITY AT METRICS. ALL THAT FOR
COUNTIES ARE IN THE PURPLE TEAR.
MANY COUNTIES CONTINUE TO SINK
INTO DEEP PURPLE THE PURPLE
CHAIR IS THE JUST IN CASE RATE
THRESHOLD OF SEVEN CASES PER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND. RIGHT NOW
FIVE COUNTIES ARE TEN TIMES
PURPLE INCLUDING FRESNO LOS
ANGELES MADERA SAN JOAQUIN
INVENTOR A- AND SEVEN COUNTIES
ARE TEN TIMES PURPLE INCUR
INCLUDING KERN KINGS MERCED
MONTEREY RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARD
DINO AND TOOK TO LARRY. OUR
EDUCATORS WANT TO GET BACK TO
THE CLASSROOMS AND CAMPUSES BUT
DON'T WANT TO COMPROMISE THE
SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AND
COMMUNITIES. OVER THE LAST NINE
MONTHS WE'VE SUPPORTED THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATORS EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
PP FOR SCHOOLS LOBBY FOR KOBE
NINETEEN TESTING AND TRACING OF
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
ADVOCATE FOR COMPREHENSIVE
TRANSPORT TRANSPARENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS
ASKED FOR A BILL AVAILABLE
ACCESSIBLE CO THAT NINETEEN
RELATED DATA AND ADVOCATED FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS
TO ACCOUNT FOR KOBE NINETEEN
RELATED COSTS. YOU CAN READ OUR
PREVIOUS LETTERS THAT WE SENT
IN JULY JULY EIGHTH AUGUST
THIRTEENTH SEPTEMBER SIXTH
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH AND JUST TWO
DAYS AGO ON JANUARY NINETEENTH.
AND I WILL SAY THAT WE DO AGREE
WITH OUR MANAGEMENT PARTNERS
THAT SOME OF THE PROVISIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN MOST RECENTLY
OUTLINED IN THE GUIDANCE AND
THE SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL PLA
WOULD HAVE BEEN HELPFUL TO HAVE
SOME OF THAT INTERVENTION AND
ASSISTANCE LAST SUMMER AS WE
WERE PLANNING FOR SAFE RE
OPENINGS. THERE ARE CONCEPTS IN
THE SAP THAT THAT DO HAVE
MERIT. THERE IS A BENEFIT TO
OUR MEMBERS AND OUR STUDENTS.
AND SCHOOLS A BIG SALMON
DISCUSS THE MOST THOUGHTFUL
RESPONSIBLE ELEMENTS OF THE
PROPOSAL. THEREIS A WAY TO
IMPROVE UPON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN AND WE
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
PARTNER WITH US TO DO THAT. THE
FIRST CELL ELEMENT IS
TRANSPARENCY RESHAPED THE SAP
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC AND
KEEP PRIVATE K. TWELVE SCHOOLS
INCLUDING GLUCK NOTIFYING LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICES OF PROFIT
POSITIVE COPING NINETEEN CASES
IN SCHOOLS SCHOOL CLOSURES AND
THE NUMBER STUDENTS ARE FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION HYBRID
MODELS AND DISTANCE LEARNING.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO REQUIRES
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS TO POSTER COBIT
NINETEEN SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS ON
THEIR WEBSITE WE SUPPORT THESE
PROVISIONS. WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
IDEA OF A PHASED IN APPROACH
THE SAP PROVIDES RESOURCES FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION TO OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS IN A
PHASED IN APPROACH AND WE
SUPPORT THAT IDEA AS WELL. AS
FAR AS UNIFORM STANDARDS WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
WORK IN ADOPTING THE EMERGENCY
TEMPORARY STANDARD ISSUE BY CAL
OSHA. WE BELIEVE THE STANDARDS
WILL MAKE OUR SCHOOL STAY FOR.
THE PROPOSED SAP PROVIDES
RESOURCES FOR TESTING CONTRACT
RACING FOR STUDENTS AND STAFF
BUT ONLY AS A CONDITION OF
RECEIVING SAP INCENTIVE
DOLLARS. TESTING IS NOT
REQUIRED FOR ELEAZER NOT
APPLYING FOR THE DIVISIONAL
DOLLARS. WE BELIEVE THAT ALL
SCHOOLS NEED RESOURCES FOR
STUDENT TESTING. AND STAFF.
STUDENT AND STAFF TESTING AND
THAT SHOULD BE QUICK BE
REQUIRED BASED ON THEIR COUNTY
TEARS THEIR CASE RATES AND
HEALTH EQUITY INDEX. FOR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE SAP
REQUIRES COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING THE
INCENTIVE GRANT FUNDING.
HOWEVER WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THE SAP COULD CREATE CONFUSION
AND CAUSE ELEAZAR TO IGNORE
SAFETY WHEN REOPENING SCHOOLS
IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO APPLY FOR
THE GRANT FUNDING. RESOURCES WE
APPRECIATE THE SAP PROVIDES
DOLLARS PER STUDENT FOR A RE
OPENING AND SUPPLEMENTAL
STUDENT SUPPORTS. HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE THAT ALL SCHOOLS NEED
RESOURCES WHEN THEY CAN SAFELY
RE OPEN FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. AS WELL AS
RESOURCES TO HELP STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES WHO CHOOSE TO REMAIN
IN DISTANCE LEARNING. WE KNOW
THAT FEDERAL DOLLARS WILL BE
COMING TO THE STATE SHORTLY
THAT WILL DIRECTLY FUND COBIT
MITIGATION STRATEGIES. WE WOULD
WANT THE STATE TO USE THOSE
FEDERAL DOLLARS BEFORE USING
PROP NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS.
HOWEVER THE STEP THE SAP FALL
SHORT IN SOME VERY IMPORTANT
WAYS. THE SAP ENCOURAGES RE
OPENING FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN PURPLE TEAR AND
I SAY DEAR AND I DARE SAY THE
DEEP PURPLE TEAR. THIS IS WHERE
THE LEGISLATURE CAN LEND THEIR
VOICE TO HELP IMPROVE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. THE
PURPOSE HERE IS NOT SAFE. THE
SAP ALLOWS FOR SCHOOLS REOPEN
IF THEY'RE BELOW TWENTY FIVE
CASES PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
WHICH IS NEARLY FOUR TIMES THE
GUIDANCE FROM LAST SUMMER
INDICATED THAT ELEMENTARY
WAIVER SHOULD NOT BE GRANTED IF
THE COUNTY WAS AT AT AT A
DOUBLE THE BASELINE RATE OF
FOURTEEN CASES PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. WE DO NOT BELIEVE IT
IS SAFE TO REOPEN IN PERSON FOR
IN FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION IN
THE PURPLE TEAR. THE
ADMINISTRATION CREATED THE
HEALTH EQUITY INDEX TO MEASURE
CO THE TRANSMISSION BY THE
CENSUS TRACTS COMPARED TO THE
COUNTY. THIS PROPOSAL WOULD BE
IMPROVED IF THE HEALTH EQUITY
METRICS WERE INTEGRATED AS A
CRITERION TO ENSURE IMPROVED
CONDITIONS FOR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR FAMILIES HARDEST HIT BY
COBIT NINETEEN. THE NEXT IS THE
TIMELINE THE TIMELINE IS TO
COMPRESS FOR MEANINGFUL
PLANNING WE SHARE THE CONCERNS
AS NOTED BY THE L. A. RO IN
THEIR OVERVIEW OF THE BUDGET
THAT THE SHORT TIME FRAME AND
THE SIGNIFICANT STEP SCHOOLS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO TAKE. IS
LIKELY AND FEASIBLE AND COULD
DISCOURAGE SCHOOL DISTRICT
PARTICIPATE. OUR MANAGEMENT
PARTNERS HAVE ALSO EXPRESSED
THEIR CONCERNS ON TIMELINE AND
IMPLEMENTATION. ALSO AS YOU ALL
HAVE HEARD PREVIOUSLY
VACCINATIONS ARE NOT PART OF
THE SAP. VACCINATIONS ARE OUR
SCHOOLS HOPE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
ACCELERATING VACCINE ROLLOUT
AND WE ARE HEARTENED THAT
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ARE CONSIDERED
WITH OTHER CENTRAL WORKERS AND
INDIVIDUALS OVER SIXTY FIVE IN
TIER ONE B. VACCINES NEED TO BE
PART OF THE SCHOOL REOPENING
CONVERSATIONS. SCHOOLS NEED A
COORDINATED BACKSEAT
VACCINATION PLAN SO THAT SO
THAT STAFF STUDENTS PARENTS
GUARDIANS AND HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS
WHO ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WERE
ELDERLY OF TIMELY AND
ACCESSIBLE VACCINATION
OPPORTUNITIES. FINALLY WE NEED
TO PLAN FOR THE FUTURE. SAFELY
RE OPENING FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IS ONLY ONE PART OF
A LARGER CONVERSATION WE NEED
TO PARTNER ON WE NEED TO ENGAGE
IN THOUGHTFUL PLANNING FOR
TARGETED INTERVENTION
STRATEGIES FOR STRUGGLING
STUDENTS. INCLUDING RESOURCES
FOR ONE ON ONE TUTORING AT
IDENTIFYING LEARNING NEEDS AND
OTHER SUPPORT SERVICES. THESE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT SHOULD BE
VIEWED IN A MULTI YEAR APPROACH
WE MUST ALSO FOCUS ON THE NEEDS
OF THE WHOLE CHILD INCLUDING
APPROPRIATE COUNSELING MENTAL
HEALTH AND OTHER WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. WE STAND READY TO
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MS THE STERLING
OUR LAST PRESENTER TODAY'S
TRISTEN BROWN WHO'S A
LEGISLATIVE REPRESENTATIVE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WELCOME MR BROWN.
THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA AND
MEMBERS- GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL I
WILL BE- MY MAKING MY BEST
ATTEMPT TO BE BRIEF. WE AGREE
WITH SO MUCH THAT HAS BEEN SAID
TO DAY AND NEED TO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE L. A. ON THE CD
HAVE BEEN. HAVE BEEN DOING OVER
THE PAST FEW MONTHS WE KNOW
THIS IS NO EASY FEAT. AND
REALLY RESPECT THE WORK THAT IS
GOING ON AND ESPECIALLY WITH-
THE DEPARTMENT OF BAD FOR
REACHING OUT FOR COMMENT. WE
DID SEND IN A RATHER LONG
LETTER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION REGARDING THE NEW
GUIDANCE THAT IS COME OUT THAT
POINTS OUT SOME- ISSUES THAT
WILL SHARE WITH THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL. STEW IS
NOT TO BELABOR SOME OF THOSE
POINTS- AT THIS HOUR. BUT WE DO
WANT BATTERIES THAT. WE MUST
HAVE A PLAN FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION THAT WORKS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH VACCINE
AVAILABILITY- AT A POINT WHERE
CASE RATES ARE AT A SAFE ZONE
AND WHEN ALSO IN CONJUNCTION
WITH ICE YOU. CAPACITY WHICH
SEEMS TO NOT NECESSARILY BE IN
EVERY. OR BE A PART OF EVERY
QUESTION. MAYBE MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS. DESPERATELY YOU WANT
TO BE BACK IN THEIR CLASSROOMS
THEY MISTER STUDENTS. WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MAKE IT A SAFE RETURN. AND
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN OPENED WE
THINK THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF. OF
EDUCATORS AND STAFF AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND SO FORTH
THAT HAVE BEEN TRYING TO HOLD
THE SHIP TOGETHER HERE AND WE
REALLY RESPECT THE WRK THAT
HAS GONE ON. AND YOU TO
RECOGNIZE THAT WE ALL WANT TO
GET BACK TO IN PERSON AS FAST.
TO DO THAT WE DO HAVE
CRITICISMS OF SOME OF THE-
BROAD STROKES THAT THE GUIDANCE
IS HAS ALWAYS HAD A PART OF IT
SINCE AS DAVID MENTIONED WE
WERE IN THESE TALKS LAST APRIL
OR MARCH. ALL THE FLEXIBILITY
REQUIRED TO REALLY TARGET THE
NEEDS. IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE. CONGRUENT WITH SCIENCE
AND BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
SITE BY SCHOOL SITES. A
REALISTIC PLAN TO BE ABLE TO
BRING IN THE STUDENTS WITH THE
HIGHEST NEEDS FIRST. WE AGREED
THAT. SUPER BOWL AND ALL THE
OTHER NAMES FOR IT SEEMS TO BE
A RIDICULOUS TIME TO TALK ABOUT
RETURNING TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. OF PACKING FOLKS
INDOORS REALLY TAKES DILIGENCE-
RIGHT NOW IT'S DANGEROUS TO DO
THIS AND WE DO TAKE SOME. ISSUE
WITH THE RESEARCH THAT IS OUT
THERE AND THAT IS BEING RELIED
ON. HOW WE THINK THAT THERE ARE
STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT CHILDREN
CAN BE A SYMPTOMATIC SUPER
SPREADERS. AND WE ALSO NOTICE
THAT THE CDC IS NOTICING THAT.
INFECTION RATES ON FOR CHILDREN
ARE ON THE RISE. WE ALSO LOOK
AT SOME OF THE NATIONAL
DASHBOARDS AND TAKE NOTE THAT
TEACHERS IN NEW YORK AND IN
TEXAS WHERE THEY HAVE RETURNED
IN PERSON. HAVE A HIGHER
INFECTION RATE THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION AT ONE POINT THIS
STATE WAS LOOKED TO AS A
RATIONALE FOR OPENING SCHOOLS
BECAUSE- WE'RE NOT. HAVING A
MORE DANGEROUS ENVIRONMENT IN
SCHOOLS WERE JUST TESTING THEIR
MORE SO OF COURSE WE SEE IT
MORE. BUT NOW THAT TEACHERS ARE
BECOMING INFECTED IN THOSE
AREAS AT A HIGHER RATE THAN
GENERAL POPULATION THAT'S A
SIGNAL TO US THAT- IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AT A TIME LIKE THIS
IS NOT THE MOST PRUDENT AND
SAFE CHOICE. THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT SCHOOLS TO NZXT'S
POSITION WE WANT TO BE CLEAR
THIS IS BROADER THAN JUST
SAFELY RE OPENING IN PERSON
STEMMING AND FLATTENING THIS
CURVE THAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
DO. FOR THE BETTER PART OF A
YEAR NOW. AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
META ANALYSIS OF WHAT CAN BE
THE BEST TOOL IN FLATTENING
CURVES. KEEPING STUFF FOLKS OUT
OF SCHOOLS IS THE NUMBER TWO
MOST. EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
WAY TO DO THAT. AND SO IT SEEMS
THAT THERE IS SOME DISCREPANCY
IN HE SCIENCE WHICH- I'M NOT A
SCIENCE TEACHER BUT IT SEEMS
THAT IF THERE'S QUESTIONS PER
THE SCIENTIFIC MODEL IT'S AN
UNSETTLED QUESTION AND WE STILL
NEED TO FIND ANSWERS TO THESE
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD. REALLY AGREE WITH THE-
CALLS FOR A MORE EQUITABLE WAY
TO SPEND THESE DOLLARS. WE
THINK WE SHOULD BE TARGETED TO
THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE IN THE
GREATEST NEED AND HAVE
INTERVENTION SERVICES RATHER
THAN BROAD GRANTS THAT. HELP
SOME DISTRICTS AND PUT OTHERS
AT ADISADVANTAGE. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE HEARING FROM OUR
PARTNERS IN MANAGEMENT TODAY
THAT- SUPPORT THE FIVE POINT%
THREE BILLION IN SUPPORT FOR
INTERVENTIONS AND TO GROW THIS
AMOUNT AND I THINK WE AGREE
WITH THAT. RATHER THAN THESE
INCENTIVE GRANTS TO RUSH PEOPLE
BACK IN. LET'S CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THE STUDENTS WHO NEED
HELP THE MOST. AND ALONG THOSE
LINES WE'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
THE FACT THAT WE SHOULD BE.
FOCUSING A LOT OF ATTENTION ON
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT. THEM THERE
IS A- LARGE CONCERN FROM
PARENTS AND MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
OF COURSE ARE ALSO PARENTS
STRUGGLING WITH THE SAME
ISSUES. AND THAT THERE IS
CONCERN ABOUT LEARNING LOSS.
AND I THINK SOMEONE SAID IT
PERFECTLY IT'S NOT LEARNING
LOSS IT'S JUST WE'RE STUMBLING
THROUGH A DELAY. D. THE
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT THAT CAN HELP
FOLKS THAT WHEN STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE A GOOD EMOTIONAL BECAUSE
THE ENVIRONMENT THAT IMPACTS
THEIR ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE. SO
MAYBE IT'S NOT THAT THE
TEACHING ISN'T BEING DONE. TO
THEM I MEAN OBVIOUSLY IN PERSON
IS THE MOST OF ACTIVE. BUT THAT
THERE ARE SOME OTHER HERE.
INTERNATIONAL IN A HISTORICALLY
UNSAFE TIME FOR US TO BE
LIVING. ON THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTING STUDENTS PERFORMANCES
AS WELL AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE WHOLE CHILD. WHOLE
STUDENTS. AND NOT JUST WHETHER
OR NOT THEY'RE IN THE CLASSROOM
THERE'S MORE TO IT. LASTLY I
JUST WANTED TO MENTION IT WAS
SAID EARLIER THAT- DISTRICTS
AND LOCALS WOULD BAD ALREADY
HAVE CBA'S COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS. AND WHO
ARE ALREADY OPERATING IN SOME
FASHION WITH STUDENTS IN
CLASSROOMS. I MEAN I NEED TO.
RE OPEN THAT. THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT AND I
WOULD JUST CAUTION- TO SAY THAT.
IS THERE MIGHT BE CBA'S THAT
WERE AGREED TO PRIOR TO
KNOWLEDGE AND ALSO HAVING THE
FORESIGHT TO KNOW THAT THESE
INCENTIVE GRANTS MIGHT BE ON
THE HORIZON OR WHAT PLANS MAY
OR MAY NOT BE. AND SO THOSE
THOSE AGREEMENTS- MAYBE STALE
IN THE CAR INTO AND WHAT WE'RE
HAVING TO DEAL WITH RIGHT NOW
AND- WE BELIEVE THAT IF WORKING
CONDITIONS DRASTICALLY CHANGE
YOU DO NEED TO RETURN TO THE
TABLE TO TALK ABOUT THE IMPACTS
OF THOSE. SO GIVEN THE OUR AND
I KNOW THAT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS ON AND I DON'T
WANT T GET IN THE WAY OF THAT
I JUST WANT TO. ITERATE ONE
MORE TIME- OUR- SCHOOLS ARE
OPEN HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND
VISUALS ARE MAKING THAT HAPPEN
WE WANT TO GO BACK TO IN PERSON
FEEL
AND UNFORTUNATELY. THIS VIRUS
HAS NO EMPATHY IT HAS NO REGARD
FOR OUR STRUGGLE AND IT POSES
THE HEALTH THREAT OF THE
CENTURY WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
THE LONG LASTING IMPACTS OF
THIS VIRUS ARE GOING TO BE.
RETURNING IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
WILL TAKE A HISTORIC EFFORTS
AND GOVERNMENT ACTION THAT.
HONESTLY I DON'T THINK WE'VE
SEEN IN DECADES I DON'T KNOW IF
I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFETIME-
BUT PERHAPS MY GRANDFATHER'S.
AND INTEL VACCINATION RATES ARE
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE. OUR
LETTUCE WRAP UP OUR ADD ON
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING AND LET US BRING IN
A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
PROVIDING IMPERTINENT STRUCTURE
AND- IN CONJUNCTION WITH
VACCINATION OPPORTUNITIES. I
SEE YOU RATES AND CAN. GET A
LOGICAL- CASELOAD RATES THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
BROWN THANK YOU TO OUR LAST
PANEL THANK YOU TO ALL OF OUR
PANELS BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
MEMBER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE THE PUBLIC
WANTING TO PARTICIPATE TO CALL
IN NOW. PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL
FREE NUMBER. 844-291-6364 WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE. NINE OH NINE EIGHT SIX
FOUR. NINE SORRY LET ME REPEAT
THAT NINE OH NINE EIGHT SIX
FOUR NINE SORRY ABOUT THAT. I
WILL NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS WHO WANT TO
COMMENT DOES ANYONE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. CENTER
LAYERED. I THINK WE'RE STILL
GOING TO HEAR A LITTLE FROM THE
PUBLIC BUT I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT TESTIMONY'S BEEN POWERFUL
IT AND THE REAL QUESTION HERE.
IS JUST CONSIDERING HOW
WORKABLE. THE ITEM IS IN FRONT
OF US AND- THEN I JUST LOOK
FORWARD TO CONVERSATIONS TO TRY
TO MAKE IT WORKABLE. THANK
CENTER LAYERED CENTER PAM. SO I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE SOMEONE FOR
THE PART PUBLIC HEALTH WE DO
YES- SO I GUESS I'LL POST MY
FIRST QUESTION TO C. P. H. AND
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
TO JOIN US. TODAY WE JUST HEARD
FROM BOTH THE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA JUST A
STATION CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS THAT- THERE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE- WHAT'S
BEING RECOMMENDED. FOR THE
PROGRAM IN TERMS OF WHEN WE
BRING PEOPLE BACK WHEN WE BRING
OUR CHILDREN BACK TO SCHOOL IN
TERMS OF THE GENERAL COMMUNITY
RATE. IS PERHAPS- NOT WELL
PERHAPS TO HIDE SAID D.
PREVAILED MADE REFERENCE DEEP
PURPLE AT CETERA- CAN YOU SPEAK
TO THE C. P. H.'S- ROLAND
DECIDING WHEN AT WHAT LEVEL AND
WHAT THE RISK IS FOR- STUDENTS
COME BACK TO SCHOOL BOTH RISK
ON HIS HIS STUDENTS BUT ALSO TO
THE STAFF- AND THIS DISC AT
LEAST THIS CONCERNED AT
SIGNIFICANT STERN RAISED BY THE
TEACHERS. AROUND THIS ISSUE
AND- EVEN MAYBE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT- SOME OF THE- RESEARCH
THAT THEY'VE LOOKED AT SO CAN
YOU JUST SPEAK TO THEM THAT'S
WHAT SEEMS TO BE THIS
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED. AND THE
CONCERNS OF THE AT LEAST THE
TEACHERS THAT INSPECTS OF THIS
HEARING. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US DOCTOR BARTEK. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE RECORD- AND I- THERE'S
A COUPLE IMPORTANT THINGS- THE
DATA I REALLY APPRECIATED THAT
THE AND I READ CAREFULLY THE-
RESPONSE FROM C. F. T. R. ABOUT
THAT THE DAY THAT WE CHOSEN-
THAT THAT WORKS ARE PRESENTING
AS THE AS THE CASE AND I WOULD
SAY THAT- IT'S EXTREMELY-
THERE'S A LOT OF DATA OUT
THERE- THE DATA WE USED AS A
RATIONALE FOR THAT- TWENTY FIVE
PER HUNDRED THOUSAND. IS BASED
ON- HARVARD GLOBAL HEALTH-
GROUP RECOMMENDATIONS AS WELL
AS A PRETTY RECENT ARTICLE OUT
OF- PEDIATRICS WHICH IS A ONE
OF THE HIGHEST IMPACT-
PUBLICATIONS AND THE FIELD I'M
LOOKING AT. SCHOOLS IN NORTH
CAROLINA THAT HAD A HIGHEST
CASE RATE ABOUT. TWENTY NINE
PER HUNDRED THOUSAND PER DAY-
THAT SHOULD THERE'S VERY IF YOU
THE RIGHT MEDICATION STRATEGY
IN PLACE AND ACTUALLY FOCUSED
ON- MASKING AND JUST WILL
DISTANCING- AND HAND WASHING IF
THOSE ARE PLACES THAT YOU THEY
HAD VERY VERY FEW OUTBREAKS
THEY HAD LIKE I FORGET IT'S IN
SINGLE DIGITS THE NUMBERS OF
TRANSMISSIONS AND THAT IT ON A
SCHOOL SETTING. AND THEY HAD-
BUT NO CHILD TO STAFF
TRANSMISSION. SO THAT DATA IS
HOPEFUL FOR A FOR US TO REALLY
HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTICE THAT IT HAS
TO BE THAT THERE'S MITIGATION
STRATEGIES IN PLACE WE CAN'T
JUST SAY IT'S SAFE TO RE OPEN-
AND JUST DO IT HOWEVER YOU WANT
TO DO IT BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
YOU KIND OPEN. IF YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT MEDICATION STRATEGIES IN
PLACE AND JUST A FEW OTHER
PIECES OF DATA THAT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED ONE WAS- BUT
THE IDEA OF CHILDREN BEING
SUPER SPIDERS- THE DATE ON THAT
IS ALL ABOUT SYMPTOMATIC
PATIENTS- SYMPTOMATIC- CHILDREN
WHO'VE BEEN TESTED WHO HAVE
HIGHER VIRAL LOADS- AND A
CONCERN THERE AND THAT THERE'S
A STUDY FROM INDIA ALSO. AGAIN
FOCUSED ACTUALLY JUST ON
SYMPTOMATIC PATIENTS SOME OF
THE REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE IS
THAT ONE OF THE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES AND SYMPTOMS
SCREENING WE GOT TO TAKE THAT
SERIOUSLY WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
AS MUCH BUT IT IS ONE OF THOSE
IMPORTANT USEFUL THINGS AND
WHEN I READ THOSE STUDIES I
SAID GRANT WE HAVE. SOMETHING
IN PLACE TO BREAK THAT CHAIN OF
TRANSMISSION- AND THEN THE LAST
PIECE OF THE CDC. DATA THERE'S-
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S INCREASED
RATES OF OUR- THIS IS THE END
CHILDREN BUT THAT'S ACTUALLY
TRUE BECAUSE A POPULAR RATES
ARE. AND THERE IS ANOTHER STUDY
LAST WEEK FROM THE CDC SHOWING
THAT THE RATE AND CHILDREN OF
THE INCREASE IS THE SAME AS THE
POPULATION RATE AND SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN AND THE YOUNG ADULTS
EIGHTEEN TO I THINK I WAS
TWENTY FOUR ALTHOUGH IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN THE SLIGHTLY OLDER
AGE RANGE THAT. SLOPE IS
ACTUALLY SPEAKER INDICATING
THAT THERE IS ACTUALLY ACTIVE
TRANSMISSION IN THAT AGE GROUP
MORE SO THAN AND OF THE YOUNGER
AGE GROUP AND SO THE CDC
CONCLUSION IS THAT SCHOOL RE
OPENING DID NOT IS NOT DRIVING
TRANSMISSION. AND THERE. AT THE
END OF THAT REPORT WAS SCHOOL
SHOULD BE THE LAST NAMES TO
CLOSE AND THE FIRST THINGS TO
OPEN. SO THAT DATA TO ME IS ALL
VERY IMPORTANT DATA FOR US TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND- YOU KNOW.
THAT IT IT IS STILL THE GOAL IS
TO DO SAFE. REOPENING AND
REASONABLE APPROACHES. OKAY
RESHAPE THAT PRESENTATION I
GUESS THE ADDED A COUPLE FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS THAT NUMBER ONE IS
THAT AND I KNOW YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE STUDIES. IN OUR OWN
STATE WE DO HAVE- SUMS SOME
SITUATIONS IN WHICH THERE ARE
KIDS GOING TO IN PERSON
LEARNING PRODUCT PERHAPS MORE
IN SOME PRIVATE SCHOOLS OR
OTHER PLACES. ARE WE COLLECTING
DATA INCLUDING CONTACT TRACING
ON ANY OUTBREAKS OF THINGS
GOING ON IN SCHOOLS THAT ARE
DOING. IN PERSON LEARNING HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
WELL PUBLIC AND PRIVATE- I
REALIZE THAT WE JUST ASK THE
QUESTION HOPE THAT SINCE THE
BAR EDUCATION COULD TELL US HOW
WHICH CHOOLS ARE HAVING
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN BUT- IT IS
THERE SUFFICIENT CONTACT
TRACING DATA THAT WE CAN FEEL
CONFIDENT. THAT THEIR OWN
EXPERIENCE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE OPEN- THAT.
THAT WE'RE NOT SEEING THE
TRANSMISSION THAT'S HAPPENING
AS A RESULT OF THE STATE.
STUDENTS ATTENDING SCHOOL AND I
KNOW THIS MAINLY APPLIES TO
YOUNGER STUDENTS WERE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE TEENS WERE
FOCUSING ON ON THE YOUNGER
STUDENTS. YEAH THAT'S RIGHT- SO
THERE'S SOME DATA IT'S NOT LIKE
I. I WOULD SAY IT'S NOT
SYSTEMATICALLY COLLECTED- AS
YOU KNOW WHEN I CAN FROM MY
POSITION AND SAN FRANCISCO
LISTENING AND TRYING TO HEAR
OTHER OUTBREAKS. I'M NOT
HEARING ANY OUTBREAKS I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO SEMICIRCULAR CISCO
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. MY
UNDERSTAND FROM SAN DIEGO IS
THEY'RE NOT SEEING OUTBREAKS
AND IT'S THE OUTBREAK SINCE THE
IN SCHOOL TRANSMISSION THAT WE
REALLY ARE LOOKING FOR AND I
THINK THERE'S TWO REASONS LOOK
FOR A WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND. IS
THEIR ON GOING TRANSMISSION
WE'RE NOT THAT THAT WERE NOT
THAT. THE DATA IS NOT HELPING
US TO ANTICIPATE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE BE ABLE
ABLE TO SEE THAT. AND HEN THE
OTHER PIECE THAT. WE NEED TO
LEARN IF THIRDS TRANSMISSION WE
KNOW WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON IN ORDER TO
PREVENT IT FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN. AND OUR TO HAVE
EVERYBODY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO DO IT THAT'S WHY
IT'S HELPFUL TO LOOK AT THESE
OTHER- YOU KNOW PLACES IN NORTH
CAROLINA RATHER. PUBLICATIONS
THAT TELL US YOU KNOW WHAT OF
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS TO DO
RIGHT- AND THAT THERE ARE SOME
CASES FROM THE NORTH CAROLINA
PAPERS ARE. BASED BASED OFF
WHEN THEY DID HAVE AN OUTBREAK
THAT IT WAS RELATED TO
PRESCHOOLS NOT MASKING AND
SPECIALIZED SITUATIONS WHERE
KIDS WERE SITTING REALLY CLOSE
TOGETHER WHILE THEY'RE EATING.
SO THAT THAT WAS GREAT YOU KNOW
LESSONS LEARNED FOR WHAT THEY
CAN DO DIFFERENTLY SO- THE ONE
OF THE GOALS OF THIS.
INITIATIVE INCLUDES THAT
TRANSPARENCY COLOR FOR EXACTLY
THE REASON YOU GUYS ARE TALKING
ABOUT WE WANT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW MANY SCHOOLS ARE
OPEN AND THEN ALSO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU DON'T IS
THEIR TRANSMISSION GOING ON OR
IS THIS. YOU KNOW HYPOTHESIS
PROTEST I PROCESS ALL THE DATA
REGISTER NOW THAT SAYS THERE IS
VERY LIMITED TRANSMISSION THAT
HAPPENS IF YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
MEDICATION STRATEGY IN PLACE.
WE WANT TO DOUBLE CHECK THAT'S
TRUE IN OUR CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
AS WELL SO I GUESS THAT FIND
THE FINAL PART. IS THAT. SO WE
HAVE OUR TEACHER EARLY SHOPPER
ZENSAR. SAYS SCIENCE THAT. THE
HEARING FROM THEM. BETTER
REALLY CONCERNED AND DON'T WANT
TO REAL. AT THE LEVEL THAT YOU
ABOUT. WHAT OF COMMUNITY. HAS
BEEN HAPPENING BETWEEN. C. P.
H. IN NICE IN YOUR VETTING
DEPARTED SCHOOL SAFETY TEAM
DAN'S- SCHOOL EMPLOYEES- AND
WHAT KIND OF DOLLARS GOING ON
IN TERMS OF TALKING ABOUT THE
EVIDENCE THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT
BECAUSE I THINK SOME RIGHT TO
QUESTIONS RAISED ABOUT SOME OF
THE STUDIES ETCETERA. THAT WE
CAN AT LEAST COME TO SOME
GENERAL AGREEMENT ABOUT WHERE
WE SHOULD BE DOING THIS- SO- SO
KEY AND TO A CERTAIN TIME OF
THAT'S FOR YOU TO ANSWER OR FOR
THIS- FOR MISTER ALLEN. AND I'M
ALSO CURIOUS TO HEAR FROM THE
BOTH OF THEM THIS EASTERLING
AND MISTER BROWN TERMS OF
FLIGHT. COMMUNICATIONS BEEN
HAVING IN TERMS OF REVIEWING
THIS DATA AND EVIDENCE TO COME
TO SOME GENERAL AGREEMENT ABOUT
OKAY- NOW PEOPLE FEEL
COMFORTABLE ABOUT THESE ARE THE
STANDARDS WE NEEDS IN THE
COMMUNITY HAVE REALIZES ALSO
THINGS THAT HAVE TO HAPPEN IN
THE SCHOOLS YOU SAID. THAT
PEOPLE THAT THAT THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES FEEL COMFORTABLE TO
GO BACK TO WORK AND- THE SAID
DAVE ALL EVERYONE'S EXPRESSED A
DESIRE TO GO BACK AND. AND
DOING IN PERSON LEARNING- YOU
HAVE A BILL OF SAY ONE OR TWO
THINGS WHICH IS THAT I- YOU
KNOW HAVING HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS. FOR A LONG TIME
NOW WITH- EVEN BEFORE I CAME TO
THIS ROLE IN EARLY DECEMBER
TALKING JERRY- TEACHERS AND
TEACHERS UNIONS THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER SINCE APRIL I THINK THAT
THERE'S ONE REALLY IMPORTANT TO
SAY WHICH IS THAT I THINK
THERE'S- YOU KNOW
UNDERSTANDABLE ABSOLUTELY.
POSSIBLE ANXIETY AND FEAR. AND
SO THERE'S A PART OF THE ISSUES
THERE'S DATA AND THEN THERE'S
ALSO AN EXPERIENCE OF YOU KNOW
BEING PART OF A PANDEMIC AND
BEING PART OF ME THAT'S PART OF
THE PANDEMIC SO. I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT WE NEED TO REGARD
SOCK ABOUT BOTH OF THOSE
PIECES- I. I ACTUALLY HAVE IT
ON MY TO DO IS TO REACH OUT TO
MISTER BROWN ACTUALLY AND TO
OFFER TO TALK TO THE SCIENCE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A SHARED AN UNDERSTANDING
AND YOU KNOW HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION IS EXTREMELY
HELPFUL AND IMPORTANT- BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO. KNOW THAT THERE'S DAY PEACE.
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO THE
HELPING PEOPLE JUST. GET OVER
THE- THAT ALSO ARAMBULA. BUT
BUT MAYOR MISTER ON ALSO WANTS
TO. TO TRAIN ABOUT THE-
EDUCATION. IT JUST TO QUICKLY
ECHO THAT IT DID WE- AS A THING
MISTER LANE MISTER BROWN- SPIRO
OUT OTHERS- CONTEST WHILE WE'VE
BEEN SAY NOT REGULAR
CONVERSATIONS AND IT STARTED
GOING UP JUST REFERENCE BILLS
WILL BE CONTINUING ON AS WE
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION SO JUST
JUST THAT WE HAVE HAD THOSE IN
THAT THEY WILL BE- OBVIOUSLY
CONTINUE CONVERSATION AND KNOWS
STOCK BUYBACK NOTED A NEW
STADIUM EVENTS COME TO LIGHT A
NEW QUESTIONS ARISE HAS NEW
HEADLINES COME UP. AND SO IT
DOES HAVE TO BE A CONTINUING
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU AND
WHAT I'M GONNA DR BECAUSE I
KNOW SHE HAS TO SO THANK YOU
MUCH FOR BEING HERE BUT DR
PANDA GERMANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS WELL ACTUALLY I WAS
HOPING. MIGHT GET A BRIEF
COMMENT FROM- THE CATHOLIC
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. NO THAT'S
FINE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
DOCTOR BARDIC KNOWS THAT SHE
HAS ANOTHER COMMITMENT AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
TO BE WITH US THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD DR PAM. YEAH ACTUALLY FAT
IF THERE CAN BE THAT WHAT THE
IF BOTH CTA AND CFT COULD ALSO
PERHAPS RESPOND AS WELL. YES
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
DOCTOR PAN YEAH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND- HAS
BEEN WORKING WITH DR BOB
HARRISON WHO'S AN OCCUPATIONAL
HEALTH DOCTOR SO IT'S NOT LIKE
THIS IS JUST SOMETHING THAT
WERE. PUTTING OUT THERE IS WHAT
WE SAY IS UNSAFE WE ACTUALLY
WORK WITH WITH THE DOCTOR AND I
THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
STANDUP AND GIVES REALLY GREAT
DOCTORS CAN DIFFER ON ON ON ON
WHAT ON THEIR OPINIONS. AND
THEN I'LL POINT TO A MOST
RECENT STUDY OUT OF MONTREAL
WHICH I THINK IT WAS THE FULL
STUDY THAT WE MAY WANT INCLUDED
IN THE IN THE DIALOGUE WHICH
ACTUALLY SHOW THAT THAT THAT
STUDENTS ARE. ARE CAN SPREAD
THE VIRUS AND THAT WOULD
PROBABLY BE THE MOST RECENT
DATA- AND JUST. I THINK WHAT.
IS MOST HELPFUL MOVING FORWARD
IS THE IDEA THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS- WILL HAVE TO REPORT
THE DATA BECAUSE IT HASN'T BEEN
TRANSPARENT YOU KNOW IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. OTHER
STATES HAVE HAD DATA DASHBOARDS
FOR MONTHS. AND WE DON'T HAVE
THAT FOR SCHOOLS SO IF THIS NEW
POLICY LEADS US TO ACTUALLY
SHOWING AND DEMONSTRATING
WHAT'S HAPPENING UNDER SCHOOL
SITES THAT'S A GREAT THING BUT
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
ASKING FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
THANK YOU. JUST ADD THAT-
DOCTOR. IS COMPLETELY CORRECT
THERE IS A- INTENSE AMOUNT OF
FEAR IN IT AMONG OUR RANK AND
FILE- THINKING THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GO TO WORK AND THEN.
EITHER NOT COME. HOME OR DIE IN
AN I SEE YOU OR YOU KNOW TRUCK
WAITING IN LINE FOR AN ICO. AND
THAT DOES. THE IMPACT OPINION
QUITE A BIT. AS A ORGANIZATION
WE'VE DONE OUR DUE DILIGENCE-
TO WORK WITH YOU RESEARCHERS AS
WELL AND FIND OUT OTHER
INFORMATION THAT'S WHY WE HAD A
YOU KNOW FOOT NOTED CITED
LETTER- TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
WITH LOVE DICK TO CONTINUE THAT
DIALOGUE BECAUSE IT IS AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CTA STATES IT IT
DOES SEEM LIKE. YOU CAN ASK TO
DOCTORS AND I'M A LAWYER BY ALL
MEANS I KNOW YOU CAN ASK TWO
PEOPLE QUESTION YOU GET TO A
DIFFERENT ANSWERS AND I IT'S
REFRESHING TO KNOW THAT THIS
HAPPENS IN THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY AS WELL PERHAPS- BUT-
TO THAT. TO THAT DEGREE YOU
KNOW WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS ARE TO FIGURE
THAT OUT AND JUST NOW I AM
NOTICING THE SACRAMENTO BEE. IS
REPORTING THAT THERE ROSA
ROSEVILLE- SCHOOLS HAVE HAD TO
A QUARANTINE AND HUNDREDS OF.
STUDENTS ARE HAVING TO
QUARANTINE BECAUSE THEY TRIED
TO GO BACK. TRIED TO PLAY
SPORTS. AND SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE BEST LAID PLANS AND
WE UNDERSTAND THE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES THAT ARE PART OF
THESE PLANS. WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT. YOUNG STUDENTS WERE
TALKING ABOUT POPULATIONS OF.
MAYBE YOU KNOW THE OLDER SO I
KNOW WHEN I TALK ABOUT OLDER
STUDENTS COMING BACK YET. BUT
IT'S A GENERATION OR AGE GROUP
RENOWNED FOR- BUCKING THE-
ESTABLISHMENT GUIDANCE AND SO
THERE ARE GOING TO BE. LARGE
LEAKS THERE ARE GOING TO BE
MASS TRANS MISSIONS WE BELIEVE
WHEN YOU BRING. SO MANY FOLKS
BACK TO SCHOOL TO GO BACK TO SO
MANY HOUSEHOLD TO INTERACT IN
SO MANY WAYS IT'S A COMPOUNDING
ISSUE AND SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE GOING TO DO IT
RIGHT. AND TO SENATOR CORTEZ
HE'S- SENTIMENT. THAT'S IT.
LET'S MAKE SURE WE'RE PUTTING.
OUR HORSES IN FRONT OF CARDS
USE THE METAPHOR YOU'D LIKE BUT
ITSEEMS TO PICK A DATE AND SAY
NO WE CAN MAKE THIS WORK- IS
NOT THE BEST STRATEGY WHEN
LIVES ARE AT STAKE- SO IT SEEMS
TO ME- THAT AND AGAIN I AM VERY
SYMPATHETIC. TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESIRED AND I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE WILL. THINK
LEADING MYSELF WOULD LOVE TO
SEE YOUR KIDS BE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL- IN PERSON
LEARNING I THINK IT'S GOING TO
IS AND I THINK IT WAS EXPRESSED
THIS IS. ONLY GONNA BE BETTERED
AND DISTANCE LEARNING ON
AVERAGE- BUT I ALSO FEEL THAT.
WE HAVEN'T REALLY DONE OUR
GROUND WORK. IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO MOVE THIS TRIAL PROPOSAL
BECAUSE IF THE TEACHERS ARE
TELLING US LIKE OKAY WELL WE
HAVE AND WHERE YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT THERE YET IN TERMS OF OUR
EXAMINATION THE DATA AND I
CERTAINLY AGREE THAT I DON'T
THINK THE TEACHERS ARE JUST
MAKING THIS UP THERE. THEY HAD
THEIR CONSULTING THEIR OWN
EXPERTS AND SO FORTH. WE NEED
TO GET TO SOME KIND OF
CONSENSUS WE ALSO NEED TO BE
SURE WE HAVE. THE ABILITY TO
BUILD THAT WE HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT AS WELL THAT THE
CAPACITY TO COMMUNICATE. BUT
ALSO AND THEN WE HAVE AN EVEN
START TALKING ABOUT
COMMUNICATING PARENTS AS WELL
SO WE'RE TO. TALK ABOUT THE
EMPLOYEES AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
TO HAVE. THE CAPACITY TO
IMPLEMENT AND KIND OF SORT OF
NARROWLY MORE FOCUSED ON THE
TESTING PIECE OFIT BUT- EVEN
FEEL LIKE EVEN JUST FOR THAT
PARTICULAR COMPONENT. THAT- I'M
SURE WE'RE I MEAN BY HERE WE
FOR SHE- IT FOR. AND SO FORTH
BUT I AM NOT. THAT FEELING THAT
CONFIDENT THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY
SET PEOPLE UP FOR SUCCESS IN
TERMS TO BE ABLE TO FIND THE
KIND OF SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE
THEY WOULD NEED TO
SUCCESSFULLY. DO THAT IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT. WE JUST HEARD FROM OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERT THAT YOU
DO NEED TO HAVE THAT TESTING IN
THAT OTHER PIECES IF WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN UP SAFELY EVEN AT
THE STANDS THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT. SO ALL THE PIECES DON'T
SEEM LIKE THEY'RE QUITE QUITE
COME TOGETHER YET. AND AND
MAYBE- THE L. MAYBE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND COME BACK
AND TELL US TELL ME HOW WRONG
BUT- AT LEAST ONE MONTH HEARING
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE ALL THE
PIECES ARE DOT AND THAT THAT'S-
THAT'S- JUST. CONCERNING TO ME.
AND THEN THAT THAT EVEN TALKING
ABOUT WHETHER WE SHOULD USE
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS OR
WHATEVER OTHER FUNDS JUST IN
TIME TO TRY TO MAKE THIS THING
GO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
PAN AGAIN THANK YOU TO ALL OF
OUR PANELS THAT PRESENTED TODA
WE APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
INFORMATION. I WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANYONE WILLING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS. TWO ONE MINUTE EACH
PLEASE. MAIL LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT HERE ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. SIR ANYONE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE. WHO
WOULD WISH TO PROVIDE A COMMENT.
WELCOME. I KNOW YOU ALL LOOK AT
ME AND JUST SEE A FLAB AND MY
VOICE KERRY'S NUMBER VS AND YOU
WANT NOTHING MORE FOR ME TO BE
SILENT AND GO AWAY BUT I CAN'T
DO THAT BECAUSE I ONCE ATTENDED
THE POOREST OF POOR SCHOOLS. I
WALKED THOSE HALLS. I ATTENDED
A HIGH SCHOOL WITH A 50% DROP
OUT RATE. WHAT WHAT THIS IS
DOING RIGHT NOW. TO THE POOREST
AND THE MOST MARGINALIZED
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S
HURTING THEM DRASTICALLY. THEY
DON'T WANT TESTING THEY DON'T
WANT ONE MASCHINE AND THEY
DON'T WANT A VACCINE. THEY WANT
THEIR SCHOOLS OPEN THEY WANT
THEIR TEACHERS BACK. THEY WANT
THEIR NORMAL LIFE BACK. WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
EXTRA. AND ATHLETICS AND IT'S
LIKE SENATOR MCGUIRE SAID THIS
THIS PATCHWORK PLAN ISN'T GOING
TO WORK. AND THIS PAINTING THE
HOPES ON A VACCINE IT'S NOT
REALLY A VACCINE BY LEGAL
DEFINITION IT DOESN'T MEET THE
CRITERIA. IT'S BEEN SPEAKS
CERTAIN USE DOES NOT LABEL TO
THIS SITE AND UNDER PUBLIC
HEALTH WISE. IT IS ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR BY THE MONNING AYE THANK
YOU MA'AM YOUR ONE MINUTE IS UP
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THAT
WE APPRECIATE IT YEAH YOU
REALLY DO I CAN TELL ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY PLEASE
GO TO THE MICROPHONE. WELL GOOD
FOR YOU. THIS IS HER NAME SHE
DIDN'T. WELCOME SIR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN MAKE YOUR CRIMES DAN
MCKENNA HI DAN REALLY ATION IS
A HUMAN BEING I'M A
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS. IF YOU ASK A
SCIENTIST HOW TO STOP A VIRUS
THAT SPREADS THROUGH HUMAN
INTERACTION DON'T BE SURPRISED
WHEN THEY TELL YOU STOP HUMAN
INTERACTION. LOCKDOWN MASK A
KEEP YOUR DISTANCE DANGER YOUR
LOVED ONES ARE NEAR. NO HUGS
HANDSHAKES LOVE THY NEIGHBOR GO
ONLINE FOR SCHOOL OR WORK FOR
PLAY ZOOM KINDERGARTEN SCREEN
AGERS THE SOCIAL DILEMMA FEAR
DRIVEN ALGORITHMS POLARIZING
EVERYONE'S DYING ANTIFA WHITE
SUPREMACISTS TERRORISTS ARE
COMING AFTER YOU. LOOTING AND
INSURRECTIONS BAD ACTORS HIDING
IN MOM'S HEARD STUPIDITY.
MASKED TRACKBACKS INTEREST CDC
WHL WTF. LIES MASQUERADING AS
SCIENCE NATURAL HERD IMMUNITY
NO SUCH THING THANK YOU DAN
RIGHT THANK YOU RIGHT VACCINE
HERD IMMUNITY CANTERING TOOK.
THANK YOU SIR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME. WITH
ONE OF. WHILE THIS MORNING ON
HOW OF ALL THIS ORDER. PLEASE
PROCEED THE TRUTH IS. THE CTA
THESE UNIONS THEY'RE ALL IN
CAHOOTS THEY DON'T WANT TO COME
TO WORK IF THEY WANT THE MONEY
SCOTT ATLAS HE BASICALLY IS THE
HOOVER INSTITUTE WORKED IN THE
WHITE HOUSE STATED JUST THREE
DAYS AGO CHILDREN FOURTEEN AND
UNDER. THEY ARE NOT SHUTTERS OF
THIS VIRUS THESE ARE FACTS HE
ALSO STATES THAT THE SCHOOL IN
GENERAL IS A LOW. NO PLACE TO
GET THAT THE TO GET THE-
BASICALLY COME DOWN COVERAGE.
SECOND OF ALL- THE THIRD THING
IS BASICALLY. WORK IF. I'M SO.
FRUSTRATED I'M SORRY FOR OKAY I
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
EXPRESS MYSELF WITH THE WITHOUT
BEING. PUT ON THIS TIME
SCHEDULE BUT I UNDERSTAND WHAT
IT IS- THE SAD THING IS CHARLES
WEAVER WAS JUST ACTUALLY
ARRESTED FROM HARVARD TWO DAYS
AGO FOR THE COVERED CARTEL
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON THERE'S
ACTUALLY PICTURES OF YOU WITH
DR BIDEN YOUR- TIME'S UP SIR
YEAH YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE THAT
WISHES TO TESTIFY. THAT'S FINE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE. YEAH
THAT'S EXACTLY SO. BEFORE YOU
GO FOR ME. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME COMPANY PROJECT. GORDON
ELEVEN YEAR OLD SHOT AND KILLED
HIMSELF ON HIS IN CLASS NOT TOO
LONG AGO. UNDER THE FEDERAL LAW
STATE AND LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE ALL CHILDREN ELIGIBLE
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION OR
RELATED SERVICES UNDER THE I.
D. E. A. BUT THE FREE AN
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION. THAT
NATION SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE
CURRENTLY MANDATED PROVIDED A
TAILORED TO THEIR INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS AND IDEATE THEY ARE NOT
IN FACT SACRAMENTO COUNTY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
REFUSED. TO PROVIDE ANY IN
PERSON ASSESSMENTS ANY
ELIGIBILITY SEVENTH. ANY IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES. I
GOOD NEGOTIATION WHEN THERE ARE
LEGALLY REQUIRED TO DO SO-
THESE KIDS ARE DROWNING AND NO
ONE'S LISTENING AND I WANT TO
BE LEFT BEHIND HOW MANY MORE
KIDS TO THE TECHNICAL ISSUE TWO
THOUSAND HAD TO RESUME CALL FOR
SOMEONE TO LISTEN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT PLEASE.
WELCOME STATE YOUR NAME HI MY
NAME IS RICHARD ARM ONE COMMENT
THAT I HAD A FRIEND DIE
YESTERDAY HE DIED BECAUSE HE
WORE MASKS HE ONLY DID IT FOR
ABOUT A WEEK YOUR ONE HE GOT A
BACTERIAL INFECTION THAT KILLED.
ALL DOCTOR CAN. YOU ARE A JOKE
TO ME YOU ARE A BUNCH OF
LETTERS I'M SORRY LET ME FINISH
SHE CALLED KNOW YOU EIGHTIES
MAY NOT CONSULT THE MEMBERS WE
HAVE NOT INSULTED YOU. HE
CALLED SOME LADIES TERRORIST IN
OUR MOTHERS WHO SUFFERED
VACCINE INJURIES TO THEMSELVES
OR THEIR CHILDREN HE CALLED
THEM TERRORISTS BECAUSE ALL
THEY WANT IS TO HAVE A CHOICE.
WHETHER TO GO TO BE VACCINATED
NOT HE CALLED THESE DECENT
LOVING LADIES TEARS. THAT IS
WHY C. WHAT I SAID. ARM WE
DON'T NEED TO GOING NAME PEOPLE
TEARS **** WHATEVER MIGHT BE
BECAUSE IT'S PUTTING TARGETS ON
PEOPLE'S BACKS. KNOWN THE
VACCINES OWN MAKE SOMETHING
VERY CLEAR AND I WANT TO FINISH
IS TO MAKE IT CLEAR WHAT YOUR
SITE YOUR TIME'S UP SO THINK IF
I'M ACTUALLY DID YOU WHAT.
THREE AM I TO. THE PHONE PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR RECOGNIZING.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND THE
SPIRIT OF MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR I WILL READ ONE OF HIS
QUOTES WE NEED LEADERS NOT IN
LOVE WITH MONEY BUT IN LOVE
WITH JUSTICE NOT IN LOVE WITH
PUBLICITY BUT IN LOVE WITH
HUMANITY HOW IS YOUR STRAWBERRY
FIZZ LIP GLOSS CONNIE LEYVA I'M
ALL OUT WE IS YOUR BANK MIKE
MCGUIRE. USEFUL FOR ME IN THE
SAP HE. YOU CALL ME A TERRORIST.
WIENER TWEETS ABOUT ME I'VE
BEEN IN THIS BUILDING A HUNDRED
TIMES I'VE SPOKEN IN DOZENS OF
HEARINGS I AM A MOTHER OF FOUR
THAT IS MY KINDERGARTEN TEACHER
HUSBAND AND YOU FRAME ME AND
THIS IS THE JOHN KNOWS THIS IS
WHAT YOU'RE DOING THANK YOU
MA'AM. THANK YOU MA'AM. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY OKAY WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. SEEING
NO ONE. WEWILL NOW GO TO OUR
PHONES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING.
THANK YOU GONNA TAKE A QUICK
RECESSED MEMBERS OF MODERATOR
STAND BY PLEASE.
WHEN TO GET
STARTED WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THAT WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. HELLO TO LIE NUMBER
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION- FIRST WOULD JUST
LIKE TO COMMEND THE GOVERNOR
AND ADMINISTRATION FOR FOCUSING
ITS ATTENTION ON SAFELY RE
OPENING SCHOOL THIS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. STAYS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE ON
ACHIEVING THESE GOALS HOWEVER-
TSA IS DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT
NON CLASSROOM BASED PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE EXCLUDED
FROM THE RE OPENING GRANT
FUNDING. WE WOULD AGREE WITH
SENATOR GLAZERS THIS EXCLUSION
IS INEQUITABLE TO MANY NON
CLASSROOM BASED PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS PROVIDE PROGRAMS THAT
UTILIZE SIGNIFICANT ON MY ON
SITE INSTRUCTION TYPICALLY TO
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
STUDENTS WITH THE CUTE NEEDS-
WE HAVE HAD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE
ALWAYS APPRECIATE. THEIR
PARTNERSHIP- BUT WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH
THEIR RATIONALE FOR EXCLUDING
THE SCHOOLS WELL IT'S TRUE MANY
OF THE SCHOOLS ARE ABLE TO
ADAPT TO ONLINE LEARNING MORE
QUICKLY IT DOES NOT NEGATE THE
FACT THAT THE SCHOOLS FACE THE
SAME RE OPENING CHALLENGES THAT
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL SPACE
TESTING PP AND ADDITIONAL
SAFETY PROTOCOLS WILL BE
CHALLENGING FOR OUR NON
CLASSROOM BASED PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS. AND THEREFORE WE
BELIEVE THEY SHOULD NOT THEY
SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN THE
FUNDING PROPOSAL YEAH YES THEY
BELIEVE ANY PUBLIC SCHOOL THAT
MEETS THE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN TO PROVIDE ON
SITE INSTRUCTION SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THE
NECESSARY FUNDS TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF ITS STAFF AND
STUDENTS. WE THEREFORE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT THE EXCLUSION OF
NON CLASSROOM BASED PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS BE STRICKEN
FROM THE DROP LANGUAGE SO THAT
ALL SCHOOLS THAT OTHERWISE MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR ONLINE ON
SITE INSTRUCTION CAN BE
ELIGIBLE FOR RECEIVING FUNDS.
WE ALSO AGREE WITH THE ISSUES
AND CHALLENGES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED TODAY BUT IN THANK YOU
SIR YOUR MINUTES- TO OUR- THAT
WOULD. MAKE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATE REFORM WE
GET OUR NEXT. CALLER HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE.
I HAVE SIX IN Q. A THIS TIME
GREAT THANK YOU MUCH TO GOOD OR
NOT CALLER PLAY. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LIKE SCHOOLS AND FIGHT BASED
CHARTER MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATION
OPERATING ACROSS SIX COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
VISIONS IN EDUCATION AND DON
CLASS REBATES CHARTER SCHOOL
SERVING SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
ACROSS NINE COUNTIES IN THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO REGION AND
BAY AREA BRIEFLY ON BEHALF OF
THE SPIRE PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE DO
SHARE THEIR CONCERNS- SHARED BY
MANY OF THE PANELISTS TODAY.
ABOUT THE ABSENCE OF THE
PROPOSED VACCINATION PLAN AND
SUPPORT MISTER BEAR DISTORTION
THAT FINDS FOR SUPPORTING
CASTING INFRASTRUCTURE
STRUCTURE SHOULD NOT COME OUT
OF PROP NINETY EIGHT WE WILL
FOLLOW UP WITH THE MORE
DETAILED LETTER ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS WE DO APPRECIATE
HOWEVER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
FLEXIBILITY AROUND THE
ELIGIBILITY OF CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES TO CONDUCT
SUPERVISION OF THE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WHEN IT GETS PAID
TO DO SO. ON BEHALF PROVISIONS
IN EDUCATION I WANT TO ALIGN
OUR CONCERNS WITH THE ONE
SHARED BY SENATOR GLAZERS ABOUT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PROPOSED EXCLUSION OF NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT RELY PARTIALLY ON ON SITE
PAGE PROGRAMS FROM IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION PERHAPS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
INSTEAD OF A FULL EXCLUSION OF
ALL INTO THE VEHICLES FROM THE
PROPOSED GRANT. THAT YOU
INSTEAD CONSIDER LIMITING ANY
EXCLUSIONS THOSE SCHOOLS THAT
PROVIDE ONLY VIRTUAL LEARNING
EXPERIENCES OR THOSE WITH
MINIMAL INCLUDING. THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. A THANK
YOU LINE FOR SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO NAME IS KEEPS OF
AN EXECUTIVE FOR HERITAGE PEAK
CHARTER SCHOOL REAL VALLEY
CHARTER SCHOOL. AND TO OTHER
SCHOOLS AND WE WERE SERVED
THIRTY ONE HUNDRED STUDENTS AND
RICHARD SIXTEEN COUNTIES WELL
WE GENERALLY SUPPORT THE GOALS
OF THE TWO BILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSAL. ENCOURAGED TO
ENCOURAGE SCHOOL TO OPEN
PROJECT INSTRUCTIONS YOU CAN.
TAKE A POSSIBLE. MEDICAL
INCLUDING OUR SCHOOLS ARE
EXPLICITLY EXCLUDED FROM
ELIGIBILITY FOR THESE GRANTS
SCHOOLS THAT OFFER ONSITE IS
pHYBRID PROGRAM. WILL NOT
RECEIVE ONSITE FUNDING GRANT
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN.
SCHOOLS LIKE OURS ARE TYPICALLY
NOTED NON QUESTION BASED
CHARTER SCHOOL WENT BACK MANY
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT ONSITE
LEARNING OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME
OF THE MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS
IN THE STATE. OUR LEARNING
SITES ARE PARTICULARLY. A
CENTRAL POINT TO CONNECTION
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ENGLISH LAW AND IN
THE QUEUE NEEDS SUCH AS- ALMOST
NEXT AND FOSTER. ALL SCHOOLS
OFFERING ONSITE INSTRUCTION
MUST RECEIVE THE NECESSARY
FUNDING TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF
STUDENTS AND- STAFF LIKE ALL
OTHER CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND
SCHOOLS THAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE
HAVE HAD TO DOUBLE THE VIRTUAL
ENVIRONMENT DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WE'RE GOING IMPORTANT
ONSITE ELEMENT OF THE PROGRAMS
FOR THE ENTREE COMPONENT OF OUR
RENTER'S CENTRAL SIMILAR
PLEASE. AND WILL HAVE BEEN AT A
CONCERT THANK YOU SIR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE A COLORS IF I CAN
REMIND YOU ONE MINUTE PLEASE WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE. IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU FOR SEVENTY SIX WHICH
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
WE CAN. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS RYAN PESTERED BY MY
FATHER FOR MANY YEARS IN
SHERMAN OAKS. A CONCERN ABOUT
THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY. ABOUT
TRANSMISSION AND SEVERITY AND
RECOVERY CONSIDERING CHILD
CONSERVATIVE BEING OPERATING
MILEAGE BAKER FULLY INCLUDING
ANNA UNIT. INCLUDING YOUR
PROFOUND JANET. COOKE COULD
HAVE BEEN OPENED FIFTH MARCH
WITH. THE MEASURE. BAND THE
GOAL POST IS KEEP MOVING NOW WE
HAVING ADDITIONAL BOXING WEEK.
BY A A. U. S. B. WE CAN ALL
REALLY NOTION. DAY AFFECT METAL
BOX. AND ALL WE HAVE LOOKED
BEFORE VERY OF THE- IF I. THANK
OBVIOUSLY NOT GOING TO BECOME.
THERE IS BASED CALIFORNIA IS
THE ONLY THAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS
HAVE CLOSED WHILE AND THE GOLD
IT'S KEY MOVING MOVING. WE
SHOULD LOOK AT OTHER AND
COUNTRIES LIKE CANADA ISRAEL
GERMANY DENMARK DOT. IT IS
ALSO. A FIFTY YEARS DOWN TO
OPEN SCHOOL SUCCESS. WITH PPA.
REALTOR THANKS. FOR BEING SPENT
WORRYING THANKS FOR THANK YOU
SIR NEXT CALLER FOR. THANK YOU
LINE ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AIR NAPPY ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN
THE EQUITY COALITION WE PROVIDE
THE JOINING OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OPTIONAL LOCALLY NEGOTIATED
WILL BE OPENING PROPOSAL MAYBE
TEN MANDATORY RE OPENING
APPROACH THE STATE OF THE DUTY
TO PROVIDE CRAZY IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION OPTION FOR FAMILIES
AND STUDENTS WHO WANT. IT
DISTRICTS ARE UNABLE TO REACH
LOCAL BARGAINING AGREEMENT
BEFORE THE DOZEN UNITY WE
SHOULD IMPLEMENT AND AGO SHE
ADDED STATEWIDE RE OPENING
STANDARDS AND ENSURE THAT ALL
DISTRICTS RECEIVED THE
NECESSARY FUNDING GUIDANCE AND
SUPPORT TO RE OPEN.
ADDITIONALLY THE CATEGORY OF
HIGH NEED STUDENTS IN ALL
GRADES THAT ARE PRIORITIZED FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION SHOULD BE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE ENGLISH
LEARNER AND INCARCERATED YOU.
WOULD AGREE THAT EDUCATORS AND
STUDENTS ON TRACK TO RETURN IN
PERSON AND THOSE IN THE MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITY SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED FOR VACCINATION THE
LAST PLACE WILL BE OPENING PLAN
SHOULD BE DEVELOPED IN
CONSULTATION WITH LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES AND SUBJECT TO A
PUBLIC HEARINGS. ALREADY
OPENING CANNOT HAPPEN
SUCCESSFULLY WITHOUT COMMUNITY
COLLABORATION AND PARTICULARLY
IN AREAS HARDEST HIT BY KOBE
NINETEEN THE EQUITY COALITION
PROVIDED THESE AN ADDITIONAL
SUGGESTIONS ON RE OPENING AND I
THINK YOU MA'AM. IN THE LETTER
THAT WE SUBMITTED THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
EIGHTY TREES AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS JOANNA- I WOULD FIRST
LIKE TO SAY THAT PLEASE DON'T
MISTAKE PEOPLE CONCERNS OVER
MANDATED VACCINES FOR ANY LACK
OF SYMPATHY TO THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED AND DIED FROM
KOBE ED- YOU CAN BE CONCERNED
ABOUT VACCINE MANDATES AND BE
SYMPATHETIC FOR THOSE INJURED
AT THE SAME TIME. I'M GOING TO
READ SOMETHING FROM STRAIGHT
FROM THE CITY OF THIS WEBSITE
ABOUT THE COMPANY- BAXEEN. IT.
IT'S UNCLEAR IF THE VACCINE
ACTUALLY PREVENT US FROM
GETTING INFECTED WITH CODE
NINETEEN OR ENTRY BACK NEED A
PERSON CAN SPREAD THE VIRUS NOT
QUITE MASCHINE AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING ARE STILL CRUCIAL.
WE ARE ALL CONCERNED ABOUT NOT
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL IN THE
BACKSEAT OF HERE WHICH ISN'T
EVEN PROVEN TO HELP PREVENT
TRANSMISSION. SO AND YOU WILL
PASS YOU CAN TEST POSITIVE FOR
ANTIBODIES THANK YOU MA'AM AND
MANAGES THANK YOU YOUR FOCUS
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
YES GO AHEAD YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI AM APRIL THE CAN THE
P. AND L. A. COUNTY AYE OPPOSED
MANDATORY VACCINATION FOR A
DISEASE THAT HAS A NINETY NINE
POINT 97% RECOVERY RATE FOR
CHILDREN THEY SHOULD NOT BE
MATH THEY SHOULD NOT BE SOCIAL.
BUT YOU JUST WANT TO GET A
VACCINE THAT'S UP TO THEM
PEOPLE THAT HAVE GOTTEN THE
BACKING SO FAR TWO POINT 7% YOU
NO LONGER WORK FROM THE SEVERE
INJURIES THAT THEY HAVEN'T
HEARD FIFTY FIVE HAVE DIED AND
BURNED IN NORWAY THE MODERN OF
ACTING ADVISOR BACKING HAVE
KILLED SO MANY THAT CHINA WILL
NOT BE ALLOWING THOSE TO
VACCINES IN OUR COUNTRY. I
THINKTHAT THERE IS A GREAT
DEAL OF DATA THAT IS BEING LEFT
OUT OF YOUR DATA AND I WOULD
THINK THAT YOU SHOULD HAVE MORE
HELP FOR US SHOW ME. THE
NUMBERS. ASSEMBLY YOUR GET. HE
GOT BACK HE TAKE OF. CLEARLY
YOUR MAKE MONEY OFF THEIR AND
YOU ARE PAID OFF. IT IS THE
BACKING WILL CHANGE. OUR INNATE
OF CHILLED. ARE ARE ANYTHING
YOU MA'AM MINUTE IS UP NEXT
CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU I DON'T
TWENTY FOUR CALL. HI THERE MY
NAME IS TINA AND I KNOW OF A
SCHOOL AND COULDN'T. MY SCHOOL
BEEN HOME SINCE MARCH MY GRADER
HOPING SCHOOL YOUNG- THE DAY IN
THEIR MEN HEALTH IS REMARKABLE.
I REALLY THINK THAT NONE OF
THIS IS COVERING HIGH SCHOOLERS
AND HIGH SCHOOLERS ARE THE
HIGHEST RATE OF DEPRESSION AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUICIDE OTHER
WITH STUDY THAT SAID THAT 25%
OF TEENS AND YOUNG ADULTS
CONTEMPLATED SUICIDE IN THE
BEGINNING OF COULD ACT BECAUSE
IT LOCKED DOWN. WE REALLY NEED
TO FOCUS ON HIGH SCHOOLERS AND
GETTING THEM BACK IN SCHOOL
THERE ARE MANY SCHOOLS MY
DAUGHTER'S SCHOOL INCLUDED THAT
IS READY TO GO BACK WITH PEOPLE
WENT. ALL THE REQUIREMENTS BUT
HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO THE
BECAUSE THEY CHOSE NOT TO GO
BACK IN THE RED HERE BECAUSE
OF- BECAUSE THE FINAL
BASICALLY- THEY WERE TOLD THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO OPEN IN
JANUARY AND THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO OPEN  WOULD ALSO OFFER
THAT YOU DEFEND AND THAT THE
FUTURE OF THE VACATION WITH
SENSITIVITY THE PHD DOCTOR. A
BAR DAY THANK YOU MA'AM YOUR.
MINUTE IS UP NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINES NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FOUR NINE YOU OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SO SORRY I
WAS ON MUTE I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS MICHELLE FORD AND
I'M CALLING WITH JUST A FEW
POINTS. SO THERE WERE
APPROXIMATELY TEN MILLION CASES
OF. THE POSITIVE. CASES IN
WUHAN AND OUT OF THAT TEN
MILLION. THAT WORK AS FROM
KANNADA CARRIERS THEY WERE LESS
THAN THREE HUNDRED CASES THAT
WERE TRANSMITTED. SO I DON'T
SEE A NEED FOR TESTING TRACING
TRACKING AND MONITORING THAT
OUR STUDENTS ESPECIALLY AT THE
TUNE OF TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY THERE WAS SOME
TALK REGARDING A POTENTIAL FOR
A VACCINE MANDATE. SHUTTLE IF
YOU GO TO BACK TRACKER DOT COM
THIS IS A WEBSITE BEING USED TO
MONITOR VACCINE RELATED SIDE
EFFECTS THAT THEY RELATE TO.
NOT ONLY THE CODE NINETEEN
VACCINE BUT OTHERS. V. A. X. X.
TRACTOR DOT COM YOU CAN SEE THE
DATA FOR YOURSELF IN REAL TIME
IN THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS
THERE HAVE BEEN ONE HUNDRED AND
THREE CASES. IT VACCINE RELATED
SIDE EFFECTS THANK YOU MA'AM
YOUR MINUTE IS UP PLEASE GO THE
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LAUREN AND
I'M A PARENT CALIFORNIA FIRST
OF ALL MASKS ARE NOT SAFE FOR
ALL SHE CASTING HAS BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED EVEN BY DOCTOR
FELT CHEATED PCR TEST WITH A
HIGHER CYCLE THRESHOLD ARE
LARGELY INACCURATE IT IS ALSO
UNDISPUTED THAT THE PCR TEST
WIDELY USED IN THE US AND
AROUND THE WORLD ARE USING
CYCLE THRESHOLD WITH ANY
UNRELIABLE RANGE OF THIRTY TO
FORTY AND MORE. THAT'S REDUCING
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF FALSE
POSITIVES AND ULTIMATELY
PERPETUATING THE OVER ARCHING
RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING OUR
SOCIETY ECONOMY AND HUMANITY AS
A WHOLE REGARDING THE VACCINE
MANUFACTURERS AND IS MATED EVAN
DID NOT BEEN PROVEN TO PREVENT
TRANSMISSION NOR PREVENT THOSE
ACTING TO CURB SPREADING THE
INFECTION. IN ADDITION IT'S
STILL AN EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION KILL UNDERGOING
SURVEILLANCE FOR ADVERSE
REACTIONS AND INJURY IN ITS NOT
YET FULLY APPROVED BY THE FDA
TO EVEN CONSIDER. MANDATING
THAT EXPERIMENTAL INTERVENTION.
ON GREATER CONCERNING. FURTHER
THE DEATH RATE FOR KOBE
NINETEEN AND THAN 1% AND ARE
SEVERAL SUCCESSFUL TO AVAILABLE
FOR THOSE ARE SYMPTOMS. AND OR
WITH. AT AND THE SOUTH OF DOC
AND SCIENTISTS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE GLOBE ARE VOICING THEIR
CONCERNS THE RESPONSE BECAUSE
THE NINETEEN. HAVING FAR
REACHING NEGATIVE IMPACTS AND
NOT BASED ON THE QUEUE MA'AM
YOU'RE. TIME IS UP SOME OF NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU VITAL
ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEN WE SORRY I NINE ONE ONE
FOUR. YEAH I MUST MEET- THANK
YOU MY NAME IS FELLOW I'M A
PARENT IN CALIFORNIA IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY I WANT TO TELL THE
COMMITTEE THAT I THINK THE
FUNDING ALLOCATION FOR THE
STATE SCHOOL FOR ALL PLAN
SHOULD ENSURE EQUITY PER
STUDENT THAT MUST REMAIN IN A
LEARNING DISTANCE LEARNING MODE
WHEN SCHOOLS REOPEN. I'VE HEARD
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR FUNDING IT ONLY TOOK PART
IN PERSON LEARNING DISTRICTS
MUST GET FUNDING NECESSARY
TALKER DISTANCE LEARNING WITH
THE MAXIMUM ACCEPTABLE STUDENT
TEACHER RATIO I THANK MY
DISTRICT IF IT WOULD COMMIT TO
A MAXIMUM CLASS SIZE FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING CLASSES IT
WILL NOT. BRING STUDENTS BACK
TO CAMPUS FOR IN PERSON
LEARNING REQUIRES HALF SIZED
CLASSES WILL CANNOT NOT DOUBLE
THE NUMBER OF TEACHERS
THEREFORE STUDENTS WHO REMAIN
IN DISTANCE LEARNING ACTUALLY
ENABLE IN PERSON LEARNING TO
OCCUR BECAUSE THEY BRING UP THE
ON CAMPUS BUT THERE IS NO
ASSURANCE THAT THESE STUDENTS
WILL NOT BE IN ZOOM CLASSES THE
FORTY FIFTY SIXTY OTHER
STUDENTS THIS IS NOT RIGHT. THE
STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE QUALITY OF
EDUCATION EQUAL TO THAT OF IN
PERSON LEARNING FOR STUDENTS OF
IMMUNO COMPROMISED FAMILY
MEMBERS DISTANCE LEARNING IS
NOT A PREFERENCE BUT A
REQUIREMENT THE FUNDING
ALLOCATION SHOULD ENSURE EQUITY
THANK YOU MA'AM YOUR TIME. IS
UP NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE SEP TWENTY CALL I
HAVE. WELCOME NOW MANY OF YOU
MAY BE AWARE OF JOURNALISM
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ESTIMATES
BECAUSE GENERATION OF CHILDREN
AT RISK OF LOSING MILLIONS OF
YEARS OF LIFE TO BE CLEAN. IT'S
NOT A PAYMENT I HAVE I HAVE
HUSBAND. THE CARD FOR STUDENTS
WHO ALREADY FACE SOME
EXPERIENCE RACISM. AND WILL
HAVE UNICORN. ENGLISH LANGUAGE
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS AND
FOSTER. THE HOBBIT. DESTROYED
THE COURT COULD. IS IT POSSIBLE
IF INCLUDE ABOUT THE QUICKLY
EVOLVING STANDARDS PROTOCOLS
THE VILLAGE THOSE RELATED HAD
BEEN. STRONG BELIEVE EDUCATORS
INCLUDING OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKERS A PRIORITIZE ABOUT ALL
ACROSS. FINALLY TO OUR
COLLEAGUE EQUITY COMMUNITY WE
URGE THE STATE TO PROTECT. ALL
AGES THE NEW YORK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CALLER. THANK YOU
DON'T WANT THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS A PART
OF IT AS YOU KNOW YOU. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING TODAY OTHER A
LOT OF ONE OF QUESTION I'M JUST
SAY FOR S. THE ARE YOU IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ANY POLICY FOR
SPECIALLY AT. DAHLE MEASURE
THAT YOUR APPLY AND EQUITY THEM-
I THINK THAT IT HOPES CAN BE UP
SOON AS IT IS PROP THE WE DON'T
KNOW SCHOOL. ARE ALREADY OPEN
WITHOUT THAT INPUT WE DON'T
KNOW HOW ACT THIS PLAN IS A
MOTHER HELP IS REALLY GOING TO
GO TO THE BLACK AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED BY CALLED IT SO WE
JUST HOPE THAT. THE COMMITTEES
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE ALWAYS APPLYING THE EQUITY
LENS AS WE MOVE FORWARD- AND
WILL COMMIT A LETTER WITH-
CONCERNS YOU QUICKLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
ONE. SEVEN PLEASE GO. WE'RE
SORRY WE'RE GOING TO ONE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO
MY NAME IS KISHA BOREDOM- I'M
AN EDUCATOR FROM SAN DIEGO AND
PRESIDENT OF THE SAN DIEGO
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OUR CERTIFICATED
EDUCATORS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS- PURPLE. IS NOT SAFE
FOR REOPENING. SANTIAGO YOU
HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE SCHOOL ITES AND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE DISTRICT
COVERS A VERY LARGE PORTION OF
OUR CITY AND BECAUSE OF OUR
SIZE THEIR COMMUNITIES IN OUR
DISTRICT THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
FIVE EIGHT TIMES THE
TRANSMISSION RATES THAT OTHER
COMMUNITIES IN OUR DISTRICT
ARE. EXPERIENCING ARCADIA
UNIFIED BOARD TRUSTEE RICHARD
BARRERA EARLIER CLEARLY
OUTLINED WATER DISTRICT IS
DOING TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS AND
STAFF STATE WHICH IS BASED ON
CLEAR ADVICE FROM HEALTH
EXPERTS AND WE HAVE BEEN IN
COLLABORATION. IN THIS WORK
WITH THE DISTRICT MY ASK IS
THAT OUR ELECTED LEADERS
FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
EDUCATORS ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THE VACCINE IF DESIRED AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE AND COMBINE THAT
EFFORT WITH ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR THE GOING TESTING. FOR
STUDENTS AND STAFF THAT IS
NECESSARY I ALSO ASK THAT WE
STOP ISSUING DATES FOR RE
OPENING AND INSTEAD CREATE
CLEAR GUIDELINES FOR RE OPENING
THAT ARE BASED ON COMMUNITY
TRANSMISSION RATES THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM AVAILABILITY
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OVER THE LINE WE SHOT. THERE
ARE YOUNG BOYS I'M CAN WITH THE
DIRECTION THAT THE BILL IS
TAKING AT A TIME OR AT THE OF A
LOCAL MY A PLATE I THANK WHEN I
GET A FOOTBALL BUT NOT PURCHASE
TO GO SCHOOL WE TO CALL OTHER
GOT OTHER INTERESTS ARE. A
LITTLE BIGGER WALMART BETTER
GET THE ON THE COMPUTER. THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN FOR RE OPENING
IS UNREALISTIC. REALLY TALK
ABOUT BEING ON THE FUTURE
NATION OF TERRIFYING. THE FACT
THAT OCCURRED REQUIRED HAVE
BEEN TAPPED OVER THE- OF YOUR
NOT MONTHS. TO LEARN HOW
THEMSELVES IN THE- CLASS. THEY
NEED TO BE IN. NOT TOMORROW NOT
NOT GET NOW. ABOUT NO TE NO
THAT THE- VISION NOT A DOCTOR
THE MORE QUESTION WHO. IN ORDER
TO GET AN EDUCATION. BY SON IS
AN IMPORTANT PART TIME ARE THE
FOR THE WAIVER. NO VACCINE NO
TESTING IN THE- ONE CASE. ONE
IT'S TIME TO STOP USING OUR
CHILDREN AND THE POLITICAL.
GAME OF JOHN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU FORTY FOUR PLEASE CALL. HI
MY NAME IS JOHN DR IN A THREE
INCLUDING ON FOSTER RUSSELL A
QUICKLY THE ISSUE MENTION ABOUT
THE HIGH SCHOOL WHAT ROSE BY
SCHOOL SCHOOL ON IT WAS A THEY
WERE OVER QUARANTINE THEY'RE
SHUTTING ON HOLD. AND SHOULDN'T
FOSTER IN THE FLOOD TO LABOR
NOT INCREASE SPREAD. ROSE CITY
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH IS
CATERING. HAS OPEN FULL TIME.
SINCE OCTOBER FOURTH IT CAN BE
DONE IMPACT BRING SOME FROM
THERE ON SPENT. NUISANCE REOPEN
GOING TO DO OPPOSITE THEIR
CLOTHES DOWN SCHOOLS NOT OPEN.
LIKE I SAID WE ARE FULL TIME.
WILL EXCEPT FOR LUNCH FIVE DAYS
A WEEK THIS IMPLEMENTED
PREVIOUS STAKE INSTANCE ALSO
SEE GOD. THE MOST RECENT KIND
OF PUBLISHED JENNIFER PUT THIS
AT RISK THOUGH IN PARTICULAR
THE FOUR FOOT MINIMUM DISTANCE
WILL FOR STUDENTS. IN ALMOST
EVERY CASE IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACHIEVING THEIR FULL
DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF IN PERSON EDUCATION. MY KIDS
OTHER FROM THE STATE LAST THAT
ESSENTIALLY FORCES SCHOOLS TO
DO HYBRID AND IF THEY CAN'T DO
THAT. THEN THEY HAVE TO BE ON
PERSONAL LINE THIS WILL NEED TO
BE CHANGED BACK TO WIN
PRACTICAL OR ELSE THE REST OF
THE GUIDELINES ARE MADE. PLEASE
PUT AN END TO THIS SCHOOL CAN
HELP CANNOT OPEN SAFELY AROUND
THE COUNTRY IN THE STATE.
BREAST CANCER THANK. YOU THANK
YOU SIR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIGHT AWAY IN PLACE.
AHEAD GOOD MORNING THIS IS
THEIR CLINIC ON THE AFTERNOON
THIS IS DEREK LANGONE BEHALF
THE STATE'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOL I WANTED TO START BY
RECOGNISING THE SCALE OF WHAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION'S TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL
APPRECIATE. WITHOUT THAT I WANT
TO POKE MY COMMENT ON JUST ONE
ISSUE. IN NEARLY EVERY COUNTY
IN THE STATE SCHOOL DISTRICT
ARE ALREADY PROVIDING IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION TO VARIOUS EXTENTS.
WE BELIEVE THE PROPOSAL MUST GO
FURTHER TO SUPPORT STUDENTS IN
CURRENTLY OPEN SCHOOL. FIRST WE
WOULD URGE FLEXIBILITY TESTING
THE SPECIAL DISTRICT AT
REGIMENT THAT ALREADY WORKING
BATES A LOCAL HEALTH CONDITION.
SECOND THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
DISTRICTS. THAT HAVE BEEN
SERVING STUDENTS IN PERSON
SINCE AS FAR BACK IN AUGUST
JAMPACKED WITH THE FUNDING
WITHOUT UNDERMINING WHAT'S
ALREADY WORKING. FINALLY ADDING
NEW AND DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS
AND GUIDANCE THE HUGE SETBACK
FOR DISTRICTS. AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES AT A PARTY IN
NEGOTIATED A PATH FORWARD. WITH
THAT SAID WE WOULD WORK-
HEALTHY ALL DISTRICTS. NOT ONLY
RIO BUT WE OPEN YOU THANK YOU
SIR NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU I
DON'T WANT NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHARACTERIZED BECAUSE-
THE VOCATIONAL ONE. BANK WHAT
ARE WOULD LOVE TO BE BACK IN
THE CLASSROOM IS LEGAL. BAKERY
OPEN. MARKET MY PAGE RIGHT OKAY
YOU WERE SAYING WELL I'M NOT A
HOPE EIGHT TWENTY IT TWENTY
FIVE OR NOT. K. RIGHT ONE OF
OUR OVER ARCHIBALD MY DISTRICT
REPORTS ARE HARDLY THAT. NINETY
DOLLARS HUNDREDS AS WE ACTUALLY
ARE ONLY ONE CHALLENGING. OUR
INSPECTIONS ARE GOING WHAT ARE.
WELL THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TANYA
RODGERS AND THE CHIEF BUSINESS
OFFICIAL FOR THE SPRINGS
CHARTER SCHOOL NETWORK WHICH IS
A GROUP OF SIX CHARTER SCHOOLS
SERVING CLOSE TO ELEVEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTERS WE HAVE FLEXIBLE
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS WHICH
INCLUDE ONLINE OPTIONS AS WELL
AS INDEPENDENT STUDY OPTIONS.
HOWEVER THE MAJORITY OF OUR
STUDENTS CLOSE TO NINE THOUSAND
TO TEN IN KENYA PROGRAM AT A
FACILITY UP TO FIVE DAYS A WEEK
WHICH RESEMBLE TRADITIONAL
CLASSROOM BY MATT ENVIRONMENTS
TO DENY NON CLASSROOM BASED
CHARTER SITE OPENING FUNDING
BECAUSE ASSUMPTIONS ARE MADE
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE BUILDINGS
IS FALSE AND DISCRIMINATORY. WE
HAVE FACILITIES SERVING
STUDENTS REQUIRE LEASE PAYMENTS
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS UTILITIES
INSURANCE MAINTENANCE AS WELL
AS THE ADJUSTMENTS NEEDED FOR
SAY FREE OPENING DENYING
FUNDING BASED ON AN INCORRECT
ASSUMPTION ASSUMPTION PUTS THE
EDUCATION OF THESE NINE
THOUSAND STUDENTS AT A
DISADVANTAGE WHICH I'M CERTAIN
OF NOT THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTENT. PLEASE ENSURE THAT
FUNDING OF EQUITABLE ACROSS THE
EDUCATIONAL SPECTRUM IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
BE A GREATTHING WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
THE BEST TODAY AND I WOULD LIKE
TO LINE MY COMMENTS WITH THAT
OF THE LAST PANEL WHO. ASKING
REPRESENTS PRIMARILY CLASSIFIED
STAFF AND SOME SIGNIFICATIVA
THROUGHOUT THE K. TWELVE- THE
GRANT AND THEN ALSO A SOME AND
CAN. OUR MEMBERS ARE ANXIOUS TO
GET BACK TO THEIR SCHOOLS BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO BE SURE THAT
THEY INDICATE THAT THE SERVER
SAFE. WE HAD A CONCERNS RANGE
AND ARTICULATED BY OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS CSTA FIJIAN PSG.
CURRENTLY TO SLOW DOWN THERE IS
A FULLY DEVELOPED WELL
COMMUNICATED PLAN TO REOPEN
SAFELY WITH SUFFICIENT FACTS
THANK. YOU THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR LEYVA
AND GOOD AFTERNOON CENTER LEYVA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
BILLY JOEL RIGHT AND PRESIDENT
OF THE HOSPITAL APPOINT THE
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER. I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR HELP
ORGANISE MELTING HEARING THE
COMMENT I WANT TO ECHO WHAT MY
SISTER TEACHER MARTIN SAID IN
REGARDS TO- US COMING BACK IN A
SAFE MANNER AS. TEACHERS I
WANTED TO GIVE A VOICE. WE WILL.
TO THERE WITH KIDS. YOU REALLY
WANT TO WE ARE KNOWN AS THE
TEACHERS WHO WILL JUMP ON WITH
THE SAME OUR KIDS I WOULDN'T
TAKE MY CARPET OTHER THAN
COUNTY FIX I HOPE THAT YOU ALL
TO PAY ATTENTION TO THE
TEACHERS WHO DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN. FOR OUR KIDS AND TO FIND
THANK YOU AGAIN OF ONE THREE
THREE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AYE TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS DOUG THAT'S BECAUSE YOU CAN
HEAR ME. YES WE SURE CAN'T- I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
POSSIBILITIES ASSOCIATION I
JUST COULDN'T TAKE NOTE THAT
THERE IS NO ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM BUT THERE'S SOMETHING MUCH
SMALLER AND MORE INSIDIOUS AND
THAT IS THE VIRUS THE VIRUS
DOESN'T HAVE A VOICE. BUT IT
DOES HAVE A GOAL AND THAT GOAL
IS TO. KATE AND TO REPRODUCE.
AND SO OUR GOAL. THROUGH CTA IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE SAYING THAT OUR
TEACHERS ARE SAYING
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE IN THE
PURPLE PHONE IN L. A. COUNTY
RIGHT NOW AND UNFORTUNATELY WE
DO NOT HAVE A SUFFICIENT NUMBER
OF VACCINE. AT THIS TIME IN
FACT TEACHERS ARE ONE TEAM BUT
WE'RE NOT EVEN CLOSE TO
PROVIDING VACCINES FOR ONE B. I
KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
STUDIES THAT STUDENT- IN
SHOWING A POSITIVE OF
POSSIBILITIES REGARDING GOING
TO SCHOOL WITH THEIR YOUNG
HOWEVER I THINK THIS IMPORTANT
POSITION. DUE TO THE LACK OF
TIME THE LACK OF RESOURCES THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE STATE WE WANT OUR
HOMELESS TO LEARN WE LOOK AT
THE WHOLE CHILD WE WANT TO
THANK YOU SERVE THEM THANK YOU.
YOUR TIME IS UP NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I WON THIRTY
Y. THREE OF GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JIMMY CARTER I'M HERE
TO ASK THAT YOU OPEN OUR
SCHOOLS FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
RETURN. IT SHOULD BE THEIR
CHOICE. LESS THAN 1% DIE FROM.%
A CORONAVIRUS. NINETY NINE
PERCENT. THAT IT IT'S BEEN
REPORTED. THAT IDEAS ARE
OVERCROWDED WITH KOBE PATIENTS.
BUT NOT WITH THE KOBE CARE AND
MY CANCERS ARE NOT CO THAT CAN.
I PERSONALLY HOME ANY PUBLIC
SCHOOL GOING TO. SHE WE FOLLOW
THE RULES WE CAN NO ISSUE LEFT
ABOUT OUR TAXES. OUR MONEY NOT
YOUR TO PUSH AGENDA. AND KIDS
DYING DUE TO SUICIDE PANEL
BLAME YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE THE
ANSWER YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE TO
ANSWER TO ME BUT YOU WILL HAVE
TO ANSWER FOR THIS GOD SHE ALSO
MAKE OUR HAD MERCY ON THE STOCK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
SHIFTED TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS NATALIE LUCY HALE
AND THE MOTHER OF TWO AND I DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT THERE'S ANY
REASON TO WASTE VALUABLE
LEARNING TIME OR MONEY ONLINE
TEST BEING HEALTHY CHILDREN
WEEKLY ON TOP OF THERE'S NO
NEED TO PAY FOREIGN OBJECTS
THAT MIGHT HELP THE CHILD'S
NOSE. AND I DO NOT AGREE WHERE.
MANDATING OR PUSHING A VACCINE
OPEN THE SCHOOLS THIS IS AN
EXPERIMENTAL PRODUCT AND
THERE'S BEEN TONS AND TONS OF
ADVERSE REACTIONS. AND VACCINE
MANUFACTURERS ARE FREE FROM MY
ABILITY AND I AM NOT WILLING TO
USE MY CHILD AS A GUINEA PIG
ARMENIANS OF THEIR NEPHEWS OR
YOUR CHILDREN. IT SHOULD BE A
PARENT'S CHOICE THAT THEY WANT
TO VACCINATE THEIR CHILDREN
WITH THE COLD AID NINETEEN
VACCINE TO SEND THEM BACK TO
SCHOOL. THERE'S JUST TOO MANY
RISKS. I DO NOT OUTWEIGH THE
PROS OF THE VACCINE THAT WITH
THE VIRUS I HAVE A 99% RECOVERY
RATE AND- MASK THANK YOU MA'AM
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARES LABOR IN
THERE TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IVANKA AREA WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS. ACCESS
AGREED WITH EARLIER COMMENTS
THAT PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
SHOULD NOT BE USED FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH ASPECTS OF THE
PLAN. THAT PROP NINETY EIGHT ON
THE RESERVE OR DIRECT STUDENT
SUPPORT AND INSTRUCTION.
ANOTHER AREA OF CONCERN RELATES
TO A SYMPTOMATIC TESTING. HOUSE
CADENCES WERE NOT ONLY COME THE
NET COST AND LOGISTICAL. BUT
THERE IS ALSO A LEGITIMATE
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE
EFFICACY OF THIS APPROACH. WE
RECOMMEND PROVIDING ELEAZAR
ABILITY TO WORK WITH LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
DETERMINED THE BEST. APPROACH
FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES. LAST
WEEK SCHOOL LEADERS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AS
CONCERNS RELATED TO COLLECTIVEBARGAINING THE TYPICALLY
ABSTRACT PARKING REQUIREMENTS
WOULD JEOPARDIZE EQUITABLE
STUDENT ACCESS IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. WE RECOMMEND
CONSISTENCY WITH CDPH GUIDANCE
WHICH STATES THERE MIGHT BE
EVIDENCE OF CONSULTATION WITH
PAPER PARENT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU I'M THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOODAFTERNOON MY
NAME IS SAM KATZ BERG AND I AM
A KINDERGARTEN TEACHER AND BOTH
THE PRESIDENT OF THE SAN RAMON
VALLEY EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
TO START OFF BY. YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION IN THE FRONT OFFICE.
ONE THING THAT REALLY RESONATED
WITH ME AND- THE RIGHT. ARMS I
KNOW THAT WITHIN THE CAN YOU
THERE A LOT OF MEASURE AND
PEOPLE EXTRA WITH THE FACT THAT
THEY WANT TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
THE ONLY QUESTION ISN'T
FAITHFUL HAMMER MODEL WE OPENED
UP OUR SCHOOLS. WE HAD SOME
SMALL COHORT I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS A SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS FEDERAL TRADE CENTER
CAMPUS WHEN HE ENTERED INTO THE
PURPLE HERE ON NOVEMBER
SEVENTEENTH. ONE CLASS. IN THE
SCHOOL WITH KOPET IN A BAR-
EMPLOYEE. WHERE CONTRACTED
CALLED IN A COUPLE STUDENTS WHO
IS WELL. IN A DAY THE FAMILY OF
THE- IT IT MIGHT. COME IN THE
PROPOSED HERE AND THE FACT THAT
WE SPREAD THE VIRUS IS IT
REALLY CHALLENGING SO I'M
ASKING YOU. TO PRIORITIZE OUR
SAFETY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE AS EDUCATORS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH OUR
STUDENTS IN THE REALLY FAITH
MANNER. AND THEY KNOW THAT
THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT AFTER ONE CALL. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRWOMAN LATE AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MAY MY IS GREG
SHUSTER THE MEDAL HISTORY
TEACHER AS WELL AS PRESIDENT OF
THE ANAHEIM SECONDARY TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE AND I MEAN
UNITED SCHOOL DISTRICT- IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION SHOULD ONLY
RESUME WHEN IT IS SAFE E
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR HEARING
OUR CALL FOR SAFETY STANDARDS
AND TRANSPARENCY. BUT MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE OUR EDUCATORS
WOULD LOVE NOTHING BETTER THAN
TO BE BACK IN THE CLASSROOM BUT
UNDER PURPLE TIER
CLASSIFICATION IS NOT THE TIME
TO STOP THE SPREAD TO MAKE
SCHOOLS TRULY SAFE WE MUST KEEP
STUDENTS AND STAFF IN REMOTE
LEARNING UNTIL COMMUNITY
CONDITIONS ARE BETTER WE MUST
MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION WHEN
IT COMES TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. BY ANAHEIM HAS%
REMAINED IN THE DISTANCE
LEARNING MODEL AND ONLY SMALL
GROUPS OF EMPLOYEES INCLUDING
FOOD SERVICE WORKERS HAVE BEEN
ON OUR CAMPUSES ARE TWENTY
CAMPUSES WE'VE STILL HAD MORE
THAN FIFTY CONFIRMS KOBE CASES
AMONG EMPLOYEES WHO WERE
PRESENT AT WORK SITES DURING
THEIR INSPECTION. JEFF AND
THANKSGIVING WE ALSO LOCK LINDA
HAN NOT OUR BELOVED LUNCH LADY
AT JEFFERSON ELEMENTARY TO COPE
WITH THIS FALL THE SPREAD
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY MAKES IT
TOO DANGEROUS FOR LARGE NUMBERS
TO BE PRESENT ON OUR CAMPUSES
NOW OR IN THE NEAR FUTURE
FUNDING SHOULD BE FOCUSED BY
DISTRICTS THANK YOU SIR THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT LAWLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU OVER LINE.
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO US I'M A
MOM TO A STUDENT AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTY MY SON IS IN A
TITLE ONE SCHOOL. ALLEN I THINK
WE NEED TO BE OPEN FOR ALL
STUDENTS NOT JUST THE ONES THAT
ARE OUT RENT- MY SON HAS
RESUMED AND THERE'S A STUDENT
THAT. WANTED TO KILL HIMSELF
EVERY DAY I REACHED OUT TO MY
DISTRICT. AND THE PEOPLE OF THE
TOOL FOR THE SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS MENTALLY BUT THEY
DON'T IMPLEMENTED IN CLASS
THEY'RE VERY BUSY TEACHING- I
THINK THAT YOU GUYS JUST NEED
TO BE FOCUSING A LOT MORE ALSO
ON THE MENTAL HEALTH IF YOU
GUYS ARE GOING TO RE OPEN THE
SCHOOLS FOR EVERYBODY. THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOMETHINGMORE DONE
SO. THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO
ME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALL PLEASE. YOUR WANT THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE SURE CAN. I THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
LISA MARKO CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES I'M BAFFLED
PROFESSIONAL AT COALITION AND
BECAUSE- WE ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE AFTER OPEN UP SCHOOL
STRONG. HOWEVER SCHOOLS AREN'T
DOING THE BARE MINIMUM FOR
HIGHEST NEED KIDS NINETEENTH
AND WE NEED ACTION SH THE
PRESENTATION TODAY WE PROVIDE
HIGH NEED KIDS MAY STILL
RECEIVE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
REGARDLESS INSPECTION RIGHT. I
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE AT YOU
TALKING TO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
SH EARLY ON IN THE PANDEMIC
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ALLOCATED EXTRA
FUNDING TO ENSURE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF STUDENTS WITH
A. DISABILITIES IP'S. RIGHT NOW
YOU AT HE WE HAVEN'T SEEN MONEY
OUT. CLEARLY ALLOCATED IN OUR
L. AND A LOT TEN MONTHS OUR
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSE THESE KIDS
ARE THE BACK BACK MAJORITY OF
THEM ARE NOT SEARCHED- YOU TO
DEVELOP A ROLE SYSTEM OF
ACCOUNTING EACH TO ENSURE THE
FUNDING I ALL BEEN HERE. ISSUES
CROP. BUT I CAN'T GET INTO
COURTS CRIME TO THEM IDEA. NEXT
CALL PLEASE THANK MA'AM OUR
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY ONE
EIGHT GO OUT. UNLADEN COMMITTEE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER AND CITIZEN.
ANXIETY AND FEAR CAN DRIVE
POWER. RESEARCH IN PERSON AND
IN STATE AT THE STATE TODAY BY
OUR BY OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER I'M WILLING TO ALLOW
CRITICAL DISTANCING AMHERST
MASS HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
MANY DISTRICTS ACROSS OUR
NATION THIS MODEL MUST BE
IMPLEMENTED IN ALL CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS SHE K. THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE NOTESTING IN
ASYMPTOMATIC HEALTHY PEOPLE IS
NECESSARY. ONE HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL TWO WEEKS AS LONG AS
YOU CAN ATTY CASES ARE NOT HIGH
IN THE INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL EACH
SCHOOL CAN THEN DECIDE IF
CONTINUED MAC WEARING NEEDS TO
BE ENFORCED IN THE SCHOOL OR IF
YOU CAN BECOME A VOLUNTARY.
SITUATION ANOTHER TWO WEEKS YES
IT LOOKS. FURTHERMORE THE CODEX
TEAMS DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
CANNELLA STATE BACK ACTUALLY
THE FROM GETTING COLD AND OR-
THIS EXPERIMENT INJECTION
SHOULD NOT UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES. ANYONE NOR
CONDITION FOR SCHOOLS WILL.
ANYONE TAKING THIS AFTER TIME
THE CENTER AND AN EX. A
COMPROMISE THANK YOU MA'AM
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
TIME. THANK YOU I ONE THREE
WEEKS AGO AT. HELLO MY NAME IS
PETER AND I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR
CHILDREN CHIU THAT HAVE
DISABILITIES WHETHER TURNED.
OUT ACTION INJURED AND THAT ONE
OF MY DAUGHTERS IS IN THE CHART
CHARTER SCHOOL SO I HAVE-
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT FIRST OF ALL I
DO NOT AGREE WITH THAT OR. THE
REGULAR TRASH. IN THE- OR HELP
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE IS A
HUGE WE OF MONEY. SHE AND- I
ADD NOT HOLD THAT MY DIRECTION
SHOULD. PUT INTO. FOR THAT.
BEEN HERE QUITE ZERO TWO POINT
TWO ALL- WHICH IS WHAT. IS ALL
THAT CAN. HAVE BEEN SHOWN AS
FAR AS THAT'S. ZERO READ DEATH
SHE THIRTEEN SHE- AND EVEN
THOUGH I NOTICED AT ISSUE. THE
REALLY ARE NOT HIGHER. ALL OKAY.
DIDN'T DISCLOSE ALSO THAT- THE
LACK OF MINORITIES ON THE
TRIALS. THAT YOU CAN CONVINCE
MINORITY POPULAR TO GET THAT'S
THAT. AND LET THE RECORDS IN
THE TRIAL OTHERWISE YOU'RE
GOING TO FEEL LIKE THEIR GUINEA
PIGS AND UNDERSTANDABLY SO
THANK THANK YOU MA'AM WE. HAVE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
RIGHT FOR THREE TO GOING. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SO THAT
SOMEONE OF MANY MEDICAL WORKERS
WHO DO NOT WANT THE SHOT. 65%
AT 65% OF MY CO WORKERS ARE
OPTING OUT OF USING PATIENTS
ALL LAST YEAR MY RISK ANALYSIS
FOR MYSELF SAYS IT'S NOT WORTH
IT. NOT MANY BUT SHALL GET THE
SHOT EITHER. CALIFORNIANS ARE
NOT INCLUSIONS FOR THE STATE.
OTHER TEACHERS OR STUDENTS ARE
PROPERTY OF THE STATE.
OWNERSHIP OVER ONE'S OWN BODY
AS A HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE THAT
CANNOT BE OVERLOOKED I'D HATE
TO RETURN TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. NOR OUT OF FEAR OF
THE VIRUS. CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR VACCINATION
IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM CREATING
ARBITRARY CONDITIONS ON LIGHT
MAKING BACK SEEMS MANDATORY.
FOR SCHOOL FOR EARNING A
LIVING. I'M SORRY NOT YOUR TO
INJECT THAT YOUR WILL. HUMAN
OPEN UP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
VERY NINE PLEASE CALL. HI MY
NAME IS LAURIE THE NINE AN
EDUCATOR WITH A MASTER'S DEGREE
EDUCATION AND I HAVE A FIVE
MARGINAL AT EIGHT. AND THEN
DOLLARS USD. THAT STUDENTS
NEEDED COVER MY THAT AND TO GO
BACK TO SCHOOL YOU THOUGH IT'S
NOT APPROVED FOR AND SIX. BUT
EVEN IF IT IS APPROVED ON I DO
NOT KNOW THE LONG EFFECT OF ACT
COULD WHICH ARE TO MARKET.
UNIVERSITY OF MIAMI STARTING
FACT OF THE FACT ON TRILLION.
SOME WE DO NOT WHAT GOT LONG
TERM ACT AND WE WILL NOT KNOW
THAT FOR YEARS. THE ALREADY
OFFERING. HOME HOPPING IT EVEN
WORSE BY THAT CITED BY ALONG
TERM THEY'VE- YOU CAN HELP IN
THE CALL COUNSELOR IF YOU COULD
GET AN EXTRA VACCINE THEIR
CHILD WHEN THE RISK OF FROM
CARBON WITH MINIMAL THEM HELLO
TERM FROM THE- BACK THING ARE
NOT KNOWN AND WILL BE NO FOR
YEARS. IT'S JUST SOMETHING OF A
FABRIC THE BAD. PLEASE. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LEVINE SAID
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND TALK
ABOUT VACCINES ANYWAY SINCE YOU
GUYS ARE STARTING LAW YOU
LEGISLATORS ARE. CATEGORIZING
PEOPLE WHO ARE ANTI VACCINE AS
TERRORISTS. AND IT'S A
DISTURBING TREND THAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE STATE
ESPECIALLY COOPER WHEN YOU'RE
LEGISLATORS OUT THERE IT'S
DISGRACEFUL. BY THE WAY WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO KEEP OUR YOU
WANT CHAIR IS ON TERRORISM.
YOUR CHILD IS INJURED BY A
VACCINE IN THE STATE REQUIRES
YOU TO GET A VACCINE IN ORDER
TO GO TO SCHOOL THAT'S
TERRORISM THAT'S ONE OF THE
WORST THINGS YOU COULD THINK OF
TO FORTUNATE MY KID. TO GET
SOMETHING THAT WAS INJURED HIM.
OR HER. IN ORDER TO BEAT UP
PARTICIPATING IN THIS GREAT
SOCIETY WE HAVE. IT'S A JOKE
YOU CAN OUTRAGE AND- YOU KNOW
IT'S ABOUT SCHOOL BECAUSE WE
YOU GUYS KEEP TALKING ABOUT WE
NEED THE OF THE VACCINE TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN WILL GAIN WEIGHT
FOR THE VACCINE WHEN THAT
HAPPENS IT'S ALL EXPERIMENTAL
STUFF. ALL EXPERIMENTS AND
WE'RE PARTY EXPERIMENT I WILL
NOT BE PUTTING MY KIDS DOING
EXPLORER MAKE YOU SERVE YOUR
TIME IS UP YOUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. JUST
ANOTHER DAY WORKING IN THE
OFFICE OF STATE. IT'S GOT A
LITTLE GUY LISTINGS DOING HAS
WEAKENED BUSINESS AS USUAL.
TODAY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
MANDATORY TESTING QUOTA ON THE
CHILDREN BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WITHOUT TESTING THERE'S NO
PANDEMIC YEAH YOU'RE GONNA
EXPERIMENTS THE VACCINE ON THE
CHILDREN. THIS IS A CALL TO
ACTION AMERICA STATE WANTS YOU
DEAD. IT'S BEING ARE AFTER YOUR
CHILDREN U. GOVERNMENT IS
PROTECTED FROM LIABILITY UNDER
THE PRESS ACT BAXEEN VICTIMS
ARE GETTING PERMANENTLY DAMAGED
AND DYING. THIS GOVERNMENT IS
GETTING AWAY WITH MURDER
LEGALIZED AND MANDATED IN THE
NAME OF HEALTH AND SAFETY.
AMERICA WILL YOU SACRIFICE YOUR
CHILD IN THE STATE SENATE
RESUMES THANK YOU SIR YOUR TIME
IS UP NEXT. AND. THANK YOU I
WON TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HI CAN YOU HEAR ME WE SURE
CAN YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI
I LIKE HOW DARE YOU. OUR MARKET
MANDATE- EVAC HE THINKS
CHILDREN AND TEACHERS CAN GO
BACK TO SCHOOL AND RESTORED Y.
ON A VACCINATION THAT HAS NOT
HAD LONG TERM STUDY THAT HAVE
NOT- THERE HAS ALREADY BEEN
OVER THREE THOUSAND ADVERSE
AFFECTS YOUR OPINIONS OUT SHE
AND THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION HAVE BOTH STATED.
THAT HE WILL NOT STOP ME I WILL
KNOW STOP- YOU FROM ACTUALLY
GETTING CALLED THE NINETEEN HOW
DARE YOU ARCHIE FLY AND OUR
EDUCATORS LIKE HOW DARE YOU
THANK YOU MAY HERE TO IS A- I
WILL JUST RE ALL THE OTHER
CALLER- THIS IS ABOUT VACCINE
IT'S NOT ABOUT ME I VACCINES
IT'S ABOUT OPENING OUR SCHOOLS
NEXT CALL PLEASE. THANK YOU I
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY IS ELIZABETH AND I
A TEACHER LIVE AND ABOUT THE
YOU'D SCHOOL DISTRICT IN HER
INSTRUCTION THREE ONLY WHEN IT
THEY- YOU ARE LISTENING TO CALL
CHRIS STANDARDS AND TRY. BUT WE
HAVE TO DO MORE WELL WE EDUCATE
WOULD LOVE TO BE BACK ON CAMP
THE PER HERE IS NOT STATE. BOTH
TRIED TO MAKE CALLS THANK FOR
EVERY STUDENTS STAFF SHOULD
REMAIN REMOTE LEARNING AND HELP.
CONDITION ARE BETTER LOOKING AT
COUNTY WIDE IS NOT EQUITABLE
THE MEDIA COMMUNITY THAT MIGHT
HAVE CONSISTED HAD HIGH NUMBER
EVEN THOUGH ARE UP WE WENT TO
MUNITY I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
MITIGATE THEIR NUMBER MOVING
OUR COUNTY AND THEREFORE
DISTRICT IN THE STATE FOR TWO
YEARS. ONE OF MY FORMER TITLE
ONE STUDENTS JUST LOST THEIR
PARENTS TO COPE IT ON DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST WE MUST WORK TO
MINIMIZE THE SPREAD IN OUR
NEEDIEST COMMUNITIES BEFORE WE
WILL OPEN DISTRICT. WE MUST
FIGHT TO KEEP ALL OUR STUDENTS
SAFE WE RETURN THE CALL SHOULD
ONLY HAPPEN WHEN IT IS SAFE FOR
EVERYONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD OR NEXT LINE. RIGHT FOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND EIGHT
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT LINE. BY ONE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE SURE CAN. HI THIS IS
MIKE FROM SONOMA COUNTY I WANT
TO THANK YOU SENATORS TODAY FOR
TAKING ALL THESE CALLS AND
LISTENING TO ALL THE CONCERNS I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
VACCINATION PROGRAM ALSO. BEING
AN EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION
THIS VACCINATION PROGRAM THAT'S
CURRENTLY GOING ON HAS NOT GONE
THROUGH THE NORMAL FTA.
AUTHORIZATION AND THIS
VACCINATION THAT THAT THEY ARE
CURRENTLY USING DOES NOT STOP
TRANSMISSION. AND IT DOES NOT
STOP ANYONE FROM GETTING THE
VACCINE. THE CONCERN ABOUT THIS
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHO IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO
BE RIGHT RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY
INJURIES BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THE NATION'S AND I'D ALSO LIKE
TO KNOW WHO AND- WHO IN THE
COUNTY. IN CALIFORNIA IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH FOR CHILDREN AND NOW WE
WILL BE ADDRESSING THE MENTAL
HEALTH MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU CENTERS FOR YOUR TIME I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU SIR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
WANT FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS.
BRITTANY CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR BILINGUAL EDUCATION
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER. TO
PROVIDE FOR TO OFFER IN
INSTRUCTION FOR YOUNGER
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS WITH HIGH
NEED. ALL BE INCLUDED IN THE
COLD WAR. ENOUGH BY POINT. YOU
KNOW LIKE. HOME AFTER YOU HAVE
SPECIAL NEEDS TO ARE NOT WELL
SERVED BY HIS LEARNING. THANK
DISTANT. YEAH. FOR FURTHER ALL.
PLEASE CLICK. THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THE- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE. THE PARKING
WHICH HAVING EIGHT DIFFICULT HI
BY GRADER TRYING TO THE FATE.
WHAT CUT SHORT WHEN PEOPLE
BEGAN THEY HOW DID YOU THE
FINISH LINE THE COMPANY OUT THE
BACK FOR HER REALLY CHALLENGING
FOR EACH I CAN BENEFIT. IN THE
PHILIPPINES YOUR THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE THAT I'M LIKE MY TO
TELL. THEIR STRUGGLE. FINDING
IT NOT ONLY. ARE FOR- READY WE
THINK THAT THEY AND THEY IT FOR
EVERYBODY BUT WE NEED FOR THOSE
THAT ARE READY AND THAT. BY THE
GOVERNOR TO NOT SO ENOUGH I AM
ENCOURAGE THAT YOU. THE OF
LEARNING I THANK YOU FOR TOP
FOUR HUNDRED MA'AM THE HAD AND
I AM THAT YOU CAN TO WORK IT
PROVIDES. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMORY PREACHER YOUR CALL TODAY
THANK YOU. I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CARISSA
CARRERA AND I REPRESENT THE
EDUCATORS IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION SHOULD
ONLY RESUME ONE OF THE STATE WE
APPRECIATE WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS
DOING HERE IN OUR CALL FOR
SAFETY STANDARDS AND
TRANSPARENCY BUT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH RIGHT NOW WHILE ALL OF
MY EDUCATORS I REPRESENT WOULD
LOVE TO BE BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM WITH THE STUDENTS THE
PURPLE CARE IS NOT SAFE FOR US
RIGHT NOW TO RE OPEN. TO STOP
THE SPREAD AND MAKE SCHOOLS
TRULY SAFE WE HAVE TO KEEP
STUDENTS ND STAFF IN REMOTE
LEARNING UNTIL COMMUNITY
CONDITIONS ARE BETTER AN ARM
COMMUNITY CASES CONTINUE TO
RISE STUDENTS ARE DALY TELLING
THEIR TEACHERS ABOUT POSITIVE
CASES AND DEATHS AND THEIR
FAMILIES MULTI GENERATIONAL
HOUSEHOLDS ARE COMMON IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND TIED WITH AN
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
IT IS NOT SAFE FOR US TO REOPEN
EVEN WITH A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
OUR SCHOOL CAN RESUME AND
INSTRUCTION WHAT IT IS
COMPLETELY SAFE TO DO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
CURRY AT THE GREAT OF YOUR CAR
WE'RE JUST ALL CALLERS WHO ARE
CALLING IN TODAY WE HAVE ABOUT
MINUTE FOR EACH AND COLOR NOT
AT ALL TRYING TO CUT YOU OFF
BUT JUST TRY TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT ONE MINUTE MADAM
OPERATOR THAT'S GOOD OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU VERY ONE.
THREE IS GOING. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS TERRA AND I'M PARENT
OF TWO IN L. A. U. S. B. THE
TEACHER UNION NOT HAVE AN TO GO
BACK IN PERSON AT YEAR THEY ARE
ASKING FOR A RE- OPENING WHEN
IT IS QUITE UNQUOTE FACED A
HOPE DAY METRO. INSTEAD WE
SHOULD BE LISTENING THE X.
FOLLOWING THE CLIENT WHICH SHOW
THAT COURT HAD NOT BEEN MAJOR
THE- AND THEY CAN AND SHOULD BE
REAL FOR EVERY. BUT HE
CALIBRATE CHILDREN BETWEEN THE
TWO POINT ONE SEVEN ACROSS
FORTY STATE AND YET WE'RE GOING
CHILL AND IN AT BROKE THAT
COULD ADVERSELY NO RISK TO THEM
ACCORDING TO COURT THERE ARE BY
CALLS A DAY CAL. VERSUS TEACH
DUE TO WITH HER CHILDREN BY
CONTRAST MENTAL AND I COULD I
TOLD CLOSER HOW TO TAKE. ON THE
BE REALLY. AND. I DON'T WANT TO
SPEND THEIR TO CAN ALL OUT YOU
NEED TO THAT CONSIDER THIS AND
THOUGHT SHE AND WHO WANT- OF
ACTUALLY PRIOR TO RETURN- NEED
TO COMMIT TO RETURN IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE THAT THANK YOU SIR AND
YOUR- THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
JUST TAKE A QUICK GIVE US
THIRTY. FURNITURE TO MICHAEL
HERE JUST ONE MOMENT. SORRY
ABOUT THAT WE DID HAVE TO
CHANGE MICROPHONES ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MADAM OPERATORS. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONCE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THE- STATE THAT CAME OUT
DATE FROM NCAA T. T. DAY. AT
THE THAT I NEED 24% OF ALL OF
THE U. S. THE COURT PROVIDE
ONLY ON LAW. LEARNING THIS
MEANS THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF.
DISTRICTS THAT WE COULD LEARN.
HELLO ALSO HAS MANY HI SCHOOL
THAT HAVE OPEN WHY ARE WE NOT
LET FROM THESE. AND THEIR
INFORMATION AS TO HOW THEY ARE
OPENING THEY HAVE NOT WITH EACH
CHAT. WHICH HAS WITH THE
MICHAEL QUESTION. AND THEY ARE.
BUT THEY ARE OPEN AND ARE
CONTRACTING AND. ADAM OPERATOR.
THANK YOU ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
LEYVA AND CENTER MY NAME IS LI
ATTY I AM A TEACHER OF AMERICAN
HISTORY IN THE MENIFEE UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE MENIFEE
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION THANK YOU
FOR THIS HEARING- I WOULD LOVE
TO BE WITH MY STUDENTS IN MY
CLASSROOM. THE CODE RATES ARE
RISING MONTHS BEFORE WE SEE THE
EFFECTS OF THE VACCINE ON THOSE
NUMBERS THIS PROPOSAL IS
UNREASONABLE AND ON LIFE. JUST
LAST WEEK TO FRIENDS LOST
PARENTS TO THIS PANDEMIC YOUR
STUDENTS ARE AT A LOWER RISK
THE OLDER FAMILY MEMBERS IN
THEIR LIVES ARE AT A HIGHER
RISK I CAN'T IMAGINE THE TRAUMA
ON OUR STUDENTS COMMUNITY IF
THEY SUSPECTED THEY HAD CAUGHT
IT AT SCHOOL AND TRANSMITTED IT
TO THEIR LOVED ONES. MY
STUDENTS ARE SCARED FOR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THE VERY REAL SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL ISSUES THAT TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS ARE FACING BUT WE
CAN ONLY BE TOGETHER SCHOOL IS
SAFE FOR ALL IN THIS PROPOSAL
DOESN'T CHANGE THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER EDDIE WE'RE
GOING TO GO. TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MADAM OPERATOR. THANK YOU I
WANT THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SENATE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CINDY AND I
REPRESENT A FACEBOOK GROUP
CALLED REOPEN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS THAT REPRESENT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PARENTS STATEWIDE.
I PERSONALLY HAVE FOUR BOYS ARE
GOING TO HIGH GRADE SCHOOL
MODEL AT THE WORKING PARENT MY
KIDS GO TO CHILD CARE AND THE
YMCA WHEN THEY'RE NOT IN SCHOOL
THIS BEGS THE QUESTION WHY THE
CHILD CARE AND THE YMCA CAN BE
FULLY OPEN. YET BUT PUBLIC
SCHOOL CANNOT TRANSMISSION OF
CODE THAT TWO. ADULTS IT'S
EXTREMELY WHERE AND WE'VE SEEN
HIGHER LEVEL OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND SUICIDE THAT. YEAH
AMONG CALL THE KIDS KIDS ARE
SUFFERING AND THEY'RE DROPPING
THEIR GRADES AND PARENTS ARE
WITHDRAWING THEIR KIDS TO GO TO
HOME SCHOOL SENDING THEIR KIDS
TO PRIVATE SCHOOLS. AND EVEN
MOVING OUT OF STATE THERE WILL
BE A MASS ACCIDENTS FROM PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IF YOU DO NOT BE
TRINKETS AND CLASSROOM
INSTRUCTION. THANK YOU. YOUR
PHONE CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU BRING THE MOTHER OF
THE SEVENTH GRADER AND I
STUDIED THE DATA THAT IS
PROVIDED BY CDPH IN THE
BLUEPRINT THAT THEY SHOULD
EVERY TUESDAY. NIGHT REOPENING
SCHOOLS WITHIN THE SCHOOL FOR
ALL PLAN IS ENTIRELY PREDICATED
ON THE OBJECTIVE CASE RATE
REACHING TWENTY FIVE HOWEVER
THE CDPH CARE THREE METHODOLOGY
THAT PRODUCES THE ADJUSTED CARE
TRADED ONE WEEK BY WEEK THE
ADJUSTED CARE TRADE DRESS CLOSE
TO AND FAR AWAY FROM THE
BROUGHT ACTUAL KIDS RATE.
BECAUSE OF THE METHODOLOGY IN
OTHER WORDS THE DELTA BETWEEN
THE OBJECTIVE CARE TRAY AND THE
ROCKETS RIGHT VERY DRASTICALLY
FROM WEEK TO WEEK. BECAUSE THE
ADJUSTMENT FACTORS BASED ON A
STATE TESTING MEDIAN THAT
CALCULATED ONLY ONCE PER MONTH
I CANNOT EXPLAIN FULLY IN
DETAIL IN ONE MINUTE BUT I'VE
SENT A DETAILED EXPLANATION TO
SENATOR GLAZERS OFFICE. AND I
WILL ALSO SHARE THIS WITH THE
COMMITTEE VIA EMAIL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE
YOU SHARING THAT INFORMATION WE
LOOK FORWARD TO IT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY
THAT'S. GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR ONCE FOUR
PLEASE CALL. GOOD AFTERNOON
CRISTINA MARCELLO ON BEHALF OF
THE SMALL WHAT IS YOUR BIRTHDAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE POP
OF THE QUESTION DAY AND A
SPECIAL THANKS TO SENATOR
MCGUIRE ALREADY SHEDDING LIGHT
ON SOME OF THE IN DURING A
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES THAT SMALL
AND RURAL DISTRICT THAT HAD TO
TACKLE THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC.
I ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ACCENT THAT
THAT THAT AND WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO ADD THAT WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE BASE FUNDING IN
THE PLAN FOR THE STATE MALIKOV
WITH. A NINETY DAY THANK YOU
ARE ADA WITHOUT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE STATE SMALLER
SCHOOL DISTRICT DISTRICT
STATUTORILY DEFINED IN THE LAW
ARE WE ON THE FINAL PROPOSAL
INCLUDING ADEQUATE LEVEL BUT
BASS FUNDING FOR ALL SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS HAVE BEEN
NOTED THESE DISTRICTS ADAMANT
COST PRESSURES ON THE
TECHNOLOGICAL HELP THE PERSON
OUT FRONT. AND I DON'T HAVE IT
DIDN'T COUNTY GENERATE ADEQUATE
FUNDING AMOUNT USING EIGHTY
EIGHT SEVERAL OF THE DISTRICTS
ARE GOING TO RECEIVE ANY
FEDERAL FUNDING BASED ON TITLE
ONE ALLOCATIONS FOR THE FISCAL
SITUATION IS PRECARIOUS AND ANY
ADDITIONAL WRECK RECOGNITION
AND ADDED THAT THE JUDGE FROM
THE STATE WILL BE CRUCIAL IN
PAVING THE WAY FOR A STATE
RETURNED IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
PROCEEDINGS CRISTINA THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. WE
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR HANGING WITH US TODAY AND
THAT'S. GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MINIMAL FREIGHTER. THANK YOU
RIGHT AWAY SIXTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KATE AND I
AM HI STUDENT ARE SCHOOLS NEED
TO OPEN NOT HAS OR VACCINE
THERE WAS AN ISSUE SPIKE IN THE-
LAST YEAR ACCORDING TO THE CDC
EVENAFTER I DIDN'T COPE WITH
THAT. I COULDN'T ARE MENTAL
HEALTH. OPEN OUR SCHOOL LEADERS
BACK TO SCHOOL I'VE BEEN
TRAVELING TO OTHER STATES TO
PLACE WORK AND MANY. OTHER
THINGS. OPENERS AND OPEN OUR
SCHOOLS PLEASE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER MADAM
OPERATOR. THANK YOU I WON SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I
KNOW WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
DISCUSSING VACCINES BUT WITH
ALL THE ANTI VACCINE
SENTIMENTS- EXPRESSED ON A CALL
I'D LIKE TO. PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR MANDATORY VACCINATIONS.
FROM THERE IS OBVIOUSLY NO RISK
FREE VACCINE BUT THE RISKS ARE.
OUR OUR SMALLER WHEN THE
BENEFIT TO SOCIETY AS A WHOLE-
I COURTS FULLY MANDATORY
VACCINATIONS. FOR KOBE ONCE
THEY ARE APPROVED FOR STUDENT.
THANK YOU. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MADAM OPERATOR.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CARLOS
MACHADO LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
WITH CALPERS SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU FOR THAT
HEARING IN THE PROPER
DISCUSSION ANY OPTION TO SHARE
THE CONCERNS OF OUR MEMBERS TO
SIT ON THE GOVERNING BOARDS OF
THE NEARLY ONE THOUSAND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION THE STATE. OUR
MEMBERS ARE EAGER FOR A RETURN
TO CHANGE IN IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. HI THAT IS BOTH
SAFE FOR STUDENTS AND STAFF
ALIKE. I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE I
AM PUT ON A COUPLE OF AREAS
RELATED TO THE PLAN. THE TIGHT
TIMELINES AND DEADLINES UNDER
THE PROPOSED PLAN. WILL MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR MANY DISTRICTS TO
COMPETE- COMPLETE THE
POTENTIALLY COMPLEX COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING DISCUSSIONS NEEDED
TO PARTICIPATE- WE URGE THE
ALIGNMENT OF THE PLANNED WITH
THIS CD P. H. GUIDANCE
REGARDING CONSULTATION WITH
LABOUR. PARENT MEDIA
ORGANIZATIONS. WE ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE CONCERN COMING
BOARDS WITH THE HIGHER RISK OF
KOBE'S LIABILITY EXPOSURE. AT
SCHOOL SPACE WITH THE RETURN TO
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION THANK YOU
SO MUCH CARLOS KNEW THAT. WERE
REALLY GRATEFUL WE'RE GONNA GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER APOLOGIZE
NOT THAT CARLOS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CALLING IN IN FOR
HANGING WITH. US LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU I DON'T WANT SEVEN PLEASE
GO. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THAT'S
ME MY NAME'S MATT FROM SAN
MATTEO COUNTY. I'M A CTA MEMBER
AND STATE REPRESENTATIVE
ALTHOUGH I'M NOT SPEAKING ON
THEIR BEHALF. AS YOU WORK TO
CREATE THIS BILL. PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU MAINTAIN THE
MEDICAL STANDARD OF INFORMED
CONSENT WHEN IT COMES TO-
MENTAL MEDICATION DO NOT FORCE
PEOPLE TO TAKE A VACCINE WHEN
IT'S IN ITS EXPERIMENTAL STAGES
I CANNOT TAKE A VACCINE DUE TO
MEDICAL CONDITIONS DON'T TAKE
AWAY MY RIGHT TO WORK. THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION HAS
DETERMINED THAT THE EFFECTS OF
THE LOCKDOWN IS MUCH WORSE THAN
THE VIRUS. TESTING AND P. P. E.
R. SUFFICIENT TO DETERMINE
SAFETY. THE PCR TEST SHOULD NOT
BE USED TO DETECT CASES IF IT
IS USED THE TEST RESULTS MUST
INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF CYCLES
NEEDED TO OBTAIN A POSITIVE
RESULT THIS IS THE ONLY WAY TO
DETERMINE IF POTS. POSITIVE
TEST RESULTS ARE RELIABLE MORE
THAN TWENTY FIVE CYCLES WERE
NEEDED TO DETECT THE VIRUS SO
MUCH AHEADWE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER ID MAD THINGS ARE
CALLING IN FROM BEAUTIFUL SAN
MATTEO COUNTY WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE GOING TO OUR NEXT CALLER
MINIMAL FREIGHTER. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE SEVENTY THREE
YEAR AND COMMITTEE. BUT. HELLO
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE AND GO RIGHT AHEAD
OKAY. HELLO HI. RIGHT I AM
PREGNANT THANK YOU YOUR HIGH
SENIOR HIGH SCHOOL IT'S COOL-
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME PROVIDE. THANK RIGHT CAUGHT
IT DURING HIS PUBLIC HEARINGS I
AM NOT. I REPEAT INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PROGRAM. KIND OF A
SUPPORT ANY IP EQUITY A ONE ON
ONE FACT THAT THE CLASSROOM IT
DIDN'T PAY IN MY SCHOOL
COMMITTEE I WORRY ABOUT MY
FELLOW STUDENTS WERE EXPECTING
ME I THINK ANYONE BUSINESS
LEARNING WE GET A PLAN. FOR
OPENING SCHOOLS. I RESPECT THE
WORK. THE FOLLOWING FOR
CONSIDERING WE ADDRESS NEEDS AS
WITH ONLY. ALLOCATED ONE BEING
IN THE WHITE. STATE CENTURY. IS
TO THE NOT RECEIVE ANY ARMY.
HEALTH SERVICE. DURING CLOTHES
AND ADDRESS IT CONSISTENTLY OF
SUPPORTING RESOURCES ACROSS THE
OPEN. IT. IN PERSON ASSESSMENT
AND SERVICES. THANK YOU AND
IMPACT THAT IS BUT THE VERY AND
CONTINUE BUSINESS LEARNING
ANALYTICAL WE'LL IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU HEY NICE JOB THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN FROM
LOS ANGELES TODAY WERE REALLY
GRATEFUL VERY ELOQUENT- AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR COMING
TODAY MADAM OPERATOR AT LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME
IS LIBERTY AND I WOULD LIKE TO
INFORM EVERYONE THE DIFFICULT
BIT NINETEEN INJECTION CROSSED
INTO THE BIO WEAPON CATEGORY.
WITH THE SYNTHETIC NUCLEIC ACID
ENVELOPE INTO A LIPID ENVELOPE.
IT DOES NOT OFFER IMMUNITY NOR
STOP THE SPREAD OF THE DISEASE.
THEREFORE IT IS IN VIOLATION OF
THE FTCACT FIFTEEN US CODE.
THE CRASH FORTY ONE TO
ADVERTISE A PRODUCT OR SERVICE
CAN PREVENT TREAT OR CURE HUMAN
DISEASE UNLESS YOU OF THE
STATUS CONFIDANT RELIABLE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE INCLUDING
BUT APPROPRIATE WHILE
CONTROLLED HUMAN CLINICAL
STUDIES. THANK THAT THE CLAIMS
TRUE AT THE TIME OF THEY ARE
MADE. IT DIDN'T HAPPEN MEEDER.
OR PFIZER'S ALLERGIES ACTING
TRIAL IT HAS THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THEIR GENE THERAPY TECHNOLOGY.
HAS ANY IMPACT THANK YOU. BYE
BYE- INFECTION VERY GREAT.
TODAY THANK YOU. THEY BYE ALL
RIGHT IT'S TO OUR CALLER. THANK
YOU THE LAST HAVING Q. WHICH
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT A ONE SEVEN NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I HAVE A
DIFFERENT ONE THAT POPPED INTO
Q. ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE FIFTY SEVEN IS THAT
ME YES IT IS YOUR COMMITTEE
GOOD AFTERNOON GO RIGHT AHEAD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M WATCHING
THE SCREEN AND NO ONE SEEMS TO
BE THERE IT CAN LAST. ME LEYVA
LAST CORTES THE LAST I DON'T
EVEN SEE ANYONE ON THE SCREEN.
I SPEAKING WELL. IT'S GOOD TO
HEAR YOU AGAIN THIS IS A MIKE
MCGUIRE. YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE.
YOU ARE EXCLUSIVELY DEALING
WITH COMMUNIST BANKS THESE DAYS
SO YOU'RE- IN THE VACCINE
PROGRAM AS WELL. AND THE CALL
FIRST. EVENING OUR CHILDREN.
THE CARD IS MY WINGS THE FIRST
TAKING THE CALL BANKING THESE
DAYS MY MISTAKE. THREE HUNDRED
FLATTENING THE CURVE. YOUR
CONTINUED TO ENSURE ENSURE
RECEIPT OF CARES AND OTHER
GRANT FUNDING I'M HERE TO TELL
YOU THAT WE ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN CARE OF MONEY BECAUSE MONEY
IS BLOOD MONEY IT IS A- SMALL
BUSINESSES DYING AND THE FORCED
ISOLATION OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. CHILDREN BEING
THEIR RIGHT TO. IN PERSON
EDUCATION SO CENTER FOR HEALTH
STATISTICS EMPHASIZE. WHAT
STEPS WE WOULD BUT WHICH WOULD
BE DECEMBER. RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH SURVEYS IN GERMAN THAT IS
GOING TO BE OUR FINAL CALLER OF
THE DAY AS WE WERE AT SUPPOSED
TO ADJOURN APPROXIMATELY THREE
O'CLOCK WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
AND ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT IT IS NOW IT THREE
EIGHTEEN WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO ENCOURAGE ANYONE AND
EVERYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO SUBMIT A COMMENT TO
PLEASE DO SO. TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE YOU CAN GO TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
BETTER SAID SUBMIT A COMMENT
RELATED TO TODAY'S HEARING- AND
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO ALL
OF THOSE WHO TESTIFIED TODAY IN
PROVIDED US WITH A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FACING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN RE OPENING IN THE
NEAR FUTURE WE KNOW WE KNOW
THERE'S A LOT TO DISCUSS. AND
SO MUCH MORE TO DO TO ENSURE
THAT SCHOOLS ARE ABLE TO REOPEN
SAFELY STRATEGICALLY IN FOR ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS TO HAVE THE
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT THEY NEED
AND DESERVE FINALLY I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO CHAIR LEYVA
FOR HER HARD WORK WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO CHAIR LAYERED
FROM THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR HIS HARD WORK THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS AND OF COURSE TO
ALL OF YOU WHO CALLED IN AND
TOOK THE TIME IN YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULE THIS AFTERNOON WE ARE
TRULY GRATEFUL FINALLY WE WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE BOTH
THE EDUCATION AND THE BUDGET
STAFF TEAMS WHO WORK HARD TO BE
A PUT TOGETHER THIS HEARING IN
EVERYONE WHO'S BEHIND THE
SCENES WHETHER IT'S MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO GET. THE
CALLS- INTO THE HEARING ROOM-
THAT THE LIVE STREAM IS- IS
ROLLING WE WANT TO SAY HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE PLACING GERMAN
THIS COULD THIS DISCUSSION WILL
CONTINUE. THIS HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED.